Was erlauben?
Was glaubt ihr eigentlich?
Was wird es das ganze Jahr über machen?
Eure scheiß Stimmung.
Das seid ihr doch dafür verantwortlich und liegier.
Jetzt auch bei Mobile Max.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bum Zag Return.
Und? Wer macht den ersten Rat?
Wir raten hier doch nie.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wovon Holgi redet.
Keine Ahnung.
Unklar.
Kann ich das als Klingelton haben?
Ja, wann landet man schon mal mit Hitler in einem Remix?
Das stimmt.
Hat er wieder jut gemacht.
So wirkt das Hitler wieder, wie der einzig Vernünftige wirkt.
David übertrifft sich und so. Diesmal hab ich auch ein bisschen zugearbeitet und den Holgi mal eingebracht.
Sehr gut. Applaus, Applaus, Applaus.
Ja, super. Hallo, hier ist Mobile-Max, Ausgabennummer 68.
Die 68er kommen zu euch. Ich hab so einen Hals.
Wir marschieren jetzt, wir starten den Marsch durch das System. Der hat ja letztes Mal...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also, den hatten wir hoffentlich jetzt hinter uns.
Ja, die Runde ist komplett. Wen haben wir alles da? Wir haben den Max da, hallo Max. Hallo.
Denis haben wir auch da.
Denis haben wir auch da. Ja, haben wir noch Themen?
Hey, wir waren beim letzten Mal nicht ganz fertig. Ich würde sagen, wir machen einfach genau da weiter, wo wir letztes Mal aufgehört haben.
Obwohl uns die Kräfte verlassen haben.
Obwohl Lion Feature Nummer 15 ist.
Aber du fandest doch die Sendung nicht so gut letztes Mal.
Nee, ich hab da so einen Fadenbeigeschmack. Ich fand das ein bisschen unpersönlich. Das können wir besser. Wir konnten unsere Qualitäten nicht voll ausspielen mehr im letzten Mal.
Wobei Max 67 ist unter seinen Möglichkeiten geblieben.
Wir haben das Potenzial nicht voll ausgeschöpft.
Ja, das kann natürlich alles sein.
Und denkt doch jemand mal an die Nachhaltigkeit.
Denkt doch mal jemand an die Kinder. Niemand denkt an die Kinder.
Das war aus den Simpsons, ne?
Was?
Diese...
Bitte jemand lieber an die Kinder!
Oder warum denkt denn hier niemand an die Kinder? Oder irgendwie so ein komischer Spruch war das.
Kannst du dich noch vage dran erinnern?
Also ich hab so lange schon keine Simpsons mehr geguckt.
Oder Chet möchte auch begrüßt werden. Hallo Chet.
Ach, Chet wird doch nicht begrüßt.
Was?
Jetzt gibt's hier gleich...
Ich kann dann schon gar nicht mehr zählen, wie oft die uns schon den Arsch gerettet haben, dass wir die Chance hatten, uns noch während der Sendung zu verbessern.
Ich erinnere nur an den epischen Control-Shift-Eject-Shortcut.
Also der alleine, ja?
Nein, das war nicht South Park.
Ja... naja... Hier nimmt alles auf, sieht gut aus. Ich bin gerade mal wieder im Rahmen umfangreicherer Umstellung, wie ihr euch denken könnt. Von daher...
Eine Geringfüge regieren.
Bin ich froh, dass es läuft. Ich hatte eigentlich auch vor, heute mal als erstes mal jetzt auch mal in AAC zu streamen, because of the bandwidth. Damit auch so die mobilen iPhoneys, die es geil finden, in der Straßenbahn per Internet streamen zuzuhören, eine noch bessere Chance haben. Aber es sollte irgendwie nicht sein, dass es hier irgendwie irgendwo zwischen da, wo ich sende und da, wo es eigentlich rauskommen soll, versichert es gerade noch. Aber MP3 ist am Start und von daher sind wir auch wieder live. Und ja, ein Tag früher als ursprünglich gedacht, aus Kostengründen und...
Auch wir müssen sparen.
Aus Kostengründen?
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall könnten wir ja mit ganz langweiligen News starten.
Zum Beispiel...
Ja, für unser Lieblingsthema SSD gibt es ja neues Futter, weil diese... Was denn, Max?
Share mal diese Notiz da, dieses Sim.
Achso, ja, ich share.
Wollt noch gern was dazutragen.
Ich share.
Mach mal hier Web-Share an alle.
Ich share. Wieso gibt er jetzt hier... Jetzt muss ich hier wieder... Etwas mit den scheren Händen.
Social Media-Film quasi.
Sharing is caring. So, ja, also, Mac OS X 6.8 ist rausgekommen. Ja, abgesehen davon, dass es wohl für Gamer was gebracht haben soll, was so die Grafikkarten-Power betrifft.
Echt?
Wie ist das so?
43% mehr OpenGL-Performance.
Macht keinen Scheiß, wirklich.
Angeblich.
Also mein Bitcoin-Minor war genauso schnell danach.
Ja, das hängt doch glaube ich nicht so sehr von Apple-Treibern ab, ne?
Das klingt so bewusst aus.
Nee, das ist ja OpenCL.
Ja, meine ich doch.
Schon klar.
Es redet so von GL-Performance.
Na ja, echt? Dass du wie nicht wirklich 43 Prozent Moischen ja nichts mitbekommst?
Es gab wohl einen Einbruch bei 1067, den sie jetzt wohl mehr als kompensiert haben. Ich kenne die Zahlen jetzt nicht so richtig aus, wenn ich habe nur so eine Aufstellung gesehen, Unterschied 6,7 zu 6,8 und da war es teilweise signifikant. Also sowas wie plus 40, 50 Prozent. Aber sie haben wohl auch Trim-Support eingeschaltet, jetzt für alle Geräte, wie es hieß, wie es sich Lars Apple SSDs haben.
Ach, hier in meinem anderen Rechner, da habe ich es noch gar nicht probiert.
Ach, du hast ja jetzt schon wieder den nächsten.
Sind sie immer top notch?
Kommt immer am Durchzyklen. Also mein Rechner heißt jetzt auch 10, das ist jetzt mein 10. Mac.
Ja, aber dann bist du auf 10.6.8. Dann schau mal schnell in dein System Profile.
Hab ich schon, ich musste den Trim-Enabler. Also ich hab ja hier in der Kiste eine Intel SSD, da wart nicht an.
Ah, interessant.
Bei mir auch nicht, weil ich hab ja die gleiche.
Und nachdem auf Mac-Rumors erst stand, so Trim-Support für alle, nach dem Motto, kam dann auch, glaube ich, auch auf Mac-Rumors in kürzerer Zeit ein Update, wo User reporteten, ne, die Third Party immer noch nicht, aber die Apple SSD.
Mit Einschränkungen. Weil auf meinem alten uralt 2006er Core 2 Duo iMac, wo ich eine Kruschel-SSD drin habe, Kruschel-SSD!
Kann man nicht auf Studio-Folkzeit kruscheln?
Was ist mit der? Na, die heißt jetzt Apple SSD und hat auch Trim. Also ich hab nur ein Update gemacht und jetzt wird diese Kruschel-SSD als Apple SSD bezeichnet, zumindest in der Konfiguration in dem Rechner, keine Ahnung, wie übertragbar das ist und sagt auch hier mit Trim.
Ist ja lustig.
Ich glaube, ich hab die gleiche.
Hier drinnen und mal gucken, damit gucke ich jetzt mal nach. Serial Autor.
Real SSD 300.
Genau. Serial 300. Trim-Unterstützung? Nein. Das ist ja lustig. Wobei ich bin ja, habe ja auch einen Löwen drinne. Vielleicht hat er das ja noch nicht.
Also your mileage may vary, aber irgendwie trauen sie sich jetzt wohl in ganz sanften Schritten. Ich frage mich, was sie da eigentlich reitet. Was, na irgendeinen Grund wird es ja haben. Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass sie das so eratisch...
Wenn was schief geht, dann wollen die natürlich da nicht irgendwie den Ärger übernehmen.
Ist klar, aber warum dauert es zum Beispiel auch so lange, bis sie ihre eigenen SSDs einschalten? Ich meine, ist ja nicht so das Trimmen erst letztes Jahr...
Und das ist ein Standard-Command, oder? Das ist jetzt nicht, was man wenn nur spezifisch oder so noch irgendwie implementieren müsste oder supporten müsste.
Ist irgendwann so ein nachgeschobener SATA-Command.
Und ich meine, die sind ja auch mit Intel in einem Boot. Also zumindest auf Intel-SSDs, das wäre doch irgendwie ein Knowledge-Transfer mit einer E-Mail und so. Kann halt nicht so schwer sein.
Steve, mach mal an, man muss sie ja wirklich nur einschalten.
Ja, das ist ein Rätsel.
Nee, die sind halt nicht so experimentierfreudig. Das ist ja auch nicht so, dass die irgendwie eine neue Software rausbringen.
Zumindest erachten sie dieses Feature grundsätzlich schon mal als wünschenswert.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil in ihrer eigenen SSDs schon langsam geworden sind.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich hab auch diese ganze Diskussion, wir haben das ja hier schon mal ausführlich, du hast das ja mal ausführlich dargelegt und hast uns auch dargelegt, warum man gar keinen Trim brauch. Wegen dieser Bräuchte. Ja, da stimme ich dir auch zu, allerdings habe ich vergessen, warum es jetzt auch bei Platten, die dieses automatische Garbage Collection machen, auch noch wünschenswert ist.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du verschlüsseln willst. Weil bei Full Disk Encryption keine Garbage Collection mehr funktionieren. Warum? Weil die ja nicht mehr weiß, welche Dateien was Dateien sind und was nicht, weil ja alles, jedes Bit auf der Platte verschüttelt ist.
Dateien stehen auf dem Ende eh keine Rolle.
Stell dir vor, du hast ein Virtual Image zum Beispiel auf deinem Rechner. Obwohl, ob da wieder das Trim auch funktioniert.
Ja, das ist natürlich der nächste Fall.
Aber die Full Disk Encryption von...
Moment, also Dateien sowieso nicht. Also wir reden hier nur von Block-Level. Und das Krypto ist der Block derselbe. Also der ist genauso unik wie... also ist immer noch derselbe Block.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt nicht mal richtig verstanden, wie diese garbage collection funktioniert.
Na garbage collection reserviert einen Bereich. Und wenn du einen neuen schreiben willst, dann nimmt er ihn halt sozusagen aus diesem reservierten Bereich, damit er ihn auch sofort schreiben kann.
Genau, also reserviert nicht, sondern irgendein Block, der sozusagen schon vorbereitet wurde, weil das ändert sich ja dynamisch. Das ist kein Bereich, sondern der Bereich ist dynamisch immer überall. Und dann nimmt er den. Und dadurch, dass der Block jetzt woanders geschrieben wurde, ist er die Originalstelle, wo der Block eigentlich hinten gehört. Der ist ja dann frei, weil er hat ihn ja woanders hingeschrieben. Deswegen weiß er, ok, den kann er jetzt erstmal schon mal vorlöschen, was er dann dieses Trimming ist.
Genau.
Das heißt, es aktualisiert sich nur über neu überschriebene Blöcke. Aber auch nur dadurch. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit ohne Trimmen, dass das Betriebssystem sagt, die alle kannst du jetzt auch schon mal freilegen.
Genau, weiß er nicht.
Weiß er nicht.
Weiß er nicht, was das OS nochmal braucht und was nicht.
Also es gibt bei anderen Tech, gab es halt so, also auf der Webseite so ein Test, wo sie halt irgendwie die neuesten SSDs, die halt auch selber ein bisschen aufräumen oder was auch immer tun, mit einmal Trim an und einmal Trim aus irgendwie gebenchmarkt haben, oder das war die Macworld, einer von beiden, und dabei kam dann raus, dass irgendwie das mit Trim war es ein paar Megabyte, aber wirklich wenige Megabyte die Sekunde schneller über einen längeren Schreib-Lese-Löschzyklus und ohne Trim war es dann halt ein paar Megabyte die Sekunde langsamer. Allerdings, also ich hatte zum Beispiel einen Arbeitskollegen, aber gut, der hatte auch eine Apple-SSD und man sagt ja, die können nichts, diese Toshiba SSDs, war auch eins der ersten und bei dem ist das so richtig, richtig, richtig doll langsam geworden. Also es ist schlimmer als wie mit Festplatte seinen Rechner zu benutzen. Nee, der hat halt Apple-SSD und keinen Trim an, also der hat jetzt nicht den Trim-Enabler angeworfen und so weiter. Und da wurde das so über die Zeit immer extrem langsamer und an der Kiste gesessen gegen gar nichts.
Ja, weil er ja für jeden Blog, den er schreibt, muss er erstmal irgendwie gelöscht werden und das halt irgendwie dauert ein bisschen.
Naja, also...
Aber sollte dann, wenn er irgendwie Trim einschaltet, mit der Zeit dann auch wieder besser werden. Wenn er erstmal so ein paar Files bewegt hat und der dann so ein bisschen vorlöschen könnte, dann irgendwann sollte es dann wieder gut werden. Das müssten die Leute eigentlich ziemlich eindeutig merken und das sind auch die Leute, die wissen, dass dieser Trim-Enabler wirklich funktioniert.
Aber liest man auch nicht so viel, ne? Also man liest nicht so viele Erfahrungsberichte von wegen, ja, Platte, hier SSD war langsam, dann hab ich Trim eingeschaltet.
Wird das dein Augenblicklich schneller?
Du musst ja erstmal ein paar Files irgendwie durch die Gegend schieben. Dadurch, dass, sagen wir mal, eine Datei löscht, du löscht einen 10-Gigabyte-Film von deiner Platte, dann kann halt das OS jetzt, weil das HFS irgendwie weiß, ok, er braucht jetzt diese Blöcke nicht mehr, du hast ihn ja gerade gelöscht, den Film, kann er sozusagen für alle die 10 Gigabyte von deinem Movie, kann er halt für die ganzen Blöcke Trim-Kommandos da irgendwie losballern und die...
Also eigentlich wäre das Beste, Trim einschalten, Platte formatieren, alles wieder drauf spielen.
Man könnte auch mit MK File heißen, glaube ich, das ist noch von Next Step Zeit, um Swap Files zu erzeugen. Ich glaube, das heißt MK File, bin mir jetzt nicht ganz so sicher. Könnte man sich eine 10-Gigabyte-Datei erstellen und die danach löschen und dann wird die getrimmt und dann ist schon mal super. Da hast du 10 Gigabyte vorgelöschte Sachen.
Den gesamten Plattenplatz, der überhaupt noch frei ist?
Na ja, du willst auch nicht, dass es platzt. Du solltest schon ein paar Prozente freilassen.
Vorgelöscht, das ist doch das neue als gelöscht markiert.
Trim ist eigentlich auch die einzige Möglichkeit, um explizit der Platte zu sagen, dass sie ganz konkrete, spezifische Blöcke invalidieren soll.
MK File ist das, das könnt ihr machen.
Gibt es denn eigentlich ein Command Line Tool, um über die Platte zu scannen und dann einfach die passenden Trim-Commandos zu schicken?
Da gab es ja mal so ein Tool. Irgendwie hat doch irgendwer da geschrieben, das war vor dem Trim-Enabler, glaube ich. Der hat das nämlich genauso manuell gemacht. Der hat geguckt in dieser Bitmap, welche Blöcke irgendwie frei sind und hat dann für diese Blöcke Trim-Commands irgendwie losgeballert. Aber das war doch schon irgendwie vor keine Ahnung, anderthalb Jahren oder wann?
Ich hab halt mal danach gegoogelt und nichts gefunden. Ich hab danach mal gebingt.
Ich hab bei Facebook geguckt.
Ich hab einfach nur bei Twitter umgefragt.
Das war nicht auf Facebook.
When I was your age, we used Alta Vista.
Wobei so richtig benutzen könnte man das ja eigentlich nicht.
Alta Vista war aber ganz schön Rock'n'Roll damals.
Nee, das war total lame.
Da kannst du nicht von davor. Also Alta Vista, da ging noch die Sonne auf.
Vor Alta Vista wusste man nicht, was im Web ist.
Ich hab immer Yahoo benutzt. Da gab's wenigstens nicht alle doppelt und so.
Also solange wie ich das Web genutzt habe, gab's...
Ach so, Directory.
Ja, das war handgepflegt. Alta Vista kann doch irgendwie alle Risals 23.000 Mal auf allen Seiten.
Ja, aber du konntest zumindest mal suchen.
Du konntest in dem Directory auch suchen.
Wir schweifen schon wieder von dem Thema ab.
Das ist auch so eine persönliche Sache.
Gibt es eigentlich noch diese Tools, mit denen man seine Webseiten bei 598 Suchmaschinen parallel anmelden kann?
Das macht keiner mehr, dieses Webseiten. Doch, bei Google kannst du ja noch deine, kannst du noch ein bisschen tunen, aber eigentlich ist ja dieses, so damals, diese Seite jetzt hier anmelden worden.
Naja, aber es ist so, so SEO und SEM, also da, wo ich arbeite, da gibt's einen, der ist im Wesentlichen für SEO eingestellt.
Ja, aber ich mein, gut, also bei Google, wenn du da deine Seite anmeldest oder kannst halt nachgucken, wie gut Google jetzt deine Seite findet und so und kannst dann geben dir ein paar Tipps, wie du das jetzt optimieren könntest.
Ja, es geht jetzt nicht darum, dass da, ich geb mal hier das Eingabeformular ein, dass ich eine Seite habe. Also das ist tatsächlich nicht mehr das Problem. Wobei, irgendwie muss man ja mal anfangen. Wahrscheinlich am besten, indem man selber über seine eigene Seite twittert, oder?
Ne, wenn du WordPress nimmst, wird's ja automatisch gleich.
Ach stimmt, da wird's auch mit reingepumpt.
Erstmal drüber bloggen, dann drüber twittern? Ne, mit dem Tweet auf dem Blog?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist alles, was wir zum Thema Trim sagen können.
Also ich kann nur sagen, Leute, die irgendwie Trim-Enabler gerade erst benutzen keins hatten und wo die Platte schon langsam ist, die sollten wirklich mal eine ziemlich große Datei mit mk-File in der Command-Line anlegen, die dann danach wieder löschen. Also nachdem sie den Trim-Enabler schon benutzt haben. Und dann sollten sie genau so viel, wie sie gelöscht haben, vorgelöschte Black haben. Danach sollte es dann gleich schon eigentlich fast wieder flott sein.
Jetzt neu, mit vorgelöschten Black? Wenn wir unsere Remotes noch gar nicht am Start, ich wüsste was.
Pre-Trimmed. Okay, jedenfalls gibt es einen neuen Trim-Enabler für 10.6.8. Gut, funktioniert, habe ich benutzt, geht.
Aber man weiß ja nicht, ob das Trim, was der da enabelt, auch wirklich seinen Dienst tut.
Doch, haben Leute auch schon irgendwie getestet. Die haben da irgendwie einen Blog vorhand geschrieben oder gelöscht und sich dann auf einem anderen Rechner irgendwie mit DD, mit einem Linux den Blog ausgelesen und der war weg, irgendwie so.
Gibt es denn hier schon Heil? Test, Test, Test. Hallo. Ich habe die falsche Remote, oder was?
Welche bin ich denn?
Die drei?
Ja, ist gerade mal wieder alles ein bisschen anstäbeln. Ich bin in einer Transition, in einer Technologietransition.
Hier sieht es auch aus wie bei Hempels unterm Sofa in der Metaim.
Ja, weil hier nämlich fleißig gearbeitet wurde. Festplatten habe ich ja hier auch mal selber zum Einsatz gebracht. Da kann man ja, wo wir eh gerade bei Festplatten reden, gleich mal bleiben. Ich hatte ja hier schon längere Zeit den Drobo, der für mich so eine Art drittes Backup ist. Also das ist so der Ort, wo ich Daten entlagere, sozusagen. Deine Asse meinst du?
Meine Daten-Asse. Genau, die alte Asse.
Und irgendwie, diesen Drobo traue ich ja irgendwie nicht über den Weg. Das ist auch lahm und das ist irgendwie auch laut und irgendwie lalala. Naja, wie auch immer. Nun reden wir ja schon seit Jahr und Tag von ZFS. Seit Ewigkeiten hängt immer dieses Nimdorf-Malfrinas im Raum. Und ich habe gefühlt, glaube ich nach 10 Jahren, das erste Mal wieder in meinem Leben einen PC in Betrieb genommen. Ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob es 10 Jahre sind, aber ich kann mich einfach nicht mehr dran erinnern, wann ich mir das letzte Mal einen PC gekauft und in Betrieb genommen habe.
Ich hab das auch gemacht, aber da kommen wir später zu.
Und?
Ich überlege gerade noch, ob es mir vielleicht doch noch einfällt, aber ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ich dachte mir so, okay, wenn es jetzt irgendwie 10 Jahre gedauert hat, dann müsste sich ja irgendwas geändert haben. Weißt du, ich war voll drauf eingestellt, ich kauf mir jetzt so einen PC und ich schalt den ein und irgendwas passiert, was ich so nicht erwartet hätte.
Und? Du meinst kein schwarzer Text mehr, der schlecht aufgelöst ist, irgendwie mit einem BIOS-Logo?
Irgendwas, irgendwas. Also ich dachte, irgendwas müsste sich doch geändert haben in den letzten 10 Jahren, jenseits von Tick, tick, tick, reeeh.
Ach, das simulieren sie immer noch über die Soundkarte.
Und naja, der Clou war jetzt erstmal, ich hab mir das Teil, also was ich mir gekauft habe, ist ein Acer, was steht da drauf?
Ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Acer Easy Store H340.
Nee, da vorne gibt's noch so einen anderen. Aspire.
So was hab ich in flach.
Ja, wenn sie vielleicht eher Acer Transpire nennen sollen, dann kommt schon ein bisschen ins Schwitzen. Na ja, auf jeden Fall ist das so ein droboartiger PC, das heißt, der hat so vier Plattenhalterungen, wo man so die Platten relativ easy-peasy reinstecken kann.
Und die vier?
Vier. Und also, sagen wir mal jetzt vom Hardware-Setup, find ich das Ding okay, sieht halt aus wie so ein PC mit so designartiger Gestaltung und merkwürdigen Lämpchen, von denen man dann nie weiß, wofür sie eigentlich gut sind. Vier Platten-Slots, die dann sinnigerweise auch von unten nach oben, von eins bis vier durchzählen, was ich auch nicht verstanden habe. Ich meine, wenn ihr vier Platten habt übereinander, welche würde die eins nennen?
Die unterste.
Die unterste, warum?
Ich hörte bei null anfangen zu zählen.
Wieso fang ich unten an?
Na, weil oben ist doch voll der Schwerpunkt viel zu hoch, dann kippt der um.
Also das war für mich einfach nicht ersichtlich. Ich hab das irgendwie erst im Laufe des weiteren Installierens und Testens festgestellt.
Das Gerät gibt es auch gar nicht bei ASA. Wir gucken hier gerade nach, ASA ist Bayer.
Also massenhaft ist Bayer.
Die im Chat sind schon wieder besser als ihr.
Bei Geiz halt, ich gucke noch nicht bei Geiz.
Amazon.
Ich gucke bei ASA.
Guck mal, ist er da?
Also auf der ASA-Seite. Das ist er doch hier. H340 hast du gerade gesagt.
Mit einem Intel-Atom. N230, der kommt ja gar nicht aus der Tasche. Und Single-Corder wie? Ach du Kacke.
Du, war günstig und ich war jetzt auch nicht bereit, in so einem PC enorm viel Geld zu investieren.
Den gleichen gibt es auch mit einem ordentlichen Atom.
Wie auch immer. Ich wollte das Teil überhaupt erst mal, was ist an dem ordentlicher? Der D410.
Der ist Dual, glaube ich. Das war der, den ich letztes Mal hatte. Jetzt gibt es ja schon den 500.
Na gut, da kann ich ja dann noch upgraden. Das ist ja alles nicht das Ding. Ich wollte ja überhaupt erst mal testen, ob es überhaupt läuft. Und gut, dann hab ich... So, und da kann man dann, wie das so üblich ist, eine Grafikkarte reinstecken.
Was, echt? Der hat keinen Onboard?
Ich glaube nicht. Also ich weiß nicht genau, wenn man den kauft, mit was für einer Grafikkarte, der so kommt. Ich wollte den auf jeden Fall...
Da stand doch Intel 945GC, das ist doch die interne...
Der hat da so Onboard-Grafik.
Aber der hat keinen Ausgang dafür, da musste glaube ich erst noch irgendwas drauf.
Wie kommst du da ins BIOS ran und so?
Ach, das darf man gar nicht einrichten, oder wie?
Ja, der hat tatsächlich hier keinen...
Der hat keinen Ausgang für den Monitor.
Wir müssen ja erstmal die Grafikkarte einbauen, um da...
Das war mir auch egal, weil ich wollte sowieso gleich Display-Port haben, weil ich wollte mir jetzt nicht dafür noch extra noch einen Monitor kaufen, weil ich hab hier nicht mehr welche rumstehen. Und ich hab ja nur meinen iMac mit Display-Port-Eingang und so, dachte ich mir so, bist du mal ganz cool und so. Ja, man sieht ja schon wieder alle im Chat so blaue LEDs. Ja Leute, ich finde auch, wenn man sich ein PC kauft, dann muss man das auch, das Röhrchen einfach.
Auch komplett durchziehen, ne?
Ich wollte einfach The Real Experience haben. So, dann hab ich mir dieses Ding gekauft, Platten reingesteckt, hatte ich noch genug von rumliegen. Und wie gesagt, da ist so eine Grafikkarte drin, die macht Display-Port. Hat zwei Display-Ports, also nicht Mini-Display-Ports, sondern Display-Port, Adapter noch dazu und so. So hört sich das auch gleich erstmal ein Adapter an.
Achso, das ist jetzt dieses Konstrukt da hinten.
Krass.
Ja, und dann hab ich sie eingeschaltet. Und ich war auf alles vorbereitet.
Angeschneit mit Schutzbrille.
Genau, dann ist mir auch erstmal wieder eingefallen, dass man ja bei diesen Geräten auch die Tastatur noch mit einem Kabel anschließen muss. Also wenn es um Booten geht, hab ich noch meine alte Apple-Tastatur von meinem iMac irgendwie, weil ich bin ja komplett auf Wireless gegangen. Hat sich halt noch so rumliegen, musste ich mir auch nichts kaufen, war sehr schön. Und dann hab ich mich hier so hingesetzt und hab das Gerät eingeschaltet und dachte mir so, okay, mal sehen was passiert. Und jetzt muss ich grad nochmal ein bisschen nachdenken. Ich glaube, am Anfang passierte erstmal gar nichts. Dann hab ich nicht so richtig verstanden, warum eigentlich nicht. Krieg ich jetzt nicht mehr so ganz zusammen, das war so etwas diffus. Da hab ich so ein paar Mal ein- und ausgeschaltet und irgendwann sprang tatsächlich mein iMac um und zeigte mir einen schwarzen Bildschirm. Auf dem dann für so gefühlte 0,5 Sekunden so ein typisches Bios. So weißer Text auf schwarzem Hintergrund, Hallo, ich bin ein PC, ich hab so und so viel RAM, ich hab auch ein paar Platten gefunden, drück doch F2 zu Continue, wenn du ein Setup willst. Und dann so, in dem Moment, wo man diesen Text wahrgenommen hat, war schon wieder alles weg. Kam dann irgendwie so Ka-Ching, die Grafikkarte mit ihrem Bios, wie das ja auch immer so ist, dann muss da was anderes, dazu muss man natürlich erstmal alles löschen, weil warum sollte man sich das auch durchlesen? Und dann war wieder alles weg und dann war da nur noch so ein Cursor, der blinkte. Und dann nichts.
Wobei man muss der Fairness-Hyber auch sagen, das ist ein Gerät, was dafür gedacht ist, dass man keinen Bildschirm anschließt. Also das hat ja nicht umsonst keine Grafikkarte onboard.
Aber was ist da default drauf?
Ich hab eine reingesteckt.
Ja, aber das ist ja irgendwie so ein Windows, was für, drauf ohne Bildschirm drauf. Wobei Windows ohne Bildschirm ist natürlich auch einfach.
Also ich verstehe ja auch nicht, warum dieser PC eine Grafikkarte hat, aber keinen Grafikkartenanschluss hat. Man kann sich den wohl irgendwie ran nibbeln. Äh, frag mich nicht. Ich meine, diese Welt ist sowieso unerklärlich.
Das ist wirklich bizarr.
Ja, bizarr, ne? Und vor allem zu diesem Zeitpunkt hab ich ihn noch nicht mal zum booten bekommen. So, Cursor blinkte, ich schaute mir den so ne Weile an. Ja, dann hab ich so mit Alt-F2 mein iMac wieder auf iMac umgeschaltet. Nochmal mit Alt-F2 wollte ich wieder zurückschalten. Das geht dann schon nicht mehr. Also man kann den dann nicht nochmal. Es kann nur nach dem booten, wenn er sagt, hallo hier bin ich, dann meldet er sich irgendwie ordnungsgemäß an, aber danach, wenn er einmal weggeschaltet ist, dann vergisst er wohl, dass er da jemals einen dran hatte und dann kannst du da auch irgendwie nicht wieder hinschalten. Das mag jetzt auch am Mac liegen, keine Ahnung, aber mit dem Laptop, mit dem Mac, funktioniert das hin und her schalten. Das ging irgendwie gar nicht. So, das war natürlich erstmal das Problem, warum war das so? Ich hab dann irgendwie lange rum probiert, dachte so, naja, okay, zehn Jahre, Tim, du bist auch ein bisschen blöd, ne? Apple-Tastatur, vielleicht mag er ja eine Apple-USB-Tastatur nicht, kam aber irgendwie auch alles nicht plausibel vor, aber ich wusste einfach nicht, was ich falsch gemacht hab. Ich mein, irgendwie meinen Händler angerufen und gesagt, hier, folgende Situation, mal so kurz das nachdenken auf der anderen Seite, ja, wart mal, so raschel, raschel, raschel, raschel, in diesen Leaflet irgendwie geblättert und dann hat er so, ja...
Verstehe, wer soll sonst so dich rascheln?
Naja, der hat mir halt das Teil auch zusammengeschraubt und dann meinte er so, ja, da musst du jetzt nochmal aufschrauben, das ist mir so geil, aufschrauben, bevor man überhaupt das Teil einmal gebootet hat, erstmal aufschrauben, Grafikkarte rausziehen und dann durfte ich so aufs Mainboard leuchten und gucken, ob da irgendwo ein Jumper gesetzt war oder nicht. The real thing war nicht und ich musste erst diesen Jumper da draufsetzen, damit in dieser Konfiguration mit dieser externen Grafikkarte meine Tastatur erkannt wird. Und das hat dann auch geholfen. Ab dann konnte ich dann...
Wait, wait, wait, du musstest was mit der Grafikkarte machen, dass die Tastatur geht.
Ich musste diesen Jumper auf dem Mainboard setzen, damit in dieser Kon... frag mich nicht. Ich hab das nicht verstanden, ich hab das nur getan. Ich hab mich verhalten wie ein normaler PC-Benutzer. Denen wird auch gesagt, was sie zu tun haben und sie haben das nicht zu hinterfragen. Und wenn es dann geht, dann ist es gut. Und dann sollen sie das vergessen, dass es jemals passiert ist. Das ist so wie bei Yoda so. Und Darth Vader so. Du hast das jetzt vergessen. Naja, ich will jetzt hier nicht so eine epische, lange Geschichte daraus machen. Das hat mich den ersten halben Tag gekostet. Der zweite halbe Tag ist so mit meiner eigenen Blödheit draufgegangen, weil ich wollte dann Freenas installieren. Und das gibt es ja mittlerweile in so einer Version 8. Und sie haben da auch irgendwie so Videos, wo sie erklären, wie einfach das doch alles ist. Du musst ja nur das Image auf dein USB-Stick drauf machen und so mit DD. Ich hab das irgendwie alles gemacht, und es ging irgendwie nicht, und ich konnte nicht davon booten. Und der Grund war, dass ich halt das falsche Image genommen hab. Aber es ist halt auch so, Freenas linkt dann so auf, ja und hier musst du nur das Image machen. Und dann kriegst du da so ein File-Listing im Web, so mit irgendwie 50 verschiedenen Dateien, mit x verschiedenen Releases, die halt irgendwie komisch benannt sind. Und ich hab dann irgendwie aus so falscher Erinnerung heraus immer das CD-ROM-Image genommen. Es war natürlich klar, dass er davon nicht direkt booten konnte. Also wenn man dann Full-Install-Image nimmt, das da drauf macht, auf den USB-Stick, den hinten rein steckt, im Setup dann natürlich auch noch so einstellt, dass er diesen USB-Stick als ersten nimmt und nicht etwa den eingebauten USB-Stick, onboard-USB-Stick, den es auch gibt, wo so ein Windows- Server-System drauf ist, um nur darauf wartet, gebootet zu werden. Das war nämlich dann der nächste Effekt, als ich das Teil gebootet hab, dass dann so ein Windows-Installations-Scheiß irgendwie kam.
Wobei das natürlich für dieses ganze Restore-Area ganz praktisch ist, weil normalerweise ist das ja immer auf irgendeine Extra-Partition drauf, dieses Restore-Image von Windows, aber wenn man so wie bei dem Ding hier alle die ganzen Teile auswechseln kann, ist das ja dann...
Ja, aber ist das auch nicht so. Also ich hab auch mehrere Mal in diesem Setup immer gesagt, bitte davon nicht booten und auch der merkt sich das nicht zuverlässig, also bei jedem, der drittem Mal booten wollte, hat er es dann doch wieder in diese Liste von bootbaren Sachen, also dieses Windows drängelt sich die ganze Zeit vor. Du kannst die ganze Zeit sagen.
Wenn man einen kauft, dass man ein gratis Surfstick dazu gelegt kriegt. Ja, und da hör ich jetzt mal hier von diesem.
Sag's noch mal.
Ein gratis Surfstick. Timmet, Timmet, lege ihn mal kurz nicht ab, ich will die Geschichte nochmal kurz zu Ende hören hier. Also erstens, wie ist das Prinas mit dem ZFS?
Okay, also ich hab's dann, nachdem ich das richtige Image auf diesen OSB-Stick drauf gemacht hab, nachdem ich diesen Acer davon überzeugt hab, dass er davon auch dann bootet und nicht von diesem Windows-Scheiß, bootet er tatsächlich davon, das dauert eine Weile, aber ich hatte jetzt auch nicht den schnellsten OSB-Stick genommen, ein Gigabyte muss das Teil auch nur groß sein. Und kommt dann doch relativ akkurat hoch. Ich hab den Vorgang nochmal wiederholt, weil ich mich beim ersten Mal irgendwie vertan habe. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass das Setup jetzt besonders benutzerfreundlich ist, aber es ist so, wenn man sich ein bisschen Ruhe nimmt und wenn man irgendwie halbwegs versteht, wie die Zusammenhänge zwischen diesen einzelnen Punkten sind, dann kommt man schon irgendwie zum Ziel. Am Anfang ist es halt immer so, du musst halt alles separat machen, du musst halt das Volumen einrichten, du musst die Permissions dafür setzen, zwar mit GUI im Web, aber halt immer noch so Unix mit User Group, ASA und RWX und sowas, einfach keiner versteht eigentlich. Und musst den User einrichten, musst die Gruppe da richtig machen, also musst irgendwie eigentlich von Unix Systemadministration immer noch genug Plan haben, um dieses User-Interface zu begreifen. Also das ist nicht so wie Time-Capsule oder so. Aber es ist besser als SysInstaller-Free Na ja, aber es ist, man merkt einfach, das ist immer noch so diese Open-Source-Techniker-Denke, an der Stelle, es ist keine Oberfläche, die jetzt ein Workflow macht, um zum Ziel zu kommen, sondern es ist mehr so nur so eine Web-Abbildung von Systemkonfiguration. Dafür ist es dann wiederum ganz okay. Dann musst du dann halt dein AFP einschalten und so, also alles separat machen. Und wenn du das dann gemacht hast, dann meldet sich das Teil halt auch tatsächlich. Kannst dann auch irgendwo noch sagen, dass er dann eben so Time Machine-artig sich melden soll.
Und was hast du für einen ZFS Setup? Miroir oder RAID oder?
Ich habe so einen RAID-Set genommen.
Also das hat ja richtig FreeBSD 8, 2, Stable.
FreeBSD 8, 2, irgendwas.
Release.
Ja, weiter.
Whatever, mit ZFS, richtig. Oh, wie viele Platten?
Vier Platten.
Im RAID-Set.
Einmal 2 GB.
Willkommen im 21.
Danke.
Will ich auch haben.
So, da enden dann auch so ein bisschen meine Tests. Also als ich das dann gemacht habe, habe ich dann erstmal einen Test gemacht, in dem ich einfach alle meine Dateien vom Drobo rübergehauen habe. Ich wollte das Ding erstmal voll machen. Ich wollte erstmal sehen, dass er in der Lage ist, 2,5 TB Dateien da drauf zu kopieren, ohne dass es irgendwie stirbt. Das hat geklappt.
Du bist jetzt welcome to the land of the wonder.
Hätte ja auch irgendwas schiefgehen können. Hätte ja der Acer sich zur Hälfte melden können und sagen, Jumper falsch gesetzt oder so. Was weiß ich? Weiß man's? So, sehr viel mehr kann ich jetzt noch nicht berichten, weil ich dann auch ehrlich gesagt, diese ZFS-Konfiguration, die ist halt dann auch echt auch wiederum für Advanced-Users. Ja, wenn du nicht weißt, was ZFS bietet, dann verstehst du dieses Freenas Interface nicht.
ZFS muss man sich schon ein bisschen auseinandersetzen. Das ist korrekt.
Ja, man muss sich mit allem auseinandersetzen. Also, dieses Freenas ist jetzt keine Lösung für jemanden, der von Unix keine Ahnung hat, der von Server-Konfiguration keine Ahnung hat und von Datalsystemen keine Ahnung hat.
Aber ehrlich gesagt...
Ein, der keine Ahnung hat, der macht sich ein Filesystem und dann ist Ruhe und der stellt auch nichts mehr ein und dann hat sich das...
Ja gut, also ich hab jetzt zum Beispiel das mit diesem Dataset, das hab ich dann irgendwie nicht so richtig begriffen. Ob sie damit jetzt, also man kann so ZFS-Datasets einrichten. Meinen sie damit jetzt Filesysteme oder was? Also Dataset kenn ich jetzt aus der ZFS-Technologie nicht.
Die Datasette, ja.
Ja, die kann man in der Datasette einrichten.
Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, was die damit meinen, aber...
Und jetzt ist das Ding erstmal voll. Was ich jetzt als nächstes mal machen wollte, ist, dass ich mal eine Platte rausnehme aus dem Rad. Gucken, ob dann irgendwie noch immer alles zugreifbar ist. Ne große Platte reinstecken und da drauf migrieren. Das müsste ja eigentlich gehen, oder geht das nicht?
Was heißt drauf migrieren? Also du hast jetzt dreimal wieviel drin? Dreimal ein Terra oder was?
Ich hab dreimal eins und einmal zwei. Und ich würde jetzt gerne einmal eins rausnehmen und durch einmal zwei ersetzen.
Also dass du dann zweimal zwei und zweimal eins hast.
Wenn du da Ray-Z machst über alle Platten und zwar mal über die gesamte Größe, dann ist ja das der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner, oder wie sagt man? Nee, aber die kleinste Plattengröße entscheidet sich denn, was genommen wird. Weil bei Ray-Z müssen die alle gleich groß sein.
Müssen sie? Und wann müssen sie das nicht?
Die müssen immer gleich groß sein. Mit dem Mirror müssen die gleich groß sein. Die müssen nicht gleich groß sein, wenn du die stripes, also wenn du zwei Platten zusammenklebst. Dann kannst du irgendwie drei Terra nehmen und ein Terra und dann hast du am Ende vier. Das geht. Aber wenn du ein Mirror machst, müssen die gleich groß sein. Wenn du ein Ray-Z 1, 2 oder 3 machst, müssen die auch gleich groß sein. Der Rest, der wird einfach nicht benutzt.
Ja gut, und wenn ich jetzt alle 1 GB gegen 2 GB getauscht habe?
Wenn du die letzte dann tauschst, dann machst du plopp und dann wird dein ZFS automatisch größer. Aber Attention, es gibt keinen Weg zurück. Kleiner geht nämlich noch nicht. Das wollten die schon immer mal machen. Das ist dieses berühmte Block-Pointer-Rewrite. Haben sie aber noch nicht gemacht und da auch irgendwie Oracle und so weiter und ZFS. Weiß nicht, ob das dann noch so in der Open Source landet, da weiß ich nicht, wie die Entwicklungen da sind, aber wachsen geht, kleiner noch nicht.
Könnte ich mitleben, weil...
Er will schon kleiner.
Er will schon kleiner. Aber das war mir unklar. Auch da bietet diese Oberfläche einfach nichts. Also nichts in dieser Oberfläche erklärt einem irgendwas.
Das ist aber jetzt diese FreeNAS-Software, die wir starmanage. Ja, okay, die kenne ich nicht.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mehr als das Install, das dir auf einem normalen FreeBSD bietet, weil da gibt es gar keinen ZFS.
Es war vor allem komplett installationsfrei. Also ich habe mir sozusagen das fertige System bootbar auf diesen USB-Stick draufgeschoben und dann direkt davon gebootet und das Ding kommt hoch mit dem Web-Server und ich kann es einfach sofort benutzen. Mal schauen. Also ich habe jetzt noch keine Gelegenheit gehabt, mich jetzt damit vertraut zu machen. Mir ist das Gerät auch immer noch zu laut. Aber jetzt ist es zumindest Ethernet, jetzt kann ich es irgendwo hinstellen.
Genau, das ist nämlich das, wonach ich auch gesucht hatte, auch schon im Twitter umgefragt. Und dann haben alle möglichen Leute irgendwelche NAS-Gerätschaften empfohlen von Drobo, dieses QNAP oder Synology und so. Die kommen halt alle mit irgendwie so mit X-FS oder irgendwelchen komischen Softwaren daher und irgendwie hat mich das alles nicht so richtig glücklich gemacht und eigentlich hätte ich auch am liebsten so einen kleinen Mini-PC, wo ich, also ich hätte gerne mehr als vier Slots, aber vier würden am Anfang auch erstmal tun. Also im Prinzip ist das genau das, was ich eigentlich suche und schon überlegt habe, selber zu basteln, aber eigentlich ist die Bauform okay und wenn man nur einen Jumper setzen muss, ja mein Gott, ich so ein bisschen basteln geht schon mal.
Kriegt man es auch ohne Grafikkarte? Also komplett? Ich schieb einen Stick ran und bute davon und mach diese Kiste drauf platt und hab so direkt SSH-Verbindung und das meldet sich am besten noch irgendwo?
Na nee, so wie das klang, musst du erstmal schon einen Monitor und eine Tastatur rannehmen.
Naja, ohne Bildschirm, also ich weiß nicht, ich finde glaub mich, ein PC kann man ohne Bildschirm nicht in Betrieb nehmen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man es bei einem Mac kann, aber es ist einfach, geht das irgendwie? Also ich meine, muss doch, wieso soll das nicht gehen? Ich meine, eigentlich brauchst du doch bloß, du brauchst irgendeinen...
Nee, beim Mac geht das auch nicht, aber es gibt halt so Server, die sprechen dich dann halt auf einer seriellen an und dann musst du dann nur deinen USB-Terminal-Adapter anschließen und dann machst du es halt alles auf der Kabelseile.
Das System, das hier drauf ist, das Windows, das ist ja dafür gedacht, dass man es ohne Bildschirm betreibt.
Ja, aber da ist kein fertiges Windows drauf, sondern da ist ein Windows-Install-Image, Self-Mounting-Image, tralala, und dann kommt da irgendwie so ein Installer hoch.
Ja, aber per Default ist ja irgendwas drauf, was du hochfahren kannst. Also du kannst das ja ohne Grafikkarte betreiben, oder?
Ich kann das ohne... also, keine Ahnung. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt die Grafikkarte rausnehme, muss ich wahrscheinlich wieder noch fünf Jumper umlegen, oder so.
Aber wenn die das so verkaufen, ist das doch ohne...
Aber er hat ja kein Video-Out. Also ich meine, wie würdest du den Windows-Installer, der da drauf ist...
Ich dachte, das muss einfach einschalten, sonst ist dann hoffnett und alles gut ist.
Ich kann es dir nicht erklären. Ich hab das Ding irgendwie auch Customized bestellt. Ich hab gesagt, ich will diese Karte drin haben und ich will auch diese Default-Platte, die da drin ist, nicht haben, weil hab ich ja genug alles rumliegen und ich will irgendwie vom Sketch starten und ich will kein Windows sehen. Dass sie dann so ein Onboard-Windows-Installer auf USB-Disc haben, konnte ich ja nicht ahnen.
Aber wie gesagt, also...
Das ist bestimmt auch noch ein Jumper, mit dem man das dann irgendwie entfernen kann.
Also auf jeden Fall will ich halt auch bei meinem NAS irgendwie gerne ein modernes Fallsystem drauf haben und so, nachdem ich jetzt irgendwie mit X-TFS, was ja dann irgendwie die meisten dealungsbasierten da benutzen, irgendwie schon ein paar mal lustige Erfahrungen gemacht hab.
Aber ein modernes Fallsystem ist natürlich sehr relativ, also das ZFS, was du heute unter Solaris kriegst, ist natürlich weit, weit, weit fortgeschrittener als das, was hier bei den Freenas kommt. Das ist irgendwie Layout-Version Nummer 17.
Ja, das kam erst vor zwei Wochen oder so, kam Version 28 für FreeBSD Stable, also nicht für Release, 8.2 Stable. Und bei Freenas, die sind natürlich dann wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so flott. Da gibt's ja auch schon De-Dub-Support und faster irgendwie Snapshots anlegen und löschen und all sowas. Also da sind reichlich neue Features.
Und was mich eigentlich noch kurz interessieren würde ist, es meinten halt auch Leute, dass das Atombord, was so üblicherweise ist bei so einer Naas-Geschichten, dass das halt auch irgendwie viel zu langsam wäre für ZFS und so. Wie viel RAM hat die Kiste, weißt du das?
2 GB.
Und aber das, also wie, hast du geguckt, wie schnell du deine Terabyte darüber schieben konntest? War das irgendwie annehmbar?
Na, die Begrenzung war glaube ich an der Stelle eher der Drobo. Also der Drobo war mit Firewire 800 angeschlossen. Und ich glaube, der hat so im Mittel mit 40 MB pro Sekunde da Daten draufgeschrieben. Was ich jetzt schon mal nicht so schlecht fand. Und wie gesagt, seitdem das dann das Wochenende durchlief, war ich gar nicht hier. Ich bin jetzt zu dieser Sendung erst hier wieder reingekommen. Kann von daher noch keine weiteren Zahlen nennen, aber I keep you posted. Aber hier, was diese neuen Features betrifft, also diese Version 17, kann halt nicht, D-Duplication kann nicht Encryption. Bei der Wikipedia...
Bei der Encryption gibt es noch gar nicht. D-Duplication gibt es wie gesagt mit der neuen Version 28, die es bei FreeBSD ja jetzt gibt.
Also Wikipedia sagt, D-Duplication gibt es seit Version 21 und Encryption mit 30.
Genau, und FreeBSD hat jetzt 28. Ach, FreeBSD hat 28. Genau, FreeBSD hat jetzt den neuesten ZFS-Stand, den man haben kann als Open Source, also extern von Oracle.
Das heißt, es ist durchaus vorstellbar, dass es bald ein Freenas-Update gibt, wo dann auch D-Duplication... Aber dann hab ich noch irgendwo gelesen, dass man für D-Duplication echt viel RAM braucht, und zwar so viel RAM, wie man Platz hat.
Das könnte man so sagen. Ich verstehe es auch nicht so ganz, die Ansprüche sind da schon ganz schön hoch, aber ich glaube, das... Also ich dachte mir auch immer, ja so D-Duplication geil, wenn ich dann irgendeinen File zweimal hab, dann wird das weg-D-dupliziert. Na, weil diese von allen Blöcken, die so drauf sind auf deinem Pool, liegen die Hashes im RAM, und zwar von allen Blöcken. Und deswegen musst du halt viel RAM haben, weil du musst ja sofort nachgucken können im RAM, gibt es den Block jetzt schon in der Schreibung, oder gibt es ihn nicht? Wenn er den erst von Platte lesen muss, dann kann er den Block auch gleich wegschreiben. Deswegen brauchst du so viel RAM. Und das lohnt sich halt nur für die Leute, die wirklich...
Wieso? Ich meine, D-Duplication ist ja nicht ein Time Saver, sondern ein Platz Saver. Ich würde ja ertragen, dass es langsam ist, wenn es mir Platz spart.
Korrekt, aber die bei ZFS haben halt einen Synchron-D-Duplizierer gebaut. Das heißt, der macht es immer gleich sofort und nicht später asynchron nachträglich und guckt nach, was es dann doppelt und optimiert. Der macht es immer gleich sofort.
Könnte man das nicht mit einer SSD noch kombinieren? Dass ich noch so eine SSD, dass ich einfach noch einen USB-Stick ran decke?
Du kannst es auch mit wenig Speicher machen, weil die Liste liegt schon auf der Platte, aber dann muss er halt immer laden und dann wird es richtig langsam.
Und kann man D-Duplication noch ausschalten?
Ja, man muss sie gar nicht erst einschalten.
Und so ein SSD-Cache, also hier in der Wikipedia steht auch, if RAM is lacking, consider SSD as a cache.
Das ist jetzt hier für Leute, die da irgendwie Terabytes an Storage haben. Und ich rede jetzt nicht von so einstelligen Terabytes, sondern die wirklich irgendwie 30, 40 oder mehr Terabyte haben. Also für den Home-User ist D-Duplication einfach nichts. Das kannst du voll vergessen.
Aber hier ist sozusagen, ZFS-Designers recommend 2 GB of RAM for every 1 TB of Storage. Das heißt, in meinem Teil, wo ich jetzt schon 3 TB habe, bräuchte ich dann schon 6.
Aber hast du denn Sachen wirklich doppelt?
Ja, so ein Foto oder Zweig.
Das lohnt einfach nicht, wenn du nicht wirklich 20-mal das gleiche VMWare-Image da drauf haben willst für deine 20 User. Dann lohnt sich sowas. Aber für eine Sache, die mal doppelt ist, lohnt sich nicht.
Pass auf, also ich benutze die Platte ja weniger. Also Time Machine kann sein, dass das Ding vielleicht auch nochmal mein Time Machine Target wird. Erstmal ist es das nicht, ja, kann sein. Aber in dem Moment, wo es Time Machine Target ist, habe ich volle Kante doppelt Zeug. Weil ich jedes, wenn ich einen Byte in einem Gigabyte-File ändere, dann ist das bei Time Machine ein ganzes Gigabyte, was dann nochmal komplett wegschreibt. Und wenn mich das dann mit D-Duplication eben nicht ein Gigabyte kostet, sondern halt nur ein Megabyte, dann ist das ein riesen Ersparnis. Das heißt, dass ich unter Umständen mehrere Monate mehr an Backup habe. Also für Time Machine bringt es schon mal enorm was. Und für was ich das hauptsächlich benutze, für Auslagerung, Auslagerung ist auch immer so eine Sache. Du weißt immer irgendwie gar nicht, was du ausgelagert hast. Und manchmal würde ich lieber so sagen, ach, kopier das jetzt. Ich lager das jetzt nochmal aus. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, in welchem Ort ich das hingelegt hab. Ich hab jetzt auch keinen Bock, hier einen such mir identische Files-Spielchen zu machen. Ich kopier das einfach nochmal dahin. Und wenn die ganzen Daten schon mal ausgelagert waren, dann hab ich halt nochmal ein paar Megabyte auf der Platte verschwendet, dafür, dass ich das doppelt hab. Aber ich hab halt nicht nochmal, was weiß ich, wenn ich so ein, sagen wir mal so ein 50 Gigabyte oder 150 Gigabyte Ordner, so Kongress-Videos oder so ein Scheiß, das lege ich da einfach nochmal hin. Und weißt du nicht, habe ich die jetzt schon, weil wie waren die benannt und habe ich die vielleicht nur anders getaggt und das meiste ist identisch. Und so, und dann kopiere ich es halt einfach drauf. Und dann weiß ich einfach...
Dann steckt dein Gigabyte nochmal nach, mach D-Dop an und dann...
Naja, aber das muss dann nicht schnell sein. Also ich würde dann eher sagen, da hole ich dann so einen 32 Gigabyte USB-Stick, den ich da hinten noch mit ranstecke und dann ist das einfach mein Cache. Weil das steht in der Wikipedia-Seite drin, dass man das tun kann, dass man an dieses D-Cache macht und dann würde das eben die Geschwindigkeit auch irgendwie achtfach beschleunigen und so weiter. Weil so ein USB-Stick, ich meine die 100 Euro da oder kriegst ja auch schon billiger, das ist ja nichts. Aber RAM kann ich da gar nicht reinstecken in das kleine Teil. Der ist jetzt mit 2 Gigabyte, ist der halt beim Max. Und ich will mir jetzt auch nicht so den Desktop...
Also es kann sein, dass dann für dich D-Duplication cool ist, muss man halt gucken, aber ich würde sagen, dass eine kleine Kiste es dann relativ schnell überfordert irgendwann. Weil ZFS ist schon so ein bisschen fordernd. Also ich hab zuhause jetzt schon inzwischen, ich hab ja den Atomenachfolger, dieses D510, das ist halt ein Dual-Core, der hat 4 Gigabyte und da bin ich mit dem ZFS eigentlich ganz zufrieden, aber ich hab halt auch kein D-Duplication, aber ich glaube, ich brauch das auch nicht. Die paar Bytes, die ich da sparen würde, da lohnt es sich einfach nicht, den RAM zu opfern.
Naja, aber bei Time-Machinen sparst du enorm.
Ich hab auch Time-Machinen.
Naja gut, aber...
Probiert das mal aus.
Ich hab halt hier so Files, ne? Audio-Dateien sind halt groß. So eine Sendung, Mobamex, zack, wieder 5 Gigabyte, da kommt irgendwie ganz schön was zusammen.
Und wenn jetzt in einem Audio-Podcast ein Blog die gleiche Checksumme hat wie ein anderer Blog aus einem anderen Podcast, dann taucht das bestimmt öfters auf.
Wir haben das gleiche gehört.
Wir müssen mal langsam wieder über Max reden.
Wollt ihr dann auch D-Double-Linien?
Das können wir dann in einer Sendung einführen. So alle Themen, die wir schon mal weg hatten, die fliegen dann automatisch raus.
Oder wenn dir der Podcast gepublished wird, dann kommen diese Ställe Nokia aus einem anderen Podcast.
Und Nokia wird 1999 nicht überleben.
Ich fragte hier in meinem Chat, ob ich komische Arbeitsweisen habe oder warum meine Probleme nicht verstanden werden. Komische Arbeitsweisen? Das Backup komische Arbeitsweisen?
Ich verstehe das vollkommen, das Bedürfnis.
Okay, das beruhigt mich.
Next.
Das Thema ist erschöpft.
Nee, den Preis wollte ich noch wissen von den Kasten.
299 für die 2, mit 2 TB T-Fold-Platte. Ach so, das ist der Neu.
Ja eben, du hast doch die kleine Version.
Jaja, ich hab mir so, ich hab gar nicht groß Marktforschung betrieben, weil da blicke ich eh nicht durch.
Sagt mir doch mal den Amazon-Preis. Musst du jetzt nicht von dem Special-Deal-Händer sein, wo du wieder alles für ein Drittel kriegst.
300. 300, ja, das ist der neue, der alte. 255.
255 Single-Core mit schon 2 GB RAM und anderthalb Terabyte Platte. Und 2,99. Also 45 Euro mehr für ein Dual-Core mit ein bisschen mehr RAM und ein bisschen mehr Platte.
300 Euro.
Quasi. Die 45 Euro hätte sich gelohnt, glaube ich.
Na, ich hab das halt, das war halt so ein Restposten.
Ich hab den halt irgendwie nicht bekommen. Grademap. Ich weiß nicht, ob die schon compressed sind oder nicht, und so weiter und so fort. Aber compression ist auf jeden Fall auch cool.
Die sind nicht compressed.
Ja, dann musst du mal gucken, ob da was zu holen ist. Mit der Kompression.
Na gut, aber Frinas hat noch keine Kompression.
Wie, aber kommst du nicht mit der Shell drauf, kannst du einfach mit dem Command einschalten.
Ist das bei der 17 schon dabei, compression?
Ja, schon lange ewig.
Also im User-Interface hab ich davon jetzt nichts gesehen.
Echt? Ja, gibt's aber.
User-Interface.
Da gibt's LZJB und da gibt's GZIP 1 bis 9. Wobei von GZIP solltest du deine Finger lassen mit so einer lahmen Kiste.
Das müsste ich aber dann wo einstellen? Das ist bei dem Volumen selber.
Das stellt man Profile-System ein.
Profile-Systeme gibt's hier gar nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die das da abbilden bei diesen Freeners.
Mach das doch mal nach der Sendung weiter.
Unklar, das ist hier irgendwie alles, was du machen kannst. Change Permissions.
Ah ja, das können wir jetzt alle sehen.
Genau, wir schauen da später mal. Ich wollte ja auch nur mal ein bisschen vormachen.
Nur mal kurz. Also ich fand es auch interessant.
Ich nicht. Aber schön, dass du es gemacht hast.
Sonst regen sich immer alle nur auf, dass ich nur mit Macs arbeite.
Jetzt hast du mal wieder einen PC angefasst.
Genau, und zwar, es war wirklich... Sieht auch schon ganz fertig aus. Es war so richtig schön um den Tag, um die Ohren gehauender Tag so, um das Teil zum Booten zu kriegen.
Ja, also ich finde optisch ist das ja nicht schlecht, weil bei mir, ich habe ja dieses Intel Motherboard, steht bei mir oben auf dem Küchenregal und staubt sie vor sich her. Weil ich ja jeden Tag zu Hause koche und sonst auch alles vollgefettet. Nee, ist natürlich nicht so, aber... Ja, aber ich finde den Würfel gar nicht so unschick, muss ich sagen. Ich würde halt gerne nur dann doch so die rechts unten Version davon shoppen und dann weiß ich nicht, ob der Preis dann schon wieder mich doch überfordert.
Vielleicht kannst du ja auch dein dickes Atombord da reinschrauben.
Können wir mal gucken, welche Varianten es da noch gibt?
Schön wäre es, wenn es die moderne Version davon gibt, denn modern ist inzwischen die D525, glaube ich.
Intel N230?
Also mindestens 510 will man haben.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es da irgendwas mit D410.
Das ist aber das von vorletztem Jahr irgendwie.
Von vorletztem Jahr?
Ja, die ist schon ganz schön alt, die Reihe. Anfang letzten Jahres kam die D510 raus.
Also ich glaube, ein Intel Atom N230, den hat auch mein alter Acer, also der, den ich für XBMC nehme.
Ja, das sind diese ganzen Single-Core-Dinger. Diese D-Reihe sind immer so die rechts unten Atoms. Und da gibt es halt den D525, der ist ein bisschen flott, aber ein D510 würde auch erstmal tun.
Das ist eigentlich bizarr, dass all diese Hardware, diese ganzen Geräte, dass die auf der Acer-Seite schlichtweg greifend nicht auftauchen.
Ja, das finde ich auch ein bisschen.
Amazon braucht man einfach nur, braucht man allein schon deshalb, um einfach überhaupt einen Überblick über diesen Markt zu bekommen. Du kannst auf diesen Homepages nie was finden. Diese ganzen Webseiten völlig unklar.
Ich finde es ja immer so krass, dass die irgendwelche neuen Produkte ankündigen und es nicht mal schaffen.
Acer Easy Store, 8 Terabyte, aber immer noch D410.
Da gibt es ja noch diese QNAP-Teile. Was ist noch mal beim Thema bleiben? Eine Option hier bei dem Freenas ist, dass das Ganze als Eiskasi läuft.
Eiskasi ist ja Skasi über IP. Da machst du dein Device klar. Auch mit ZFS als Grundlage. Von mir aus weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau. Du kannst sogar auch Mirror sagen. Da hast du ein Device, das als Grundlage den Mirror hat. Dann exportierst du das zu einem anderen Rechner per Eiskasi, also Skasi per IP. Auf Mac gab es beim Disk Utility für Leopard oder Snow Leopard so ein Eiskasi-Menü. Da hättest du klicken können, hier mount mir mal das File-System von Remote und dann holst du das auf dein Rechner. Dann werden richtig die Skasi-Commands zum Eiskasi-Host geschickt. Das ist das Block-Level.
Der Rechner bestimmt, was da drauf ist.
Also wahrscheinlich kein ZFS.
Der macht dann ein HFS in ZFS.
Das ZFS spielt nur die Grundlage. Das kann ZFS. Das stellt dir einfach nur ein Block-Device zur Verfügung, obwohl du unten drunter einen Ray-Z oder einen Mörrer oder sonst irgendwas hast. Das kann das ZFS, ja.
Aber dann bräuchtest du halt ZFS auf dem Mac, wenn du über Eiskasi immer noch ZFS haben willst.
Ja, das hast du dann natürlich nicht.
Du kannst auch nur mit einem Rechner darauf zugreifen, weil das ist geil.
Du steckst deine Platte per IP in deinen Rechner, so könnte man das sagen.
Ja, das ist eigentlich Quatsch. Dann kannst du ja nicht mit zwei Rechnern drauf zugreifen.
Nee, das ist ja auch für was anderes. Das ist ja für Server, wo du die Platten per IP dranhängst.
Und halt mit Gigabit und schnell und so.
Ja, all sowas. Dieses ZFS ist auch eine Menge für so Enterprise gedacht, und deswegen muss man nicht alle Features für sich zu Hause benutzen.
Nicht mal Tim?
Nee, also es könnte auch sein, dass hier so mit Compression auf seinem Single-Core, das wird glaube ich auch schon nichts.
Die Welt der Nasen.
So, gut.
Ich wollte jetzt gerade irgendein dämliches Wortspiel machen mit Mörrer, Mörrer, eben, egal.
Da wir jetzt schon, da wir noch in diesem ganzen Festplatten-Thema sind, wollen wir dann irgendwie das Thema Festplatten und so einfach auch mal gleich Was haben wir denn da noch mit den Festplatten? Na, Trim hatten wir jetzt schon. Genau Trim hatten wir schon.
Acer hatten wir schon. Dann irgendwie gibt es dickere Festplatten und Timecaps. Wie meinst du das?
Zum Beispiel. Wobei ich noch was anderes, noch ein kleiner Tipp, wir hatten doch hier auch schon ein paar Mal so dieses wie rüste ich meinen MacBook Pro auf, damit da eine SSD reinkommt.
Indem man die alte Platte rausschmeißt.
Genau, oder dass man die CD-Rom rauswirft.
Hab ich auch überlegt, damals im März oder wann das war. Aber ich hab halt erst mal nur gedacht, okay, ich wechsle erst mal nur die Platte raus, pack die SSD rein und guck mal, wie sie performt. Hab ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt. Und dann beim Einschalten ist mir gleich eins sofort aufgefallen. Es hat keine Geräusche mehr gemacht, also so keine mehr. Und da wusste ich schon, die Platte kommt dann nie wieder rein.
Ja gut, aber es gibt ja auch noch diesen Fall.
Naja, da gibt es ja diese Optibay China Seller auf Ebay, wo du irgendwie für 8 Euro so ein Optibay-Dings holen kannst. Das wird irgendwie Optibay genannt, wo du halt das DVD Superdrive irgendwie rausnimmst, da so ein Mini-Rahmen-Plastedings reinsteckst, wo die SSD dran ist. Und ja, das Problem ist nur, dass bei unserem MacBook Pro hier das... Ah, da gab es auch Gerüchte, genau, kann man auch gleich erzählen. Normalerweise hat es irgendwie nur SATA 3 Gigabit beim Anschluss für das Superdrive. Aber das hat Apple wohl heimlich geändert jetzt. Habt ihr das auch gelesen? Hast du schon... Kannst du nicht wissen, da hast du dich ausprobiert.
Ist doch egal, weil die Leute sich ja eigentlich natürlich die Festplatte mit der SSD tauschen und die dicke Festplatte ins Optibay tun.
Der Hauptslot ist der, der das schnelle Saat hat. Das will man schon haben.
Das soll wohl auch zu Problemen führen, wenn man aus dem Sleep-Modus aufwacht, was die Bootplatte ist. Und die Bootplatte sollte schon die sein, die im Festplattengehäuse ist. Habe ich nicht selber ausprobiert, aber ich habe mir voraufhört, ein bisschen schlau gemacht.
Ich hab das auch ganz viel gelesen, also nicht ganz viel, aber das das manche so sagen. Ich hab immer gehört, das soll ja, das soll ja. Aber ehrlich gesagt bin ich da so ein bisschen skeptisch, weil ich denke mal selbst, wenn Apple da irgendwelches Leap Command uns an die SSD schickt, dann sagt die SSD, haha, ich bin aber eine SSD und ignoriert das.
Ja, aber vielleicht beim Aufwachen. Dass zuerst, dass zuerst die eine Platte mit Strom versorgt wird und wenn die dann nicht rechtzeitig hochfährt, dass die andere gar nicht mehr aufwacht oder irgendwas. Nee, bin ich nicht.
Ich bin da echt sehr skeptisch. Ich hab da auch immer nur, da soll es Probleme geben, irgendwie gehört aber nie einer, der sagt, ich hab da...
Aber wenn du die Kiste eh schon aufhast und deinen Superdrive rausschreibst, dann kannst du auch die zwei Schrauben für deine Premiere-Platte auch mit rausschrauben.
Ja, eben.
Also willkommen im Reich der Sagen und Mythen. Auf jeden Fall gibt es hier auch noch für Leute, die Schwierigkeiten haben, das Ganze aus den USA zu beschaffen, gibt es hier auch ein Angebot aus Germanien.
Krass.
Heißt Hard-Wrk.
Also bei eBay hab ich deutlich weniger bezahlt dafür. Also war nicht von Hardwerk hier...
Die geben einem gleich das komplette Set.
Du kriegst halt hier so ein...
Aber holy shit, Batman, gucken wir mal, was die haben wollen.
Na 80 Euro.
Mit SSD oder wie?
Aber da ist auch noch ein USB-Gehäuse dabei, oder?
Ja, da ist ein USB-Gehäuse für deinen Laufwerk dabei. Und du hast diesen Rahmen dabei. Und sie geben dir auch noch einen Spatel und zwei ordentliche Schraubenzieher dazu.
Also die Schraubenzieher alleine kosten schon 30 Euro.
Meinst du, dass sie so viel taugen?
Das sind die guten.
Ja, tatsächlich. Nicht schlecht.
Ja, also da ist noch eine 70 Euro.
Also zwei ordentliche VH-Torx sind das ja dann wahrscheinlich, nehme ich an, ne?
Nein, ein Torx, ein Kreuz, glaube ich.
Ja, und ein Spatel.
Ein Spatel.
Aber da ist keine, okay. Also Gehäuse, ein bisschen Schraubenzieher für 80 Euro, weiß nicht.
Ja, wie gesagt, also die Schraubenzieher alleine kosten bestimmt schon 30 Euro.
Naja, ich meine, wenn du jetzt das Gefühl hast, da mit 5 Euro über den Tisch gezogen zu werden, mehr oder weniger, ich meine, das ist so die, hat ja auch Mehrwertsteuer drauf und so, ne?
Deutschland.
Und kein Zoll und so.
Ja, das China-Zoll ist inzwischen auch, kommt nicht mehr aus Roppong. Da gibt es hier schon Retailer.
Auf jeden Fall ist das so die Easy-Peasy-Lösung.
Sieht auf jeden Fall sehr schön aus.
Haben sich Mühe gegeben, ja.
Die Easy-Peasy-Lösung ist, dass man das zum Schrauber seines Vertrauens gibt und sagt, hier hast du 80 Euro, bau mir das mal ein.
Ja, Schrauber seines Vertrauens.
Ich habe keinen Schrauber meines Vertrauens. Ich bin mein eigener Schrauber meines Vertrauens.
Ich lasse nur noch schrauben.
Es gibt ja auch Leute, die wollen, wenn sie schon irgendwie, für viele ist es ja dann auch schon so ein Moment der Überwindung, überhaupt sein Gerät soweit aus dem Ende zu schrauben, da ein Laufwerk raus zu operieren. Wenn du dann noch so windige Beschreibungen hast und dann so ein Taiwan-Manuel... Bedienen, anleiten, nehmen Festplatte aus, Tastature und schieben in den Schlott.
Bei mir war da gar nichts dabei.
Dann schrauben, Display fest.
Gepolst hat der Brief umschlagt und dann lag da dieses Ding drin und hat geklappert. Aber ich hab das einmal auch selber gemacht, weil es ist die Einbauen und so, es macht schon Spaß. Dann hatte ich ja ein Problem mit der Platte und hatte das Gefühl, dass die langsam dem Ende entgegengeht und dann dachte ich, ach nee, nochmal will ich das nicht haben. Weil dann muss man auch an einer Stelle die Kamera loslösen, wenn man das austaut. Also wenn man hier ans OptiBay ran will.
Echt?
Ja, du musst da das Kamerakabel ausbauen und so. Und das musst du dann erstmal wieder reinkriegen und so. Das ist schon kein Spaß, den man mal ganz dringend haben möchte. Ich hab's geschafft, aber ich hab auch ganz schön geschwitzt dabei.
Und dann hast du aber natürlich ein schweißaufsaugendes Stürmband getragen, damit kein Salzwasser auf die Elektronik tropft, was ich schon mal gemacht hab und mir da mit einem Rechner geschraubt hab. Ernsthaft? Irgendwie im Hochsommer eine PC-Büchse geschraubt, also meine eigene, glaube ich, und irgendwie mir ronnen der Schweiß von der Stürmung und so ein fetter Tropfen direkt aufs Board. Und irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob die in dem Zeitpunkt schon unter Strom war oder keine Ahnung, was, auf jeden Fall, war dann auch direkt instantan vorbei.
Wie zischt er, ein Puff?
Ja, es ging irgendwie, also es war einige, weiß nicht, ging es aus oder blieb einfach nur Freeze und danach ging es nicht mehr an. Irgendwie sowas war das. Also ich hab viel geschraubt, dabei geschwitzt und dann lag der noch offen vor mir und irgendwann musste ich noch machen und dann... Das war echt ein Fail, sag ich dir. Da hab ich mich ganz schön geärgert.
Huckel, Huckel ist super schweiß, hat irgendwie die Kiste durchgebrannt.
Genau, ich hab mir mal...
Das war ein Quadra, hab ich mir selber hochgetaktet, oder hab ich nicht selber gemacht, sondern hab mir von jemand anderem da einen neuen Quarz reinlöten lassen.
30 Megas anstatt 25, stimmt's? 33 statt 25.
33 statt 25.
Das hab ich auch noch nie gemacht, das ging nicht.
Doch, das ging super.
Aber nur mit Kühlung.
Nee, ich hab aber einen falschen Quarz gekauft, sodass der nicht direkt drauflöten konnte, sondern er hat dann so kleine, aus Draht, so kleine Beinchen gelötet für den Quarz. Dann stand er da so oben drüber quasi und ragt aus. Hat auch super funktioniert, bis ich dann irgendwann mal im laufenden Betrieb den Quarz so gegen das CD-ROM-Laufwerk-Gehäuse gelehnt habe, weil ich irgendwie am Scassi rumgepasst war.
Das machte zuck und das Ding war aus und ging auch nicht mehr an.
Das hat mich ein Schweinegeld gekostet.
Das ist auch eine schöne Kategorie, so die schönsten Rechner-Schrotz-Stories.
Ich habe das ja auch gemacht, aber ich habe mir für den Quarz gleich einen Sockel eingebaut, damit ich switchen konnte immer. Auf einer Amiga aber.
Ich hatte auch mal einen richtig fiesen Festplatten-Fail. Habe ich... Habe ich nicht gemerkt, dass der Rechner noch an war und das war noch zu IDE-Zeiten und habe irgendwie eine neue Platte eingebaut und das IDE-Kabel ran und das Stromkabel, das hat irgendwie Zomk gemacht und dann war die Platte direkt im Arsch. Die neue, ja.
Ich hatte mal so ein... Es gibt ja immer diese hochkantstehenden Festplattengehäuse, so diese USB, warum immer die hochkantstehen müssen, also nämlich, weil dann irgendwie versehentlich übers Kabel gestolpert, das macht einfach und die Platte lag und...
ja, also es hat mich auch erstaunt irgendwie, nur weil da jetzt Strom drauf ist und ich stecke den Stecker rein, so ist das Ding tot irgendwie. Mit SATA wäre das nicht passiert.
Kommen wir wieder zur Software. Ach nee, wir können ja noch mal kurz diese Time-Capsule erwähnen. Da gibt es ja nicht viel zu erwähnen. Das Ding ist neu rausgekommen und ist jetzt irgendwie 3 Giga, 3 Terabyte spät.
Naja, da gibt es aber auch schon so ein bisschen Discussion im Netz.
Weil die nicht...
Weil da steht Server Grade und sie haben das Ding natürlich auseinandergebastelt und da sind ganz normale Festplatten drin. Aber da ist schon das Apple-Logo auf dem Sticker. Also haben die jetzt wieder eine Special Firmware oder was ist da anders als an den normalen Platten? Warum schreibt Apple das Server Grade aus?
Das machen sie doch aber, sie machen aber alle ihre Platten, die sie selber verbauen, Apple-Logos drauf, oder?
Nee, aber die schreiben überall Server Grade dran.
Vielleicht ist die einfach Server Grade.
Vielleicht haben sie, nee, das Original ist nicht Server Grade angeblich. Vielleicht haben sie vergessen, das aus dem Werbetext von der alten Time Capsule rauszunehmen. Und die ist jetzt einfach nicht mehr Server Grade.
Waren irgendwelche Green, Western Digital Green oder was?
Ja, aber es auch keine schlechten Platten sind.
Aber es ist halt teurer geworden, auch das verstehe ich nicht.
Aber ne, aber nur die große ist teurer geworden, oder?
Ich meine, das Ding läuft jetzt seit einem Jahr mit zwei Terabyte irgendwie Fortschritte. Platten sind jetzt einfach 50% größer. Und ich finde das Ding an sich schon jetzt nicht so günstig.
Also ich hätte jetzt eher damit gerechnet, dass sie noch ein bisschen...
Die nutzen jetzt langsam ihr Monopol aus.
Ja, und ich meine immerhin, gerade wenn du so so ein Device als Router verwendest. Ich frage mich, wie die Leute das heutzutage eigentlich machen, weil wenn du heute eine DSL-Leitung bestellst, dann kriegst du ja teilweise noch nicht mal mehr einen Modem. Du kriegst nur so einen fertigen Router dazu, wo das Modem mit drin ist. Und den du auch nicht unbedingt als Modem-only konfigurieren kannst. Bei Addis ist das zum Beispiel so. Wenn du das Ding jetzt halt nicht...
Ach doch, grenzt er. Aber musst du hacken.
Naja, aber es gibt jetzt keinen Schalter außen, wo du sagst Modem-only oder Software, wo du das umschalten kannst. Das Ding tut es einfach so out of the box nicht. Sondern du müsstest da anfangen, die Chips zu schleifen. Und dann denkst du dir halt, na dann nehm ich doch meinen Apple-Teil. Das Ding ist einfach gar nicht in der Lage, mit einem DSL zu reden, wenn da halt nicht ein Modem dazwischen ist. So eine Fritzbox kommt halt mit Modem daher. Zumindest so für immer was so gerade so aktuell ist. Und das aktuelle High-End-Modell bei Fritz ist ja auch mit VDSL schon gesegnet. Und da hat halt Apple irgendwie nix. Es gibt auch keinen Apple DSL- Modem zu kaufen. Und es gibt auch sonst eigentlich so DSL-Modems, weiß nicht, gibt es DSL-Modems so zu kaufen, auch nicht wirklich. Du kannst auch solche Autos, die das... Gibt's dedizierte Geräte, die nur DSL-Modem sind?
Na klar, hab ich zu Hause. 1000 Massenfachwerden verschickt von allen Firmen inzwischen.
Nicht mehr?
Ja gut, eBay ist voll davon.
Naja, aber VDSL?
Naja, aber da weißt du immer nicht, was du kaufen kannst, was du irgendwie mit deinem DSL aufwirkst.
Siemens ADSL2 Plus.
DCOM TeleDAT 431 LAN DSL-Modem. Ach, gibt's auch nur gebraucht.
Da bin ich ja echt ganz froh, dass ich da so bei Kübel Deutschland mit meinem schönen Kabelmodem diese ganzen Probleme ja gar nicht habe.
Consta DSL Box 2 für 21 Euro.
Dieses DSL, ach, ich hab schon tatsächlich jetzt so nach, ich hab jetzt bestimmt ein halbes Jahr Kabel Deutschland Internet und ich bin ja echt eigentlich sehr zufrieden und bin wirklich sehr froh, dass ich dieses PPPoE und dieses Ganze graffellos bin.
Ok, ich sag nichts, es gibt DSL Modems einfach so zu kaufen.
Ich mal wenige.
Noch nicht mal teuer.
Ja, wenn es nicht teuer ist, dann kaufst du sogar nichts.
Gibt es das auch in teuer?
Ich verkaufe dir eins für 200 Euro, wo ein Apple-Logo drauf ist.
Eine Telekom kostet immerhin 60 Euro. Achso, ok, Speedports und so weiter, alles klar. Ich nehme alles zurück. Ja, wir aber trotzdem irgendwie Quatsch, weil das kommt ja im Prinzip jetzt noch dazu.
Du kannst ja auch einen DSL-Modem, du kannst auch einen Router mit DSL-Modem mit reinkaufen.
Können die irgendwas Tolles hier, solche Teile?
Nein, die sollen ja auch nichts können.
Ich denke, da geht es darum, dass die nichts können.
Das ist Technologie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend. Also da hat sich auch wirklich nicht wahnsinnig viel getan, glaube ich, in der Zwischenzeit.
Außerdem, wie gesagt, sowas kauft man nicht in neu, da geht man zu Ebay, weil natürlich alle ihre Geräte behalten, nie zurückschicken und die noch für den Fimber verkloppen wollen.
Aber die gehen auch kaputt mittlerweile, die scheiß Dinger.
Ja, die gehen kaputt. Deswegen ist meiner zu Hause auch. Der ist offen. Habe ich den Deckel abgenommen und habe auf den Hauptchip, wo man sich die Finger dran verbrennen würde, habe ich so einen Kühlkörper draufgeklatscht, weil nämlich bekannt ist, dass die abrauchen, weil die zu heiß werden. Und meiner tut einfach. Auf dem Chip, ja.
Irgendwie so einen kleinen Kühlkörper rumliegen, den habe ich da einfach draufgetitscht.
Besser als Lüfter.
Ja, spannend.
Wir haben echt geile Themen. Das dreht sich um Festplatten. Ich finde auch immer noch sehr fragwürdig, dass da nur eine Platte drin ist, weil es kein Backup ist. Wenn dir eine Platte kaputt geht, dann ist dein ganzes Backup in Arsch.
Du kannst ja über USB immerhin eine externe Platte anschließen und darauf per Airport-Utility sagen, mach mal einen Backup auf diese externe Platte. Allerdings...
Bei der Time-Capsule.
Bei der Time-Capsule. Allerdings, was ich nicht gefunden habe, ist, dass wenn dir deine Platte wirklich abgeraucht ist und du hast da eine neue Time-Capsule mit einer leeren Platte, eine Funktion, mit der du dieses Backup auch wieder zurückspülen kannst. Das ist irgendwie nicht vorgesehen.
Was passiert, wenn man diese Platte dann anschließt an Mac?
Na, das mountet dann irgendwie. Aber dann musstest du es dann halt over the air da Daten drauf spielen.
Diese Time-Capsule...
Und dann ist das ja auch so ein Time-Machine-Backup mit Hardlinks. Und Hardlinks kriegste halt mal nicht eben über AFP übertragen.
Nee, ich meine, wenn du diese Platte, die du dann da hast, diese USB-Platte, diese externe, wenn du dann die wieder an Mac anschließt.
Naja, dann siehst du die Daten. Aber du willst ja deine Time-Capsule wieder in diesen Zustand bringen, dass sie weiterhin das tut, was sie vorher getan hat mit der gesamten Historie. Und diese Funktion existiert nicht.
Sonst fängst du ja wieder an, deine 500 GB von vorne.
Also du hast ein Backup, aber du hast nicht ein Spiel, ein Backup wieder ein.
Also das bestätigt meine These, du hast eigentlich mit dieser Time-Capsule keinen Backup. Also hast du aber, wenn es halt in den Arsch geht...
Brauchst du einen Experten.
Wenn es halt in den Arsch geht, dann...
Ja, aber dann brauchst du wirklich jemanden, der genau weiß, was Sache ist.
Dann hast du es immer noch auf deiner externen Platte.
Besser als nüscht.
Aber das machen ja auch die wenigsten.
Ja, aber du willst ja auch wieder...
Die wenigsten machen überhaupt einen Backup. Es macht überhaupt niemanden. Also es gibt nur ganz wenige Leute, die überhaupt einen Backup machen.
Das wird alles anders mit der iCloud.
Ja, das will ich auch gerade sagen.
Warum sexelt ihr, wenn ihr iCloud sagt?
Ich weiß auch nicht. Ich glaub, sie ist alles so sexisch, diese iCloud.
Da ist aber so ein kleiner Tipp. Denis, wie heißt denn dieser Typ, der hier FreeBSD, der diesen Backup-Service über Amazon S3 gemacht hat, mit äh... Da gibt es so einen... Da weiß ich ja gar nichts von. Doch, das gibt es auch, glaube ich, für...
Für Menschen über S3? Für Leute mit zu viel Geld?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Ist das ein Command Line Tool?
Ne.
Und das läuft, glaube ich, sogar auch auf Mac und so allen anderen POSIX-Systemen und das Backup dann auf Amazon S3. Das war von irgendeinem FreeBSD-Typ hier, aber da komme ich jetzt gerade überhaupt nicht mehr drauf.
Ein Bekannter oder wie?
Aber falls Tarsnip, was ist das? Klick mal da drauf. Ich klick da drauf. Egal.
So.
Wir klicken nochmal kurz und dann.
Was wollen wir denn eigentlich für ein Device haben, vom Apfel?
Na eins mit schon mal zwei Platten drin oder so ein Mirror, wäre ja auch mal... Was soll denn, dann kannst du die eh nicht austauschen. Ach weiß ich nicht. Also dieses auf so einen kleinen Plastikkasten, wo man nicht rankommt und wo nur eine Platte drin ist und...
Direkt dann da mit DSL hängt. Firewall und Daten-Backup in einem. Ja, ist alles irgendwie...
Also es ist nicht so appealing für mich zumindest. Hasnap, genau. Für Allo-Esser. Und gecryptet. das, was man da bezahlt für den Storage von dem Backup, geht auch in Teilen entweder hier einfach für dieses Projekt oder ich glaube sogar auch an FreeBSD.
Was ist Hasnap?
Es ist secure Online-Backup-Service von BSD Linux und OS X in Solaris. Kannst du dir einfach in die Show-Notes mal reinlinken, können sich die Leute mal angucken. Wir filmen jetzt nur gerade einen wegen Backup und so weiter.
Was heißt, mit Krypte, der verschlüsselt lokal, schiebt es dann hoch. Die können bei Amazon auch nichts damit anfangen und dann holt es auch von da wieder einschlüsselt und zack, fertig.
So war die Ansage.
Nur jetzt in ordentlich, in bunt, mit GUI, in schick, mit Schatten.
ist jetzt nicht appealing für Mutti und Fadi, aber kann man sich mal angucken. Der hat, also ich kann mich glaube ich erinnern, als er mir das letzte Mal das angeschaut hat, war das auch irgendwie alles ganz smart gelöst, so. Ich hab's jetzt auch noch nicht benutzt, von daher. Aber so als kleiner Tipp für die Show-Notes.
Für die Bastler.
Und man zahlt hier nur für Storage und Bandwidth.
Genau, also es geht halt über Amazon und der macht sozusagen den Mittelsmann und zwar er hat sowieso bessere Preise als Amazon, weil er irgendwie da Reseller-Preise kriegt und kriegt halt irgendwie ein Prozent oder so oder so ein kleiner Mini-Betrag geht halt entweder an das Projekt oder an FreeBSD.
Die hat bessere Preise als Amazon.
Ich glaube, 30 Cent.
Also S3 kostet normalerweise so 17 oder 18 Cent.
Aber bis welche Größe?
Pro Gigabyte.
Na gut, vielleicht war es doch anders. Oder Amazon ist mittlerweile billiger geworden und die FreeBSD von der Haitian oder R kriegt jetzt mehr davon, also muss man nochmal durchlesen. Da bin ich jetzt nicht voll im Bilde.
Gigabyte-Monat.
Toll, dass... Ah ja, genau, da waren irgendwie... Da war irgendwie so ein Konzept dabei, was irgendwie immer ein bisschen was anderes war. Aber auf jeden Fall jute, dass der Chat am Start war und diesen Link sofort aus meinem Gedächtnis gefischt hat.
Voll toll.
Dieses Mind-Reading-Interface für den Irrkanal funktioniert super.
Lob dem Chat. So, was haben wir jetzt noch? Jetzt könnten wir mal langsam zu den Apple-ähnlichen Themen kommen. Über Macs reden und ein bisschen softiger werden.
Wir haben letztes Mal so viel über Mac geredet, dass wir jetzt nur noch nachtragen können.
Ein bisschen mal nachtragen.
Dann lass uns doch schnell nachtragen, da haben wir ja die Line-Karte, da waren wir ja letztens dann Max, Sie haben das Wort.
Achso, nee, das hat jetzt eigentlich... Ich hab das Wort.
Hier mit dem Arc, das wird mich ja schon mal interessieren.
Das mit dem Arc, ja, genau. Ich dachte beim letzten Mal, da darf man nichts drüber erzählen, weil es unter dem NDA stehen würde, aber steht gar nicht.
Nee, steht bei Apple auf der Seite.
Bei Apple auf der Seite kann man quasi vorlesen. Das ist das Automatic Reference Counting. Und zwar ist das so für Total-Anfänger wie mich jetzt die Anfang mit der iOS-Programmierung und kein Bock auf dieses Retain und Release haben. Also man muss sich ja doch beim iOS relativ weitgehend um die Speicherverwaltung selber kümmern. Auch wenn es jetzt relativ elegant gelöst ist, also viel besser als Anno dazubahlen, muss man trotzdem noch darum kümmern, dass man das nicht plötzlich der Pointer ins Leere zeigt oder dass man irgendwo seinen Speicher liegen lässt und nie wieder frei räumt. Und dafür hat Apple was eingebaut gehabt, oder Objective-C, das heißt Reference Counting. Und das haben wir jetzt automatisiert. Jetzt liegt da eine neue LLVM-Version bei, bei dem iOS SDK und auch bei dem Xcode, mit dem man dann, dass sich darum, dass sich sozusagen automatisch um den Speicherverwaltung, die Verwaltung für einen kümmert. Und zwar nicht wie bei Garbage Collection, erst zur Laufzeit, sondern schon beim Kompilieren. Also im Wesentlichen bauen die wahrscheinlich das Retain, oder die bauen das Retain und Release dann auf Compiler-Ebene ein. Was dazu führt, dass es auch mit iOS 4 funktioniert. Und für mich ist das voll super, weil wenn jetzt für mich alles gut läuft, dann brauch ich dieses Retain- und Release-Konzept nie mehr zu lernen.
Herr Jungermann, ja, das ist ja grundsätzlich schonmal der falsche Ansatz. Also erstmal gehst du dir noch mal schön Assembler angucken, weil wenn man das kann...
Ich hab lang genug in meinem Leben, ich hab genug in Assembler gemacht, um zu wissen, was ich nicht mehr machen möchte.
Dann kriegst du es mit dem Retain und Release auch noch hin.
Aber wie funktioniert das genau? Das hab ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden. Also ich meine, wenn ich es richtig mitbekommen habe, das Ganze ist ja im Wesentlichen ein Feature von LLVM. Genau. Da wir jetzt generell auf LLVM gehen, ist das sozusagen etwas, was diese VM macht. So, um aber Reference Counting automatisch zu machen, müssen sie ja diese References kennen und wissen, wann eine Referenz nicht mehr besteht. Sonst können sie es nicht automatisch counten. Also ich meine, sie merken, dass eine Referenz wegfällt und dann...
Na, du bist ja sagen wir mal in einer Methode drin und du hast da irgendwie ein Objekt und der weiß, wenn das aus der Methode rausläuft und dein Return irgendwie dieses Objekt nicht weiterreicht, dass das irgendwie nicht weiter benutzt wird. Zumindestens nicht von der Methode. Das heißt, der Reference Count, der in der Methode um eins hochgesetzt wird, weil das benutzt, kann dann sozusagen am Ende auch wieder eins runtergezählt werden.
Und die Garbage Collection, die sie dem Mac OS X vor kurzem spendiert haben, hat genau dasselbe gemacht?
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich halt nicht auf Compiler-Ebene, sondern in Runtime.
Das heißt, die haben eigentlich das...
Die haben das so gesammelt und irgendwann plötzlich meinte die Garbage Collection, oh Gott, da ist jetzt voll viel abzuarbeiten und dann steht das erst mal alles kurz, weil das ist nämlich der Nachteil von der Garbage Collection.
Naja, nicht von allen, ja.
Ja, die das gibt ja gut und schlecht und so weiter, aber schon immer so ein bisschen das Problem war, dass ab und zu kann es sein, dass die jetzt plötzlich zuschlägt an einen Zeitpunkt, wo es gerade ungünstig ist. Wobei es natürlich sein kann, dass das mit dieser neuen Automatik, ich weiß ja nicht, wann die zugreift, dass es da vielleicht auch der Fall ist. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, aber die scheint es ja mehr so fein grain pro Methode zu machen. Und wahrscheinlich ist es halt eben nicht, dass sie so zuschlägt wie die Garbage Collection.
Nee, also wenn sie es auf Compiler-Ebene machen, dann ist das ja nicht in einem Runtime drinnen, sondern ich vermute mal, dass die einfach das Retain und Release sozusagen an den richtigen Stellen für dich in den Code reinschreiben. Also du hast ja, wir haben ja vorhin schon mal kurz darüber gesprochen, du hast ja, so kompliziert ist es ja eigentlich gar nicht. Also du brauchst ja, also dieses Retain musst du ja nur, wenn du es an zum Beispiel ein anderes Objekt übergibst. Und da musst du, gibst eben zwei, also wenn man eine Property anlegt, ein Objective-C, dann muss man dir jetzt sagen, ob man das, ob man das Strong zuweisen will, mit einem Retain oder Weak, ohne Retain, sozusagen.
Also sie haben dafür einfach ein anderes Vokabular sich ausgedacht und Also hier im Chat ist einer schon ganz hektisch und meinte, man sollte doch die Developer Tools Kickoff-Video-Geschichte sich angucken, weil es da voll erklärt wird.
Ja, die hab ich noch nicht geschafft zu sehen. Tim kann ja eh nicht gucken, weil der hat keinen Account.
Da musst du gar keinen Account haben.
Und ich bin auch dafür, dass du dich kostenlos registrieren kannst. Bei Apple auf der Developer-Seite und dann kriegst du die Videos um die Ohren. Ich hab da auch schon fleißig geguckt.
Und das Kickoff aber nicht?
Developer Tools Kickoff habe ich nicht gesehen, nein. Aber ich hab mir ein paar andere Sachen schon angeschaut, aber ich bin noch nicht sehr weit gekommen. Das ist schon alles wieder mal sehr interessant, was sie da tun. Ich bin immer wieder erfreut zu sehen, wie viel Hand und Fuß das alles hat, was sie da auf Compiler-Ebene tun. Also dieser Progress, insbesondere mit diesem LLVM, jetzt auch mit dem Debugger und so weiter. Ich meine, sie haben es jetzt geschafft. Mit diesem ganzen LLVM-Projekt, ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht im eigentlichen Sinne Apples Verdienst. Weil LLVM ist ja unabhängig von Apple losgetreten worden. Das ist nur so, ich glaube, da haben wir schon ein paar Mal drüber geredet hier, dass der Typ, der das erfunden hat, ich habe jetzt seinen Namen gerade vergessen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er das erfunden hat, dieser Chris Lettner.
Jaja, der hat das gestartet.
Startet oder erfunden auch wirklich?
Nee, der hat sich irgendwann mal hingesetzt, hat gesagt, wir müssen mal über VMs reden. Wir müssen mal wieder über VMs reden. Und das muss man doch irgendwie mal anders machen. Das ist halt sehr low-level VM. Das heißt, er hat sozusagen dieses ganze, hat eigentlich diese high-level VMs, so wie Java und eben diese super low-Ebene, wo der Compiler Bytecode erzeugt, den er dann letzten Endes in Assembler Code umsetzt. Diese beiden Konzepte sind in LLVM verschmolzen. Das ist jetzt ein sehr abstraktes Bild auf diese ganze Situation, aber so muss man sich das vorstellen. Das ist einfach eine Abstraktion, eine umfangreiche Abstraktion dieser allerniedrigsten Schicht um den Prozessor herum, die so bisher keine Abstraktion hatte. Das war einfach wild wuchs, jeder Compiler hat es anders gemacht, etc., Und jetzt ist es eben sprachenübergreifend, etc., Plug-in-fähig und deswegen wächst diese ganze Infrastruktur so. Und vor allem haben sie, als der halt mal bei Apple auf der Mailingliste angeklopft hat und gesagt hat, hier, sagen wir mal, Objective-C, wie macht ihr das da eigentlich mit dem und dem und so, weil ich brauche nämlich gerade hier so was, dann haben sie ihn ja gleich gekauft. Ich habe so, was machst du? Komm mal mal vorbei!
Komm mal ran auf den Meter!
Wie viel willst du verdienen? Hier, setz dich hin irgendwie. Dann haben sie irgendwie ein bisschen den Popo gestreichelt.
Und Schailer auf dem Schreibtisch gefilmt.
Und vor allem haben sie einfach dieses Projekt. Ich meine, mittlerweile ist der Typ halt Head of Compiler Chain. Also sie haben den Typen geholt und er ist einfach derjenige, der sagt, wie Software übersetzt wird. Im Apple-Universum. Das ist mal ganz einfach.
Und der Witz ist, Microsoft hatte den Typen auch schon mal am Start.
Er hat bei Microsoft gearbeitet?
Ne, ne, ne, die haben sich das auch angeguckt. Und haben ihn nicht gleich weggekauft.
Kann er halt nicht dort net, ne?
Wir haben wahrscheinlich das Potential nicht gesehen.
Keine Ahnung. Also Apple hat das Potential auf jeden Fall gesehen.
So.
Und dann haben sie diese ganze Sparte so sehr gefüttert, dass jetzt auch alles andere, was sie sich in diesem Projekt vorgenommen haben, Realität geworden ist innerhalb weniger Jahre. Die haben den kompletten C GNU C-Compiler ersetzt. Die haben einen viel besseren C++-Compiler. Sie parsen irgendwie C-Code wahnsinnig. Und vor allem haben sie mit dem ganzen Compiler ein Level, ein Detail in der Fehleranalyse rausgeholt, den es so vorher noch nie gab. Also das ist ja nicht nur so, dass er irgendwelche obskure Fehlermeldungen ausmacht, sondern du hast so...
Und was macht Apple die Verkackungs mit Xcode 3? Ne, 4. Xcode 4.
Ja, aber da sind ja diese ganzen Sachen auch eingebaut, ne? Also Xcode 4. Benutzt die Parsa von LLVM et cetera.
Ich kann nur sagen, also Final Cut Pro X ist das, was Xcode 4 ist.
Ich finde Xcode 4 super.
Alles neu und es ist total schlimm. Also Xcode 4 ist genau das gleiche los wie bei Final Cut X.
Also ich habe auch tatsächlich einige Leute, die sich über Xcode beschweren, weil irgendwann zwischendurch irgendwie das Syntax- Highlighting nicht geht, dann irgendwie muss der Xcode neu starten, dann irgendwie die Warnings oder Build and Analyze gibt dir auch manchmal irgendwelchen...
Crashed wie Sau.
Crashed zurück.
Crashed.
Also es geht schon in die richtige Richtung, aber es ist aktuell auch immer noch wohl nicht so...
Na ja gut, auf jeden Fall dieses LLVM-Projekt hat halt das geschafft, was glaube ich viele gar nicht mehr für möglich gehalten haben oder nicht mehr geglaubt haben daran zu wagen, dass einfach dieses ganze GNU C, dieses ganze GCC Imperium einfach aufgelöst wird. Apple benutzt das jetzt nicht mehr. Vor allem, die erste vollständige Compiler Toolchain ist nicht nur besser als das, was du in dem ganzen GCC Universum hast, das ist auch alles noch BSD lizenziert. Das heißt, du kannst das jetzt eben in deine kommerziellen IDE und andere Systeme integrieren, was eben so vorher nicht möglich war. Naja, ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht so sehr über den Klee loben. Tatsache ist, da passiert eine ganze Menge und solche Sachen wie dieses Automatik-Reference-Counting ist einfach so ein Langzeiterfolg dieser Grundlage, die sie da gelegt haben. Also weil dieses System einfach so viel weiß über den Code, der da auf niedrigster Ebene ausgeführt wird, können sie sogar sowas realisieren.
Das hat man vorher auch schon gemerkt, wenn du mit LLFM was compilst, dann kann der dir sagen, ja hier, du hast ja ein Objekt geholt und du releasest das ja gar nicht. Das würde der GCC gar nicht wissen, weil er von der Sprache irgendwie, was er da genau macht, eigentlich gar keine Ahnung hat. Und der LLFM sagt auf einmal, ja hier, ist aber, was bist du für ein Idiot hast. So geht es aber nicht. Dann denkst du auch schon, oh der versteht das ein bisschen, was ich da mache und das war schon ganz cool. Jetzt versteht das nicht nur, sondern er macht das auch gleich für einen. Hey du Idiot hast du vergessen, ich mach das mal für dich.
Das heißt, diese Garbage Collection, die sie vorher hatten, war quasi so eine Art Prototyp.
In der Runtime, genau.
Für das, was sie jetzt komplett in LLFM gelegt haben, aber sie konnten es erst dann legen in dem Moment, wo eben auch ihre ganze Chain vollständig LLFM basiert ist, was sie jetzt eben ist.
Aber es gab auch irgendwie Leute, die meinten, dass hier so Reference Counting jetzt kein echter Ersatz oder vollständiger Ersatz für Garbage Collection wäre oder so. Also, dass man durchaus immer noch Garbage Collection benötigen könnte oder so.
Entweder du machst das von Hand oder du machst dieses Automatic Reference Counting oder du machst halt Garbage Collection. Das ist halt die Frage, was man so haben will. Klar ist irgendwie, dass die Garbage Collection immer irgendwie... Du musst dich zwar nicht kümmern, aber die kann halt im falschen Moment zuschlagen und sie kostet halt minimal Performance. Ist ein bisschen wie Automatikgetriebe früher. Und ja, und Retain und Release ist so ein bisschen wie Handschalten. Kannst halt eine Menge rausholen, musst aber auch genau wissen, was du da tust. Und es könnte sein, dass jetzt dieses... Das ist Automatic Reference Counting. Oder dass die modernen Automatikgetriebe sind, wo alles irgendwie flutscht und du noch sogar mehr spritzbarst, als wenn du selber machen würdest.
Ich glaube, so Garbage Collection, die kann noch mal was rausholen, wenn es eine gute Garbage Collection ist, wo dieses, wenn du es total verkackt hast. Also wenn du zum Beispiel schaffst, dass da zwei Objekte, die nur auf sich gegenseitig verweisen und die dann im leeren Raum hängen. Genau.
Das lösen die aber auch schon auf die guten Garbage Collection.
Ja, eine gute... Aber hier, das kann ARC, glaube ich, sagt, alles klar, da ist noch der Retain Count, ist noch eins, eins, eins, ich behalte den, ich gebe den Speicher nicht wieder frei.
Weiß ich nicht, muss man sich angucken.
Klar, kann man machen, aber, und das kriegt eine gute Garbage Collection hin.
Was ich ja eigentlich auch noch ganz schick fand, hier bei diesen ganzen WWDC-Video-Gedöns, irgendwie, machen eigentlich andere Firmen das auch? Also jetzt war ja das erste Mal, dass die Videos auch sowieso relativ schnell und relativ breit irgendwie verfügbar waren, also das halt auch...
Letztes Jahr auch schon so.
Auch kostenlos irgendwie registrieren?
Ja, ja, ja.
Machen das andere Firmen eigentlich auch so? Ich meine, die Videos sind ja auch echt supergute Qualität und ich meine, die...
Naja, supergute Qualität von so Slides halt.
Ja, aber... also es ist ja...
Es gibt auch immer so ein paar, die sind wirklich so mit Video, also sind ja nicht nur Slides.
Diese Keynotes.
Mehr nicht, da hören wir noch schon ein paar andere.
Ich dachte letztes Mal auch, dass mehr werden. Aber egal.
Ich meine nur so diese Keynote-Style, Overview, Tra-la-la, State of the...
Ich glaube, es ist eine Audio-Spur, wo sie ab und zu mal das Bild wechseln, aber es ist tatsächlich ein Video. Ist auch schon ganz schön lame, was man da an Bandbreite sparen könnte.
Also auf jeden Fall finde ich ja cool, dass sie ihre Entwickler-Horden auch mehr und mehr mal bilden. Und denen beibringen, wie man mal ordentlich abschreibt. Das kann uns allen nur dienlich sein.
Naja, Apple vor allen Dingen auch.
Ich bin immer davon total beeindruckt, dass sie nicht nur Leute haben, die jetzt in einer Lage sind, guten Kurz zu machen. Sondern dass sie auch noch Leute haben, die in der Lage sind, darüber eine Stunde einen knackigen Vortrag zu halten, der verständlich ist.
Apple University.
Ich weiß nicht, wo lernen die das? Nehmen die nur Leute, die das können oder bringen dir das denen bei? Oder ist das einfach so in den USA?
Ich vermute mal, dass die intern auch so viele Schulungen machen. Ich meine, wenn irgendwie ein Team was entwickelt, dann musst du es ja auch den anderen Teams vorstellen intern. Du brauchst ja auch eine interne Kommunikation. Ich nehme an, dass die da schon aus den Teams jeweils gute Leute rauspicken, die dann da schon rausgefiltert werden und die dann auch auf der WBC dastehen.
Und außerdem haben die doch sowieso immer ihre Evangelisten, die diese weltweit rumschicken, die dann oder die so ansagen, dass jetzt hier in irgendeinem Hotel wieder oder was auch immer dann so Vorträge sind, dann schicken ja auch immer diese Apple-Leute rum und die erklären einem was. Und dann, wenn du mit denen Quatsch hörst, ganz genau, dass das wirklich deren täglich Brot ist, sind nicht welche, die nur da Folien vorlesen, sondern es sind die, die wirklich da rumkoden.
Naja, aber ihr werdet ja auch schon mal Vorträge von Entwicklern gehört haben, ich sag nur Kongress. Was man da teilweise...
Ja, aber auf Kongress sind auch wirklich viele, die das zum ersten Mal machen, die machen es halt eben.
Aber mir fällt schon noch, dass die Amerikaner das in der Regel viel besser machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob die irgendwie Coaches nehmen, gibt es ja auch die Profession der Speaker-Coaches und so, und da gibt es ja in Amiland auch hier und da wohl mal eine Konferenz, wo die Speaker tatsächlich auch das in Anspruch nehmen können, mal eine Stunde mit so einem Coach, eine Session vorherzumachen, bevor sie auf die Bühne gehen. Vielleicht ist das auch so ein Mentalitätsding so, weil irgendwie so viele europäische Speaker und so, die sind echt sau schlecht, sprechen leise, sind schüchtern, und dann hast du irgendwie so Amerikaner, die machen eine Show und nehmen dich mit, und hast du nicht gesehen, als wäre das gar nichts.
Ja, aber die Talks sind ja auch in sich gut aufgebaut, ja, Slide folgt auf Slide, wo wirklich ganz, also die sind in der Lage, ihre Konzepte auch so zu entfalten, dass das vollkommen nachvollziehbar ist. Ich hab bisher noch kein einziges Video dabei in der Apple WWDC gesehen, was nicht diesen Anforderungen entsprach. Ist nicht so, dass da mal eins war, wo man...
Die haben bestimmt selber Coaching...
Na ja, irgendwie kann ich mir das nicht anders vorstellen.
Also aus dem Bude, da klagen sie da irgendeinen, der sich um sowas kümmert.
Aber ich hab auch schon von WWDC-Sessions gehört, womit mittendrin der Akku von dem vorführenden Laptop alle war und dann niemand ein Ladegerät dabei hatte und so eine Späße.
Dann kommt der Sensor mal irgendwie.
Die mussten sie abgeben an der Tür. Darf ich noch einen ganz kurzen Nachtrag... Also sind wir jetzt damit fertig, bevor ich jetzt hier wieder dazwischen vorgehe? Bei Tar Snap ist dieses Pricing-Modell besonders, weil wenn du einmal 5 Dollar beweist für das initiale Speicherplatzvolumen und darüber nie hinaus gehst, dann bezahlst du auch nicht mehr. Obwohl das bei Amazon liegt, musst du dann nicht monatlich für deine 5 Gigabyte bezahlen, sondern du zahlst halt einmal für deinen Initial Storage und dann steht hier irgendwie...
Doch, da steht Gigabyte pro Monat.
Tar Snap ist built only based on actual usage. If you only store a small amount of data, a 5 Dollar payment might last 4 years.
Ja, das ist auch klar, wenn du nur 1 Gigabyte brauchst, und das 30 Cent kostet und du hast aber 5 Dollar bezahlt, dann hält das natürlich irgendwie 15 Jahre.
Wenn du da 2 Terabyte liegen hast, dann zahlst du jeden Monat den Platz für den Storage, den da liegt. Ist nicht so, dass du das einfach da hinlegen kannst, sondern dann ist es so lang kostlos, bis du es abbrust. Sie haben jetzt bloß keinen zusätzlichen Fee darüber hinaus. Du zahlst nicht noch mal eine Task-Nap-Pegue, um überhaupt Kunde sein zu dürfen, sondern nur für das, was du da wirklich hast. Und wenn du weniger Daten da hast, dann... Also das muss man schon bedenken. Aber das kann sich ja trotzdem rechnen. Vor allem... Also ich würde das zum Beispiel... Was ich halt gerne hätte, wäre... Es hat mich vorhin vergessen. Ich meine, so ZFS hier, das ist natürlich das eine. Man kann natürlich immer die Hütte abbrennen. Und was ich halt noch gerne hätte, ist halt so ein Syncing. So ein ZFS-Snapshot zu einem anderen ZFS. Das heißt, wenn ich irgendwie eine Büchse in der Cloud hätte, was weiß ich, so ein EC2, dass du da so deinen FreeBSD in der Wolke hast und das kannst du so aus der Ferne, fährst du das hoch, so zack, jetzt da, weil ich will dir jetzt hier Synken. Dann synkst du da eben mal den Snapshot hoch einmal am Tag und dann fährst du die Instanz wieder runter, sodass die irgendwie nur für diese kurze Zeit läuft und sonst keine Kosten aufruft.
Dann brauchst du aber trotzdem noch den Speicher, wo du es auf den Chips...
Aber du musst halt kein Gerät...
Ja, das wär halt geil, weil du kriegst ja von Amazon noch Block-Storage. Dann kannst du dir sozusagen irgendwie 500 GB oder einen Terabyte Block-Storage da mieten und dir das in dein EC2 ran mounten und dann damit ein ZSF...
Bittiger, diese Block-Storage?
Ich glaube, aber ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ich guck mal, weil das ist... So richtig billig wird das leider nicht.
Übrigens ist Tarsnap auch eins der wenigen Projekte, sehe ich gerade, die Bug-Bounties ausgeben von 1 Dollar bis 2000 Dollar, wenn jemand einen Bug findet. Hat mich letztens nämlich irgendjemand mal gefragt, ob das irgendjemand außer DJB noch tut. Small Default, alles hier am Start.
So, kommen wir mal wieder zurück. Entschuldigung, ich muss mich entschuldigen für diesen kleinen Ausflug, aber...
Nee, dafür sind wir ja bekannt, berühmt und berüchtigt, sage ich mal.
Ja, da haben wir uns zumindest nicht vergessen. Aber vielleicht noch mal zurück zu Lion und überhaupt diesem ganzen Developer-Kram und so. Was sich ja auch so abzeichnet am Firmament, ist diese Sandbox. Die ist ja technisch schon lange gab. Die meines Wissens mit Snow Leopard das erste Mal.
Ja, ich glaube mit Leopard schon.
War die schon bei Leopard?
Nur nicht so richtig in Benutzung.
Naja, sie haben das für ihre System-Demonen, so für den...
Quick Look zum Beispiel.
Ja, und natürlich im Safari, beziehungsweise... Aber das war doch erst Snow Leopard, glaube ich. Und der Launch-D. Also diese super kleinen Miniprozesse, die auch eine ganz klar definierte Aktivität haben, die sie nie überschreiten. Ich bin ein NTP-Server, ich muss nicht mehr als Netzwerk-Traffic machen, weil ich schreibe nur sowas hin, etc. Und da haben sie das dann zum ersten Mal zum Einsatz gebracht. Das heißt, da existierte das technisch schon. Dann kam es irgendwie bei iOS auch mit durch.
Oder da sogar zuerst, als war ja noch kurz vor Leopard.
Vielleicht sogar, das stimmt, das war eigentlich sogar noch davor. Und wie auch immer, jetzt kommt es auf jeden Fall back to the Mac in den App-Store, wie es den Anschein hat, dass künftig Programme zumindest, wie ich es richtig verstanden habe, unter LINE dann eben, gibt es eine Pflicht, dieses Handbox zu nehmen, oder ist das noch optional?
Das ist einfach eine Pflicht, das kann man wohl nicht anders sagen.
Wird man nicht automatisch in eine reingepackt, oder wie untersucht man sich dasselbe aus?
Ja, aber du musst dann eben als Entwickler eben sagen, was dein Programm so für ein Profil hat. Aber das Ziel ist halt vor allem, dass du so in deinem Container existierst.
Ja, das finde ich voll gut. Zeit wird's.
Es wird Pflicht.
Das ist an sich cool.
Wobei ich noch nicht so genau verstanden habe, wie das ist mit, also man kann ja wohl angehen, ich möchte gern auf Netzwerk zugreifen und so weiter, ob man nicht einfach die Möglichkeit hat zu sagen, ich möchte gern auf die volle Platte zugreifen und dass dann einfach, dass dann irgendwie davor gewarnt wird oder ähnliches, bevor man dann den Zugriff tatsächlich durchführt.
Also, also bevor du die abstartest, der sagt dir hier, der passt oft die ab, aber...
Diese Art von Dialogen wollen sie nicht haben. Sie wollen nicht dieses, dieses Programm braucht irgendwie vollen Zugriff auf deine Unterhose, um irgendwie was zu tun. Ja, nein, was so generell die Frage ist, möchtest du jetzt, dass dieses Programm läuft oder nicht?
Das will man nicht haben, das ist ungestimmt.
Das will man halt nicht haben. Und wie Apple das halt angeht, scheint so zu sein, dass sie quasi automatisch Rechte zugreifen auf Basis von Interaktionen. Sagen wir mal, du hast so ein Programm, das ist in seiner Sandbox, und du möchtest jetzt aber, dass es irgendwie ein Programm öffnet. Dann machst du einfach drag und drop auf deinen Desktop, legst diese Datei auf dieses Programm-Icon im Dock und damit wird automatisch gesagt, ab jetzt darf dieses Programm auf die Datei zugreifen, weil der User will das.
Naja, das ist jetzt nichts total Neues. Ich kannte schon Java. Also wenn du so ein Java-Desktop-App hattest, das konnte, und das wollte eine Datei öffnen, also es durfte ja so ein Java-Programm da fernommen, oder so diese, wie hießen diese? Dieses Webstart, das konnte ja auch so was aus dem Netz runterladen und dann konnte das ja auch nicht per se auf deinen Desktop zugreifen oder auf dein Dateisystem. Aber wenn du was über einen öffnen Dialog sozusagen eine Datei geöffnet hast und gesagt hast, hier diese Datei ist es, dann durfte das... Dann durfte der darauf zugreifen. Und so ähnlich ist es jetzt mit der Sandbox auch.
Ja, jetzt gibt es so ein bisschen Wegklagen bei so Programmen, die halt so viel auf dem Fallsystem machen. Da kennen sie diese ganzen Cleaner und Duplicate Finder und...
Aber gibt es dann das Terminal dann auch in der Sandbox?
Ne, ich hoffe, also...
Ja, mir sind die Implikationen noch nicht so ganz klar, aber ich meine, sie versuchen auf jeden Fall, Mac OS X so dicht zu kriegen, wie es nur irgendwie geht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie unbedingt eine Mac OS X so dicht kriegen wollen, wie es geht. Ich glaube, sie wollen diesen Store so dicht kriegen, wie es geht. Das ist zumindest meine Hoffnung im Augenblick. Solange es sich nur um den Store dreht, kann ich damit leben. Das finde ich sogar gut. Dann bringt das für den User eine ganze Menge. Solange ich als Power-User noch in meinem Mac OS weiter rumfriemeln kann, wie ich will, bin ich glücklich.
Wenn sie die abstellen, dann können sie gleich dicht machen.
Aber so dieses, dass ich über einen App-Store, dass ich irgendwo draufklicken kann, sage, installiere mir das, lade mir das runter, hier gib mir einen Euro. Und dann habe ich das und wenn es mir nicht gefällt, dann schmeiße ich es wieder weg. Und es ist auch anstandslos wieder weg. Super, ich meine, das will man haben. Keine Installations-Arbe.
Da habe ich hier vor einem Jahr schon mal darüber geredet. Dieser Komfort, dass ich lösche das Programm und alles, was dieses Programm mit sich gebracht hat, mit Präferenz und Pipa Pro, ist dann einfach weg.
Ja, aber auch, dass es keinen Schaden anrichten kann, solange wie man es drauf hat. Das ist eigentlich die Kontrolle, die man über seinen Rechner all die Jahre haben wollte. Und die vielleicht auch Leuten, die da prinzipiell ein bisschen mehr Angst haben, dazu zu einer Bereitschaft führt, mehr Programme zu installieren. Beim iPhone sieht man es ja auch, wie das funktioniert.
Tja, ich bin gespannt. Ich bin gespannt. Wann denkt ihr, kommt Lion raus?
Mit dem neuen MacBook Air.
Ja, aber wann?
Hoffentlich vor meinem Geburtstag. Ich will ein neues MacBook Air. Hallo Apple, ich hab am 29.07.
Du willst dein MacBook Pro verlassen und auf ein Air gehen?
Auf jeden Fall.
Klein oder groß?
Groß. Ich will da schon richtig drauf coden und so.
Ich will Air coden.
Naja, ich mach das nicht so als kleinen...
Ich bin auch super gespannt. Ich bin immer noch voll happy mit diesem Elva. Einfach so.
Elf Zoll meinte?
Macht mich echt froh, das Teil. Ich hab auch keinerlei Complaint. Ich hab noch nicht mal die hintergrundbeleuchtete Tastatur vermisst, fällt mir gerade auf.
Ich hab die immer aus.
Ja, die habt ihr auch fast nie an. Aber manche brauchen das schon, aber ist schon eher selten. Aber ist schon ein nettes Gimmick.
Ich hab die schon sehr oft an.
Also ich würde das begrüßen, wenn sie einen Weg finden, das wieder einzuführen. Das fände ich schon okay. Sieht einfach scheiße cool aus. Und wenn du mal so im Halbdunkeln arbeitest, dann... also ich bin jetzt auch nicht so mega tastensicher, dass ich jetzt sagen könnte, ich treffe auch im Dunkeln immer noch den richtigen Delete-Key.
Also ich hab das bei der... Du hattest ja vorher auch dieses Nicht-Uni-Body mit Hintergrundbeleuchtung. Die fand ich immer total doof. Die hatte ich auch nie an, aber die hier bei der...
Ja, die sind jetzt heller. Die alten, die waren nicht so Leistungsstark, die sind jetzt so ein bisschen fetter hier.
Ja, waren die Tasten auch noch silbern und dann hast du so dieses weiß, was dann silbern durchgeläuchtet hat, hat man es teilweise schlechter gesehen.
Genau, genau.
Und das ist bei der Tastatur nicht mehr der Fall.
Die funktioniert einfach. Das haben sie echt alles total gefixt.
Und das hätte ich auch gern bei MacBook Air.
Und was hättest du da gerne für Plattenkapazität? Ich frage mich ja, ob sie die Platte größer kriegen, ob sie die reinbauen.
500 wäre schon gut.
Sind die Speicherzellen nicht in der Zwischenzeit wieder kleiner geworden?
Preise ist das Problem.
Preise!
Ich kann mir das gar nicht so richtig vorstellen.
Wir sollten ja dieses SSD-Video auch einmal verlinken.
Das, was ich dir gestern gezeigt hab.
Das ist einfach, wenn ihr das noch nicht gesehen habt, dann hält einer einen Vortrag, warum man ein SSD haben will. Das ist einfach cool. Für alle Leute, die noch kein SSD haben, die sollen sich das einmal angucken. Das ist schon deswegen cool, weil der cool ist. Da bringt es einfach cool rüber. Danach fühlt man sich wie ein Loser, wenn man keinen SSD hat. Oder?
Das ist Flash, ja. Das geht nicht mehr.
Das hat jemand per Twitter geschickt, dass die bei Blackberry, wie heißt das, Playbook, die englische Werbung dafür, die haben unseren Flash-Sound hinten drinnen, um für Flash zu werben.
Also, was heißt unseren Flash-Sound?
Damals, als ich mit Freddie rumsaugte und sagte, hey, mach mal dieses Flash so. Genau das. Jetzt suche ich noch mal raus, wer das war.
Ich hab mir schon wieder alles hier irgendwie verbastelt. Das ist wirklich unfassbar.
Eines schönen Tages mach ich dir auch nochmal ein paar tolle Samples.
Ich brauch mehr Zeit hier. Ich muss mich einfach mal eine Woche in mein Studio einschließen.
Pack das mal in die Show-Notes.
Mach ich.
Arthur ist dabei. Ich hätte gern, ich hätte gern, ich hätte gern irgendwas, dass sie sich irgendwas einfallen lassen und was ich nicht gedacht hab, was ich total toll finde. Aber nicht so richtig so ein Kaufreibs-Attack.
Ist das schon wieder neu? Ist das nicht erst gerade neu?
Ja, Ende des, Mitte der...
Also die richtige Küche ist so krass. Also alles andere als Lion und R gleichzeitig würde mich jetzt überraschen.
Das ist auch gar nicht mehr neu. Das ist schon, wie alt ist das jetzt schon?
Über ein halbes Jahr, oder?
Das war noch vor Weihnachten, oder?
Kannst fragen, fragen.
Das hat wahrscheinlich gar keine USB-Ports mehr, sondern nur noch Bluetooth.
Ne, nur noch einen Thunderbolt-Anschluss.
Oder so, ja.
Es muss einfach Thunderbolt haben.
Du hast noch nicht ein Thunderbolt-Gerät angeschlossen, in deinem Leben wahrscheinlich, und willst Thunderbolt.
Na, wie soll ich ein Thunderbolt-Gerät anschließen, wenn ich kein Thunderbolt habe? Siehste?
Ja, aber es gibt ja auch kaum Geräte.
Hier, Tilman Baumann hat das.
Das ist Henne-Ei-Problem, und ich bin bereit, als Henne einzuspringen.
Ja, das Ding ist halt irgendwie, habe ich ja heute gelesen, dass die Lizenzgebühren für Airplay und Thunderbolt so premium sind, dass viele Billighersteller sozusagen auch gar nicht Bock haben, das zu implementieren, das ist so wieder diese Firewire-Krankheit.
Ich werde jetzt noch gleich dieses kleine Programm, mit dem man mal eben die Macintosh-Daten von allen Modellen...
Wie herzhaft und schmackhaft und lecker.
Wer den nicht kennt, MacTracker müssen wir auf jeden Fall auch nochmal hier.
Hab ich ja auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt.
Hat doch alle Star-Sounds drin, ne? Wobei das waren ja mittlerweile nicht mehr so viele.
Viele neue Versionen.
Wieso ist das nicht aktuell, dieses Programm?
immer neues Gerät. Der Download ist auch leider langsam. Ich hatte ja schon immer gehofft, dass sie eine Web-Version davon machen. Aber... Ja, aber die muss man ja auch updaten im Zweifel.
Aber das gibt es ja nicht schnell.
Es gibt auch eine Web-Version, die gab es schon immer. Was ich immer wieder empfehlen kann, die ich auch schon mal empfohlen habe, ist everymac.com. Das ist eigentlich meine Nummer 1 Ressource für Fragen zu Details von Apple-Hardware. Da steht eigentlich alles drin. Einschließlich solcher hilfreicher Informationen wie alter Computer, wo Apple meinte, es passt nur so viel RAM rein und was wirklich reinpasst und so. Also das ist immer wieder cool. Insbesondere, was ich sehr geil finde, habe ich auch schon mal erwähnt, aber ich erwähne es einfach nochmal, bei everymac.com/uluniversal, wie haben sie das genannt?
Ultimate Mac Lookup.
Da kannst du dann einfach die letzten drei oder vier Stellen deiner Seriennummer eingeben und dann sagt der dir halt, was das für ein Gerät ist. Das ist sehr praktisch, wenn du so auf Ebay und so weiter, wenn die nicht in der Lage sind zu kommunizieren, um welches Gerät es sich wirklich handelt, dann fragst du einfach nach den letzten Stellen der Seriennummer und gibst sie dann halt ein und dann kriegst du da einfach eine klare Antwort, was dieses Gerät wirklich ist.
Nur die letzten Stellen, nicht die ersten Stellen?
Letzten.
Krass, Mac Trecker gibt es hier gratis ja im Mac App Store, das heißt die Updates, sie kommen dann von Akamai. Yeah, das ist auch so ein schönes Feature eigentlich dann am Mac App Store.
Das stimmt schnell.
Ja, wobei...
Das stimmt.
Ja, doch stimmt, das ist schnell, ja.
Vor allem hast du so eine einzelne Quelle von Updates.
Das klicke ich mir doch gleich mal gratis.
Ja, ich auch, ey.
Ich zuerst, ich zuerst.
Ich hab schon. Jetzt ruft mir der Stream.
Überträgt.
So, jetzt gucken wir noch mal, was die... also Late 2010 war die Ansage eigentlich. Wo ist das R?
Wollen wir haben.
Mach mal hier auf dem, mach mal auf dem Größen-Schirm.
On-Screen.
Wir brauchen noch einen echten Studio Sachsen, finde ich.
Ja. Unsere sächsischen Freunden dreht sich wahrscheinlich auch jedes Mal am Magen um, wenn wir irgendwie in diesen Tonfall gehen. Weil wir das überhaupt nicht drauf haben.
Es ist kein Affront. Ich komme aus dem Osten immerhin.
Oktober 2010. Das ist ja gefühlt schon zehn Jahre her.
Krass, ist das alt.
Und damit traust du dich ja noch in die Sendung, oder was?
Ich hab das auch erst 2011 gekauft, muss ich sagen.
Also 256 MB ist ja, Gigabyte ist natürlich ein Muss, finde ich.
Also das wär halt schön. Also wenn sie es schaffen, die große SSD-Kapazität auch in das kleine Teil reinzubauen.
Ach, das kleine, das wollen sie mir wegen komplett sein lassen. Ich will ein 13 Zoll mit 500 irgendwas.
Und nochmal das Doppelte an RAM. Doppelt RAM, doppelt SSD und Doppelprozessor.
Genau, 8 GB RAM und...
Und mehr System-Bass.
Wie viel RAM hat das jetzt, das Kleine?
Doppelt, doppelt, doppelt.
Das gibt's in den F2, beziehungsweise in 4, wenn du es in 4 kaufst.
Ja, 8 will man.
Aber ich kann nicht behaupten, irgendwelche Einschränkungen zu haben.
Also es ist mehr außer Plattenplatz halt, ne? Also 128 fände ich schon für einen Everyday-Computer knapp, weil ich hab jetzt hier mit meiner 250er, ich hab nicht mal all meine Musik so, die ich sonst auf dem anderen drauf hatte drauf und ist schon über die Hälfte voll und hab schon mich nur ein bisschen zurückgehalten, nicht alle meine Projekte darauf kopiert, die ich sonst so dabei hab. Also wie viel freien Platz hast du noch auf deiner?
Da ist aber wirklich gar nichts drauf, oder?
Na, ich hab so einen Core von 20 GB Arbeitsdateien, die ich so brauche, ungefähr. Plus halt Scratch Space für Full & Bar und Recordings und so weiter.
Also wenn es dann so weit ist mit den SSDs, dass man dann drüber wieder nicht mehr nachdenken muss.
Gut, hier sind ja auch die ganzen alten, super alten Teile drin, ey.
Mach mal wieder die Themenliste.
So, wir können uns über iOS unterhalten. Falls es da überhaupt was zu erzählen gibt, da gibt es dann wieder diese Gerüchteküche und Interpretation von Strings.
Genau.
Ja, String lesen, das ist auch, aber Stringsatz lesen, oder?
Was hast du denn im Stringsatz gelesen?
Nee, der Pelis-Satz eigentlich.
Ich hab... Puffy, Puffy-Satz.
Ich hab darüber gelesen, dass... Ich mein, es wird ja irgendwann mal Zeit, dass die wirklich mal langsam mit einem eigenen Kartenmaterial ankommen und nicht hiermit das alles über Google machen lassen. Weil das ist ja... Nee, das ist nicht The Evil Empire.
Das ist ja...
Wir kriegen ja immer noch nur die Pixel-Karten für iOS. Wir haben ja nicht diese... Die ganzen Google-Geräte, die Android, die haben ja die geilen Vektorkartenmaterial, wo du so stufenlos rein, uns rauszoomen kannst. Das kriegt ja unser eins. Wir kriegen das ja ja nicht.
iOS 5 hat genau keine Ankündigung im Bereich Maps gehabt, oder? Nichts.
Also es ist wohl so, man kann jetzt mehrere Routen anzeigen, also dass wir sagen, welche von den drei Routen das sein werden.
Aber wir kennen doch schon Leute, die iOS 5 haben, oder nicht?
Ja.
Und wie sieht das Mapszeugster aus?
Exakt so wie auf iOS 4, außer dass man mehrere Routen auswählen kann, also vielleicht Detailunterschiede. Viel nimmt sich das alles nicht. Aber da ist irgendjemand aufgefallen, dass sie in ihrem Kartenmaterial, in ihren Copyright-Notizen ein paar mehr Firmen erwähnen. Und zwar habe ich jetzt mal hier eine schöne Liste. Unter anderem, ich glaube, da war von TomTom die Rede. Was war da noch? So, Map Data Processing Companies wie PlaySpace und Poli 9, was auch immer die machen, die reichern wohl noch irgendwie so ein paar Daten an.
PlaySpace ist die, die sie gekauft haben.
Ach, haben sie gekauft?
War das nicht die?
Ich glaube, PlaySpace hat Apple gekauft.
Und ja, vielleicht kommt ja doch irgendwann noch mal neues Kartenmaterial rein in die neue Maps-Applikation. Und so ein bisschen müssen sie sich ja auch überlegen, was doch dieses iPhone 5 bringen wird an neuen Features. Und ich glaube, es wird nicht nur eine neue Kamera und ein bisschen schnellerer Prozessor sein.
Wollen wir wieder Kaffeesatz lesen? Das machen wir lieber kurz vorher irgendwie im August.
Ach, du weißt schon, wann es kommt?
Im September, oder?
Weihnachten. Oktober, Ende Oktober, muss das, damit es zu Weihnachten richtig losrockt.
Da hat jemand mal ausgerechnet, dass es das nicht mehr reicht, um das noch vernünftig groß rauszupuschen.
Hat einer mal ausgerechnet?
Hat mal jemand ausgerechnet.
So ein Analyst wahrscheinlich.
Pavel ist doch sonst immer wohl. Ich hab da mal ausgerechnet den Weltkohleverbrauch.
Ich glaube, das war der Gruber.
Der Gruber John.
Wenn alle ihren Teekocher nicht mehr benutzen.
Das Ding kommt im September.
Hat gesagt, dass Oktober zu spät ist. Und der Gruber John, der hat recht.
Naja, oft nicht immer. Was ist denn eigentlich mit deiner Zwitscher-Kategorie? Hat dir mal wieder jemand was gezwitschert?
Genau, wo ist denn deine Quelle?
Dein Vögelchen. Nicht das, das andere.
Wie viele Vögelchen gibt es denn jetzt schon?
Ja, da sieht es gerade nicht so gut aus mehr mit dem Vögelchen.
Hast du zu viel erzählt?
Nee, das Vögelchen bewegt sich gerade weg aus dem interessanten Bereich, leider. Wie es aussieht.
Ist jetzt zu einem anderen Meisterwirt geflogen oder was? Nein.
Du hast den Käfig gewechselt.
Ich kann da nicht so viel zu sagen, aber...
Dann erzähle ich jetzt noch einmal so ein paar iOS-Programme, die man vielleicht empfehlen kann. Ich habe hier, toll jetzt funktioniert es prompt nicht, mir ein neues Kalenderprogramm runtergeladen und so ist das jetzt fett beworben worden. Das ist leider alles andere als perfekt, aber schon mal gar nicht schlecht. Agenda heißt das, das ist so ein Kalenderprogramm. Weil...
Was mit dem normalen Kalender arbeitet, sozusagen eine Alternative zu dem normalen Kalendertool.
Das machen sie mittlerweile fast alle, glaube ich. Das gehört sich auch so.
Was ist an dem toll? Kann es irgendwie Wochen anzeigen?
Es hat eine Jahresansicht. Man kann so mit dem Finger hin und her swipen. Es hat eine Monatsansicht. Und es hat so eine durchscrollende Tagesansicht. Wie viele Tage sieht man? Auf 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Wechselnde. Je nachdem, wie viele Termine man an einem Tag hat. Also so 5 sieht man maximal. Wenn man mehr Termine hat, sieht man ein bisschen weniger. Und man scrollt einfach so durch. Und es ist ganz hübsch gelöst. Macht Spaß. Was ich ein ganz nettes Detail finde, ist das einzige Kalenderprogramm, was ich kenne, was auch auf dem Springboard den aktuellen Tag anzeigt. Und zwar haben sie es über so eine Notification oben gelöst. Also sozusagen wie andere Programme.
Weil du halt noch diese Anzahl an Notifications offen hast oder wie und du kannst ja einfach nicht wegmachen.
Nee, das ist einfach, er zeigt einfach, anhand dieser Notifications zeigt er einem an, dass er, also heute ist der 28.
In dem 28 Notifications anzeigt.
Nee, nicht 28 Notifications, sondern indem sie da einfach die 28 draufhängen auf den Counter.
Ja, aber dann muss der auch 28 Notifications haben.
Nö, das kannst du ja beliebig, du kannst ja Notifications machen, die nur da angezeigt werden, ohne eine echte Notification zu erzeugen. Also man selbst kriegt da überhaupt nichts von mit. Ich finde es eine ganz hübsche Lösung. Es gibt auch so ein Wetterdienstprogramm, was das auch macht. Die schicken einem dann per Push immer die aktuelle Temperatur zu, wo man gerade ist, indem sie da in die Notification-Bar rein schreiben, wie viel Grad Celsius gerade sind. Funktioniert natürlich nicht bei Minusgraden, aber... Bei Tagen funktioniert es ganz gut. Also ich finde es schade, dass man auch mit iOS 5 nicht diese Kalenderansicht mal aktualisieren kann, dass das Icon sich selber updaten kann. Aber ja, das ist die zweitbeste Lösung, die es sozusagen gibt.
Ja, hier ist doch so ein kleines Batch irgendwie mit einer Zahl drin, oder auch von mir aus mit Minus. Das ist doch eine super Lösung. Ja, dass es Minus nicht geht, schon klar, aber es könnte Apple ja mal sehen, alles klar. ich bin Ist das nicht eine coole Sache für Apps, dass sie noch so eine Zahl anzeigen oder irgendwas halt?
Besonders weil natürlich Apples eigene Apps wieder mal mehr können. Zum Beispiel, wenn du eine SMS nicht verschickt kriegst, dann zeigt dir das SMS-Programm so ein kleines Ausrufezeichen da dran an. Kann wieder niemand außer Apple.
Es gibt ja noch ein anderes Agenda, das ist auch so ein ganz ähnliches, icon-halblos ein rot.
Es gibt ganz schön viele Piggyback-Applikationen, ne? Also so die, da kommt halt irgendeine coole App raus, sowas wie Reader oder so oder Alfred, hier dieser Application-Lounge, wenn du dann im Mac Store oder im iOS Store suchst, dann gibt es irgendwie dann in den Suchergebnissen so Programme, die irgendwie ähnliche Logo-Elemente haben und auch ähnliche Namen oder ähnliche Claims, aber irgendwie dann doch totaler Schrott sind.
Hast du hier einen, wie ist dein Kalender, also wie ist dein systemweites Kalender-Setting? Du bist schon auf europäisch.
Ich bin schon auf europäisch, ja wieso?
Das ist ja amerikanische Software.
Hier fängt die Woche wieder mit dem Sonntag an.
Ach so, da war ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht aufgeachtet. Ich hab ja...
Das ist immer das erste, worauf ich gucke.
Ich gucke einfach nur...
Gibt es eine Kalenderwoche überhaupt? Gibt es auch nicht? Du zeigst halt keine Kalenderwoche an.
Wir hören jetzt den Live-Kalendertest von Tim.
Naja, ich meine, so ganz... Unerheblich ist das ja wohl nicht, oder?
Kalenderwoche brauch ich immer.
Wenn Tim das immer braucht, dann...
Immer und nie sind verbotene Worte. Vom Sohn zuvielten bis Sohn zuvielten.
Kann ich gut mitleben.
Also wir sollten... Genau, wir bennen jetzt ab heute immer und nie aus den Wortschatz für diesen Podcast.
Kalenderwoche ist eine echt tolle Erfindung. Von Europa oder Deutschland.
Das ist okay. Da war jetzt wieder immer noch nie drin.
Aber hat denn der eine Wochenansicht? Nee, hat er gar nicht. Er hat nur Tagesansicht und die Liste oder was?
Tagesansicht, Liste, Monat. Aber man kann halt so durchscrollen. Das ist so ein endloser Kalender, ne?
The Queen ist nicht endlos.
Ich kann nur bis zum 28. Juni scrollen und dann will er nicht mehr weiter.
Mann, geh nach rechts.
Ist auch der 28.
Und jetzt runter scrollen. Nein, andere Richtung.
Was?
Mann, nicht in den Termin, mit rechts, links gehst du in die Details rein.
Ach so.
Und mit hoch, runter.
Okay, das ist aber im View nicht zu unterscheiden.
Das können jetzt die Hörer auch gar nicht sehen.
Doch, doch, das ist total leicht unterscheidbar. Geh mal eins weiter nach links.
Das ist sozusagen die Null-Uhr-Grenze und der 31.
ist jetzt in diese Linie rein.
Null-Uhr-Grenze nennt man auch Tageswechsel?
Also...
Ich mag das. Tim mags nicht.
Tim sagt Tonne.
Nee, aber ich finde...
Ich finde, das geht hier mit dem Scrolls ganz einfach. Das Scrollt noch mal.
Max, ehrlich, ein Kalenderprogramm hat als allererster, bevor die irgendeinen Bit auf ihrem Bildschirm malen, hat es sich einfach, die Kalendereinstellung des Betriebssystems zu ziehen und zu respektieren. Und da steht drin...
Nokia.
Wo man ist... Ich halt's maul jetzt.
Also ich finde, hier steht oben der aktuelle Tag und da drunter stehen dann mehr Tage und das finde ich super, mehr brauch ich nicht.
Oh, unser Stream ist abgerissen.
Kaum lege ich den Hall auf die Stimme.
Tja. Da hoffen wir mal, dass mein Recording richtig funktioniert, wa? Nee, der Stream ist abgerissen. Weil ich verwende ja, habe ich das letzte Mal schon gesagt... Nee, ich glaube, das war jetzt noch nicht verwendet. Ich verwende nicht mehr Nicecast dieses Mal, sondern ich verwende Ladiocast. Und Ladiocast hat gerade was ganz Furchtbares getan. Es hat nämlich einen Fehler gehalten. Ihr habt, wo auch immer der Herr kam, beim Streamen, und zeigt dann so ein beklopptes Dialogfenster, dass da ein Fehler war. Anstatt diesen fucking Stream sofort wieder herzustellen und nichts zu verlieren, muss man dann Return drücken. Hüpft auch nicht im Doc. Das wird ja schon wieder zu Punktabzug. Was soll denn das? Kannst du nicht einfach irgendwo hinschreiben, dass ein Fehler war? Und jetzt geht es wieder los. Die Software kostet nichts. Leute, bitte macht eure Software nicht kostenlos. Verdient was dran.
Und macht es ordentlich.
Macht es ordentlich. Hört auf eure Kunden.
Hört auf Timme vor allem.
Wissen die das du, sind das Deutsche oder sind das Internationale?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Japaner. Das macht die Sachen natürlich etwas knifflig.
Die haben gerade eh ganz andere Probleme.
Software aus Japan kann man jetzt nicht mehr benutzen. Die wird nicht mehr aktualisiert.
Na doch, vom Ostteil der Insel schon, aber...
Und die strahlt.
Deine Homepage ist auch nicht zu erreichen.
Deine?
Deine, die in deinem Programm verbaut boxtritt.
Mach mal... Ja, die steht halt irgendwo in Japan.
Da werde ich japanisch.
So, was soll ich jetzt mal machen?
Themenliste zum Beispiel.
Gut, Themenliste.
Du hast da irgendwie Monstersoup reingeschrieben.
Ja, ich weiß nicht warum. Ich habe das neulich mal installiert und es hat Zeit geraubt.
Aber du hast letztens voll getwittert, hier so irgendwie Bäume und Pflanzen erkennen und hattest da mehrere Kandidaten gepostet. Ich war eigentlich total interessiert daran, was denn jetzt so der Gewinner war, weil du ja auch einen sehr hohen Anspruch, also die Messlatte gleich hochgelegt hast, mit irgendwie, einer hat dir was empfohlen. Ja, da ist doch hier XY-Strauch nicht drin.
Ich wollte halt genau einen bestimmten Strauch bestimmen. Das war für mich in dem Moment der Benchmark. Und es hat keine abgeschafft. Keine?
Haben die denn überhaupt irgendwas geschafft?
Na ja, die haben halt irgendwelche diffusen, also die allermeisten Programme mit Baumbestimmungen, die waren alle furchtbar designt. Viele stürzten ab. Viele haben halt dann nur Nordamerika drin und so. Grundsätzlich kann man so die unterscheiden, die versuchen das mit Kamerabilderkennung zu machen. Und dann gibt es so die, die so versuchen, das über Bestimmungen zu machen. Und es war so ein bisschen das Rennen ab gegen Google. Und es war ein bisschen erniedrigend für diese Ups. Weil bei Google musste ich nur eingeben, vier blättrige weiße Blüte returnen. Und dann kamen tonnenweise Bilder mit Sträuchern, wo man sofort wusste, das ist es. Und diese Ups, die haben sich da einen abgebrochen mit ist das Blatt gezickt und gezackt und gerundet und gefloppt und volugt es und schnuppelt es und hast es nicht gesehen. Und diese Kamerabilderkennung, legt das Blatt auf ein weißes Papier und fotografiert es und dann irgendwie rechne, rechne, rechne, denk, äh grübel, nie kenn ich nie. Also es war einfach die Experience, war einfach lame. Also ich hab da nichts gefunden. Ich glaub zwei Ups haben es überhaupt nur geschafft, installiert zu bleiben und auch von denen.
Also ich wüsste nie wieder starten.
Ich hatte einfach keinerlei Erfolg in irgendeiner Form. So, das war jetzt auch nicht so ein exotischer Strauch, der hier nur im Botanischen Museum steht oder so. Sondern das wechselt hier so.
Ich hab noch ein kleines Programm, vielleicht kriegst du ja irgendjemand zum Laufen. Bei mir hat es dann nicht geklappt, soll ganz toll sein. Skinscan heißt das, der ein Server ist.
Der am vielsten Programm, was du selber nicht zum Laufen kriegst.
Der ein Server ist die ganze Zeit überlastet. Wir sind gestern irgendwo empfohlen worden. Und zwar ist das Hautkrebsfrühwardung. Man macht ein Foto mit dem iPhone von seinen Leberflecken.
Woher sind das denn ausgebuddelt, ey?
Dann sagt er einem, ob das... Kostet doch nicht was, oder? Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das was kostet. Das sagt einem dann so...
Du bist tot in drei Wochen.
Geh damit mal zum Arzt, oder brauchst du dir keine Sorgen machen?
Du hast noch so und so viele Tage zu leben.
Ich finde das eine schöne Sache. Das beunruhigt doch. Ich war letztens im Grabestore.
Ich meine, mit Leberflecken soll man zum Arzt gehen und durchchecken lassen und so. Dann machen hier viel zu wenig Leute und so. Hautkrebs und alles ganz schlimm und dann ist man tot.
Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott.
Jetzt haben die letzten Wochen auch noch Familie.
Jetzt verlieren wir Hörer.
Ich kann was Schönes erzählen. Ich war beim Grabes und habe mir ein neues Netzteil gekauft. Wir waren aber bei iOS ab.
Kannst du sagen, dass dein Internet hier einfach nicht mehr geht?
Du musst bedienen, man. Du kannst nicht einfach irgendeine Karte drauflegen. Du musst schon bedienen, was da liegt.
Ja, das kann irgendwie sein. Es gibt hier Kommunikationsprobleme. Weiß ich nicht warum.
Das geht nicht.
Der Chat geht auch nicht mehr.
Was habt ihr wieder angestellt?
Leuchtet irgendwas?
Also über...
Also stimmt schon. Zwei Minuten lang wurde im Dings nichts mehr gesagt. also hat es eventuell nicht.
Ja, ich kann browsen.
Ja, jetzt geht's grad wieder. Irgendwas hat sich da grade rebooted oder so. Dieses VDS ehrlich gesagt.
Aktuell werden keine Sendungen gestreamt.
Naja, das ist halt auch so, weil da kein Stream hinkommt und dann timet es gleich aus. Das ist so wie Xenim an der Stelle funktioniert.
Aber warum sagt hier mein Irrk nichts mehr?
Netsplit oder wat?
Naja, nee, es war wahrscheinlich schon wirklich gerade mal weg und mein Adium kam auch gerade wieder rein und raus. Das heißt, mein Irrk muss ich auch kurz...
Ja, hier wird gerade auch, glaub ich...
Man kann ja nicht so reload sagen, dann muss man mal warten, bis er austimet, das ist natürlich ein bisschen blöd. Lass uns einfach weiterquatschen, weil in der Sendung spät, das ist ja total super.
Bei Linkinus, diesem Irrk-Line, den man hier so benutzt, da kann man auch so Disconnect und Reconnect einfach klicken.
Ja, vielleicht...
Also ich hab übrigens meinen Langzeit-Test von Alfred auch fortgezogen und bin damit jetzt vollständig glücklich. Na, hier so Loungebar-Ersatz. Loungebar für Armen. Alfred App. Mit dem Powerpack allerdings. Weil ich das Multiple Clipboard haben wollte und es gab nur ein Powerpack. Alfred ist ansonsten kostenlos. Ja, ich hab glaube ich sonst echt hier... Hab ich keine Apps installiert in der Zeit? Gibt's doch gar nicht.
Ja, ich hätte noch einen kleinen Tipp zum Zeitverlieren. Falls ihr also ein bisschen Produktivität weghauen wollt. Monstersoup auf iOS.
Ich hab schon geladen, aber noch nicht probiert.
Für zum Superklicken?
Nö, das ist mal wieder so ein Programm, was diese ganze Touch-Geschichte irgendwie ganz interessant löst. Das sind so kleine Monsterströme, so von unten nach oben. Und wenn sie oben an der Wand aufschlagen, werden sie irgendwie zu Eis. Und irgendwann ist dann ein ganzer Bildschirm voll mit Eis und alles vorbei. Und du musst halt die Viecher vorher zerplatzen lassen, indem du eh so mit Touch gleiche miteinander verbindest. Und dann ploppen die irgendwie so weg. Und umso mehr du auf einmal machst, umso mehr Punkte und Features gibts. Das ist ein Game. Ja genau, es wird immer schneller. Es ist halt so ein Zeitvernichter. Aber es ist ein schönes Teil, mal wieder so eins, was so auf Touch ist. Also so ein Spiel, was so auf Touch ist. Ich mag immer diese Spiele nicht, die so irgendwelche so hinten Joysticks haben und so.
Aber da gibt es jetzt von ThinkGeek, diese Arcade-Box, die haben wir jetzt wirklich gebaut.
Auf wo man...
Diese iCade heißt die.
Wo man ein iPad reintut.
Genau und du dann so richtig Joysticks, Dattel-Buttons und so hast hier iCade, klick mal, also die gibt es jetzt bei ThinkGeek. Zum Bestellen kostet irgendwie 100 Dollar. Aber sieht echt, also ich... Was, wie hast du das geschrieben? Ja, genau.
iCade, iPad-iCade. Ah, das ist ja putzig.
Das ist schon richtig, also als Gadget-Geschenk hätte ich das irgendwie schon gerne auf dem Regal.
Und was soll dann da mitlaufen? Also was machen diese Buttons?
Also wie kommt das da rein? Na, es ist halt mit Dock-Connector, ne?
Ja, und welche Programme unterstützen das?
Na, ich habe so doch so ein paar, die da offensichtlich dabei sind. Luna, Lander, Battlezone.
Was heißt dabei? Die sind bestimmt nicht dabei, sondern die kommen aus dem App-Store.
Nee, die sind halt im App-Store dieses entsprechende Programm dazu runter.
Achso, die Atari-Teile funktionieren und die unterstützen das auch, ja?
Scheinbar.
Das ist natürlich fully compatible with... Das ist natürlich, das ist natürlich echt geil.
Vor allen Dingen, sie haben auch einen Münzeinwurf-Schlitz dran. Obwohl der jetzt nur gefaked ist, aber rechts unten gibt's dann halt irgendwie Münzeinwurf-Schlitz auch noch.
Das ist aber auch wirklich mal richtig geil.
Aber bei Centipede hast du immer nur gleich den Knopf zerspürt.
Ja, und Asteroid. Also Asteroid mit... Ich hab das mal mit Touch das Ding auch gekauft, dieses Atari-Dings, und dann so mit Touch, das ist es irgendwie nicht.
Nee, das war lame.
Ein Freund von mir hat sich jetzt dieses, von MB oder was, oder Mattel, war das so ein Vector, wie hieß das? Vector-Grafik-Spiel-Konsole, da war Asteroids so original dabei ist.
Wollen wir mal diesen Ton hier irgendwie einspielen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Aber ohne Bild ist das wahrscheinlich doof.
Nein, aber so...
Na ja, das sieht irgendwie so lustig aus. Warte mal, ich... Ich kann nicht ahnen, dass es so laut ist.
Ja, man hört Spielemusik und...
Und die Musik ist auf jeden Fall ganz schön, ja?
Könnte auch nicht dudeln, ne?
Also ist jetzt Werbung für das iPad Arcade Kabinett.
Ja, was ich so geil daran finde, ist, dass so... Also erstens kannst du das iPad jederzeit auch wieder rausholen, also musst du das nicht dediziert da jetzt nur dafür kaufen und dann ist es da eigentlich fest eingebaut.
Krass.
Das finde ich auch sehr schön, einfach nur so Musik und nichts anderes. It touches my heart. Ja und vor allem ist es so schön klein, es nimmt nicht so viel Platz weg, wie so ein fester Dada Lomata, wie im Club irgendwie. Ich meine, gut, da ist der Platz da, aber das baut man sich natürlich nicht so mal so eben rein.
Und laufen tut es auch gerade nicht.
Da kann man die Kinder auch an die ursprüngliche Kultur der Arcade-Automaten.
Ich will ja meinen, also was Max ja auch schon mal meinte, ein Mac Plus, ein iPad einbauen, das wäre auch geil. Also einen alten Mac, aber andere Baustelle.
Stimmt, ich hab ja noch den Mac Plus.
Aber jetzt sind wir bei Hardware.
Arcade.
Ich bin ja...
Ne, ne, ne, stopp, stopp, stopp. Lass uns doch kurz bei den Hubs bleiben, ja?
Oh Gott, wir haben ja das eigentliche Thema noch gar nicht.
Der Kracher kommt noch, haltet euch fest.
Bleibt im Sattel.
Ich wollte nochmal kurz diesen Bereich Banking aufschlagen, weil wir da ja neulich schon mal drüber gesprochen hatten. Dann hab ich auch mich auch ein bisschen begradigt worden von ein paar Leuten, dass ich was vergessen hatte unter iOS.
Dieses iControl?
iControl, was ich nämlich zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon mal benutzt hatte, wo mir aber gar nicht klar war, dass das eigentlich für meine Kontolage etwas am besten funktioniert. Zum Beispiel, ich hab so ein Sparkassenkonto und über diesen Kontozugang kann ich halt nicht nur mein Girokonto und Sparbücher und so ein Kram sehen, sondern eben auch die Kreditkarten, die damit verbunden sind. Plus diese anderen Programme sind nicht in der Lage, diese Kreditkartenkonten auch auf den Screen zu bringen. Was natürlich bekloppt ist, weil du willst natürlich auch deine Kreditkartenbuchung sofort sehen und nicht immer nur mit der Monatsabrechnung. Du willst ja möglichst sofort sehen, dass da irgendwas abgebucht wurde. Insbesondere sollte es mal etwas sein, was du nie so autorisiert hast.
Richtig. Na ja.
Kann man die dann schon vorher irgendwie einsehen? Ich dachte, die kommen auch immer erst nach einem Monat.
Nö, das hängt von deiner Bank ab. Früher war das mal nicht so, aber irgendwann kam das mal dazu.
Das kommt doch darauf an, wenn du bei der Postbank bist oder irgendeiner anderen und du hast halt eine Visa-Karte, dann kriegen die auch bei der Postbank wahrscheinlich die Daten von Visa auch erst dementsprechend später.
Nee, die kriegen die quasi in Echtzeit rein.
Das geht schon.
Ich bin bei der DKB, da geht das ziemlich flott da.
Bei der Volksbank bei der Berliner auch.
Ja, also die Zeiten sind vorbei, dass du da wirklich nur einmal im Monat einen Zettel siehst. Also du hast schon die Möglichkeit. Nur die Software muss das auch können und die muss dann eben auch über HBCI das können. Und iControl konnte das. Dann ist wieder etwas Zeit vergangen und auch auf Mac hat sich jetzt was Neues getan. Also als wir letztes Mal drüber gesprochen haben, hatte ich dieses Money-Money vorgestellt, was irgendwie ganz slick rüber kam, aber noch nicht so sehr viel mehr macht eigentlich als Kontoanzeige und kam auch wieder mit allen Konten. Also das habe ich auch keine Kreditkarten gesehen und ich konnte auch zu bestimmten Banken das nicht machen, was Outbank zum Beispiel konnte. Und jetzt ist eine Beta rausgekommen von diesem Outbank für den Mac. Und das habe ich jetzt getestet und obwohl das irgendwie echt Early Beta ist, sieht das schon mal sehr gut aus. Also sieht schick aus, hat auch so einen iOS-Touch irgendwie und vor allem kommt es irgendwie an viel ran, unter anderem auch PayPal. Also du hast auch zu PayPal damit ein Interface. Aber ich glaube, last time I checked, konnten sie auch, warte mal, ich muss da nochmal schauen, habe ich da die Kreditkartenkonten eigentlich dabei? Die releaseen auch gerade, also wenn man diese Beta liest, jedes Mal wenn du startest, hast du eine neue Version. Das ist echt krass. Oh, da hat sich ja richtig viel getan, schon wieder sein letztes Mal.
Krass, ich hab's vorhin, zum Anfang der Sendung installiert und jetzt gibt's eine neue Version. Und das war jetzt nicht übertrieben, sondern exakt so.
Ja, die sind da ganz fleißig am Arbeiten und machen irgendwie Release-Often.
Wobei so richtig weit ist die auch noch nicht. Also es macht schon alles noch einen sehr ähm...
was?
einen alpharigen Eindruck.
Ich find das macht einen betarigen Eindruck.
Also bei mir ist es jetzt so, dass ich die Kontodaten importiert habe von der iOS-Version.
Ah, jetzt haben sie auch die Titel.
Und jetzt hat er nämlich hier Postbank Nürnberg und DKB vertauscht. Und zwar ist die schein die Visa-Karte unter Postbank und umgekehrt.
Es ist nicht fertig, aber ich finde, das sieht schon mal ganz okay aus. Das wird mal gut. Das könnte ganz spannend werden. Kann auch noch nicht überweisen und so weiter. Aber immerhin macht auch eben PayPal, macht aber auch nicht die Kreditkarten. Also nur dieses iControl war bisher in der Lage, auch diese Kreditkartenkonten bei der Sparkasse zu machen. Keine Ahnung.
Was war das jetzt gerade?
Das war jetzt so ein Update, dass er jetzt aktuell...
Kann er auch Bitcoin-Konten?
Tja, soweit sind wir glaube ich noch nicht.
Ja, aber wer da auf der Suche ist, ich bin jetzt auch kurz vor der Sendung auf noch eine neue App hingewiesen worden, die gerade irgendwie in Entwicklung ist, aber die gibt es noch nicht, auf dem iPad, da ist gerade echt was in Bewegung.
Auf dem iPad?
Da generell, also auch auf dem Mac.
Gibt es jetzt nur Objective-C, HBCI-Library, das alle plötzlich loslegen, oder?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Für dieses ganze Visa Zeug, da müssen sie ja auch immer noch irgendwelche Scraper schreiben.
Ich habe aber das Gefühl, wenn sowas auf einmal im Markt ist, dann ist das einfach eine gute Nachricht für die ganze Plattform.
Wenn für sowas ein Markt ist? Wer vernimmt hier das Online-Banking?
Also überhaupt Finanzbuchhaltung, dieser ganze Büro-Schlips-Kram, FIBA 2009, wahrscheinlich eher FIBA 1986.
Wie hieß das nicht? FIBA Finanzbuchhaltung?
Ich habe heute so eine Software gesehen, mit der Handwerker ihre Abrechnung machen und Rechnungen schreiben und sowas. Sind wir noch aus den 80ern, oder?
Mit DOS?
Ja, es sieht so aus, als ob da einfach nur eine hässliche Windows-Shell drüber geklebt worden wäre. Das war wirklich so unerträglich. Ich glaube, das kann mehr, als man mit FileMaker auf die Beine kriegen könnte, aber es wäre unmöglich, mit FileMaker sowas unglaublich hässliches zusammenzubauen. Zum Beispiel bei der Adresseingabe, dass alle Felder über die gesamte Bildschirmbreite gingen. Wenn du das Postleitzahl war, dann waren ungefähr 200 Pixel breit, weil es standardmäßig auf 20% von der Gesamtbreite gesetzt ist. Also wirklich so, wo du denkst, ach nee, und dafür nehmt ihr Geld. Siehst du, das ist auch Sachen, die Geld kosten können scheiße sein, Tim. Es gibt keinen Automatismus, dass die Leute nur Geld für ihre Sachen nehmen müssen, und schon wird es gut.
Nee, ist schon klar.
Sieh es mal so rum.
Ja, aber wenn es kostenlos ist, dann...
Verdienen sie kein Geld dran, schon klar.
Dann kannst du halt nirgendswo drauf treten.
Ja, ich lese gerade beim Gruber Google Swiffy Converts Flash SWF-Files zur HTML5.
Ja, das hab ich auch schon vorhin gelesen. Hast du erst mal einen SWF-File hier, mit dem man das mal ausprobieren könnte? Oh, das war jetzt aber extrem leise.
So, nächstes Thema.
Und das swiffy.googlelabs.com gibt es nicht?
Ja, das wollen wir mal ausprobieren.
Was ist mit swiffy?
Converts, SWF-Contento hat dem 11.5 angeblich...
Original Flash-Animation?
Ein bisschen was irgendwie oder alles und funktioniert und ist fertig.
Ganz schön viel. Na ja, es ist bei Google Labs, also mit anderen Worten, die haben es noch nicht mal als irgendwas ansatzweise Beta bezeichnet. Swiffy currently supports a subset of SWF 8 in ActionScript 2.0. If possible, exporting your Flash-Animation as an SWF 5.5 might give better results.
Ja, und was ist... Aber das ist doch, das ist, ich meine...
Das kann doch gar nicht funktionieren.
Das muss doch einfach nicht sein.
Das ist, glaube ich, nicht das erste Mal, dass so was...
Adobe hat es auch schon probiert.
Adobe hat es auch schon probiert und ist damit gescheitert.
Oh, und Adobe ist begeistert. Pleased to see the Flash-Plattform extend to devices which don't support the Flash-Player. Also sozusagen alle.
Ja, aber warum macht Google das? Ach, Scheiße, das hab ich jetzt vergessen. Es gibt so ein Spiel fürs iPhone, mit dem kann man so das alte Nokia-Snake spielen. Und zwar mit dem simulierten Nokia-Telefon dazu. Das ist sehr lustig. Da hat man so ein Telefon, man kann verschiedene Nokia-Modelle aussuchen.
Darauf haben wir gewartet.
Na ja, bald gibt es nur noch Nokia als Up.
Wenn Denis nicht schon eingepennt wäre, dann...
Nokia als Up.
Ja, Nokia-Telefon als Up.
Genau, Snake 97 heißt das.
Die bauen dann keine Hardware mehr, gibt es nur noch Immolationen.
Das wäre es, damit man T9 irgendwie...
Kostet 80 Cent. Guck, hier kann man verschiedene Handys ausschicken. Das ist so mit Bildschirm am Rand und so.
Gibt es das 6210i?
Wie sieht denn 6210i denn aus?
Das ist das Telefon, Mann!
6310i.
Ja, du einigt euch mal, welches das Telefon ist.
Ist das das hier? Nee. Na dann gibt es das da nicht.
Brauchst es nicht kaufen.
Mac-Software. Nachtrag zu meinem iCal-Rahns letztes Mal. Irgendjemand hat mich darauf hingewiesen, zu Recht, dass habe ja beklagt, dass das da so unflexibel ist mit irgendwie nächsten Tage und so weiter. Was ich eigentlich wollte, ist ja die aktuelle Woche und darunter die nächste Woche. Was ich aber übersehen habe, ist, dass es tatsächlich in den Prefs eine Option gibt, wo du zumindest sagen kannst, dass er den Wochenview, wenn du da weitergehst, Tag für Tag weiter schiebt. Also du kannst da zumindest so tageweise hin und her schieben. Hat wieder andere Probleme, weil du willst, ich will einfach immer wissen, wo eine Woche anfängt und wo sie aufhört. Und da iCare ja noch nicht mal Wochenenden einfärben kann oder irgendwie mir irgendein Visual-Q geben kann. Wo ich mich befinde, ist es einfach wirklich so dämlich, diese Software. Ist das so, naja, okay, verwirrt mich jetzt nur anders. Aber ich bin immer noch vollkommen entsetzt, dass es keine ordentliche Kalender-Software gibt. Aber ich hab ja auch mal beklagt, dass es keine ordentliche HBCI-Software gibt. Das scheint sich ja jetzt zu bessern. Das scheint ja wirklich was zu bringen. Hier Leute, ihr wollt alle irgendwie jetzt auf dem Mac eure erste Geile abschreiben. Ihr wollt mal wirklich überzeugen, schreibt eine ordentliche Kalender-Software.
Es gibt nichts.
Es ist alles Scheiße.
Aber es ist auch das größte, also eins der schwierigsten Felder, wie wir wissen.
Und vor allen Dingen, es geht gegen Tim.
Was ist da so schwierig dran?
Naja, das größte Problem ist, glaube ich, dass die Leute versuchen, eine Kompatibilität zu diesem iCal, zu diesem unsäglichen iCal-Format aufrechtzuerhalten.
Was heißt denn Format? Das ist ein Systemdienst.
Nee, iCal ist ja auch der Name des Formates. Ja, das ist doch super. Doch, das Format ist das Problem.
Nein, das User-Interface ist das Problem.
Ja, auch, aber...
Nein, nur... Nein, nur, der Speicher ist okay. Ich kann alles abbilden, was ich an Terminen habe.
Ja, das schon.
Aber kein Programm ist... Guck mal, es gibt so viele Probleme. Trag mal in iCal einen Termin ein, der, sagen wir mal, um 14 Uhr an einem Tag startet und um 16 Uhr am nächsten Tag endet. Sowas soll es geben, ja? Veranstaltungen und so. Dann taucht der irgendwie in so einem Monats-View nur am Tag, wo er anfängt, auf. Du siehst es einfach nicht.
Ich weiß.
Oder warum kann ich nicht einstellen, wann für mich ein Tag überhaupt anfängt? Ich will nicht einen Termin, der um 1 Uhr eingetragen ist, dass der im nächsten Tag ist. Verstehst du, ich will immer bis 5 Uhr alles irgendwie noch... Der Tag ist für mich, wenn ich aufwache und schlafe gehe.
Zeit ist eine lineare Sache, die geht da so lang. Du willst bestimmte Bereiche darauf angucken, dass es ein Tag ist. Da kannst du so Marker setzen. Aber du willst dir genau aussuchen, was du wie betrachtest. Und Zeit geht hintereinander weg. Da gibt es ja nur mal keine.
Es ist aber auch sehr wichtig, dass du so ein View hast. So ein Kalender-View. Was sehr wichtig ist, du musst immer sofort, wenn du draufschaust, du musst immer sofort wissen, worauf du schaust.
Das ist eine Voraussetzung.
Das kann niemand.
Das ist bei iCal nicht gegeben. Bei iCal startest du. Da muss ich den richtigen Winkel zu meinem Bildschirm haben, damit ich dieses Hellblau-Highlighting überhaupt richtig erkenne, was mir den aktuellen Tag anzeigt. Es gibt bestimmte Winkel, da bin ich nicht in der Lage, dieses Highlighting zu sehen. Also sie sind noch nicht mal in der Lage, mir zu sagen, wann heute ist.
Das Tim nicht mehr richtig sieht, das haben wir schon in den letzten Folgen festgestellt.
Ja, aber ist so. Ich meine, warum ist das nicht einfach rot oder hat ein Rand oder ist irgendwie dunkel oder invers? Das Wochenende ist überhaupt nicht markiert.
Du kannst überhaupt nicht sagen, dass das am Ende der Woche ist.
Warum können bestimmte Tage nicht bestimmte Farben haben? Warum ist nicht ein Montag grün und ein Dienstag ist irgendwie rot nach irgendeiner Palette, die ich mir auswähle? Warum?
Weil manche Leute noch so Kalendereignisse drin haben wollen, die sie auch noch nicht haben wollen.
Das geht alles, Verläufe, irgendwie verschiedene Tinkturen, irgendwas.
Also abgesehen von dieser GUI-Sache, die auf jeden Fall... Es geht mir nicht abgesehen, es geht mir um die GUI-Sache. Ja, pass auf. Aber ich glaube, dass ein großer Teil dieser Kalender-Software auch in der GUI so schlecht ist, weil sich die Leute in diesem iCal-Format festklammern und an den Beschränkungen und diesem bekloppten Format an sich und dann auch gar nicht mehr Bock haben irgendwie noch...
iCal ist für Kalender, was Text-Edit für Word-Processing ist. Ja, es ist the bare minimum.
Und... Und das iCal-Kalender-Format ist, was hier Avi für Video-Format ist.
Na, aber... Warte, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
iCal ist wie DevM unter den Kalender-Formaten.
Das iCalender-Format ist zwar scheiße zu parsen, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man da nicht die eigentlichen Informationen drin abspeichern könnte.
Naja, ich weiß zum Beispiel nicht, ob jetzt mit diesen Reoccurrence... Obwohl, noch mit Reoccurrence-Rules würde es wahrscheinlich hängen.
Ja, das gibt's da alles.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich hab mich damit auch schon mal beschäftigen dürfen. Aber ich würde ja sagen, halt, also, wenn neue Kalender-Software dann am besten auch gleich neues Format und neue Syncing-Infrastruktur, weil auch diese ganze Syncing-Infrastruktur mit diesem iCal-Format und diesen unterschiedlichen Interpretationen dieses Formats und den Feldern da drin...
Siehst du das als Problem, dass die Programme das unterschiedlich interpretieren?
Es gibt da... Also es ist halt... Das ist in einer Spekt oder gleich neben der Spekt von Vcard und vielleicht hast du dir schon mal die Vcard-Spekt angeguckt. Ja, das ist halt... Also da ist halt viel Raum für Interpretationen und deswegen ist das halt auch so, dass der eine das so reinschreibt und der andere so und irgendwie...
Ja, aber das ist in meiner täglichen Arbeit mit Kalendern kein Problem.
Ich weiß. Ich sage...
Das ist ein Problem, wenn du ein iCalParser schreibst, dann ist das ein Problem. Aber das Hauptproblem ist, dass einfach noch niemand ein wirklich erschlagenes Konzept gefunden hat, wie man Kalender richtig visualisiert. Und auch Apple finde ich... Ich meine, auf dem iPhone, du kannst ja da noch nicht mal durchswipeen. Ich meine, du kannst ja nicht scrollen, du kannst ja gar nichts machen. Bei so was wie Denis richtig sagt, Zeit ist eigentlich fluid. Das ist eine sehr flüssige Geschichte. Ich will da auch pinchen können. Wenn ich da mehr sehen will, dann pinche ich das zusammen, wie ich das in so einer Karte mache. Dass ich einfach Level of Detail habe, dass ich da doppelt tappe und dann fokussiert das auf den Tag und dann mach ich noch mal doppelt tappe und dann geht's...
Alle wollen Sünden mit ihren Kalendern. Das ist halt, ich weiß nicht wieso. Ja, also wie gesagt, ich würde halt sagen, wenn jemand das mal richtig machen will, schmeißt iCal weg, denkt ihr, holt den visionären Grafikdesigner und macht einfach beide Seiten neu.
Nein, man muss Kalender mit anderen Leuten zusammen machen.
Ja, das kann man ja auch alles.
Aber wenn du iCal wegschmeißt, dann kannst du keine Termine mehr austauschen mit anderen Leuten.
Man macht halt ein neues Format. Warum?
Wie will man denn Termine austauschen mit anderen Leuten? Man muss mit denen irgendwie kommunizieren.
Ja, so wie jetzt auch halt.
Per Exchange oder was?
Nein, Kalender ist ein Systemdienst.
Du meinst nur das eigene Interne. Dann kann man ja auch bei iCal tauschen, oder? Man kann ja auch exporten nach iCal dann.
Du kannst auf deinem Mac ein Programm schreiben und das holt sich exakt dieselben Kalender wie iCal einfach aus derselben Stelle.
Ja.
So, das machen die auch alle. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Ja, aber wenn Huckel jetzt meint, man soll dieses iCal-Format wegschmeißen, das basiert nur mal auf dem iCal-Format, dann muss man das, also entweder man ist zu einem incompatibel...
Das Format ist überhaupt nicht das Problem.
Für Huckel schon. Ich will das weghaben.
Ja Huckel, aber in diesem Format kann man alles ausdrücken. Das ist scheiße zu pasen. Was kann man denn da nicht ausdrücken?
Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Ich wüsste da jetzt wenig.
Ich behaupte trotzdem, dass es eine Gedankenblockade verursacht bei diesem ganzen Kalender-Thema. Und mitverantwortlich ist für den i-Kalender.
So wie es geschrieben wird, ist es furchtbar. So, gar keine Frage. Diese ganze V-Card-Geschichte, diese ganze 80er Jahre Palm-Pilot-Scheiß, das ist irgendwie, das gehört zu den schlimmsten Dateiformaten, die wir haben. Aber das, was du da drin ausdrückst, das ist zwar nicht lesbar und nicht einfach passbar, aber es ist nicht falsch. Du kannst sagen, dieser Termin findet statt am letzten Freitag eines Monats.
Auf jeden Fall eine sehr emotionale Diskussion zum Thema.
Mir geht es wirklich ums User-Interface. Und wenn ein Programm nicht in der Lage ist, mir zu sagen, wie meine Zeit ist, vielleicht muss ich Outlook installieren, vielleicht ist da ja alles so. Aber es ist halt geil, viele Leute benutzen das.
Habt ihr schon mal Outlook benutzt? Ja, früher mal. In der Sendung, in der Tim Outlook nutzt.
Du benutzt jeden Tag Outlook?
Ja.
Outlook?
Auf deinem Mac? Microsoft Outlook?
Microsoft Outlook, ja.
Von Office?
Und?
Es ist einige Scheiße, das andere ist gut. Ich bin halt in so einer Firma, die so auf Exchange setzt. Und du kannst damit iCall und Konsorten, kriegt man das relativ okay hin. Also man kriegt da so ein Subset an Exchange-Sachen.
Bisher ist es so eine iOS-Developer-Bude.
Ja, das jetzt bald.
Und da ist dann alles auf Google. Aber bisher ist das eben alles noch Exchange-basiert. Und da macht sich das mit dem Office am besten. Und da haben die mir halt irgendwann gesagt, hier Max, willst du mal ein Office für den Mac haben? Dann hab ich gesagt, ja, hätte ich gern ein Office für den Mac. Und seitdem hab ich jetzt ein Office für den Mac. Das Mail-Programm ist jetzt auch nicht schlechter als das Mail in Snow Leopard, sag ich jetzt mal. Es sind ein paar ganz hübsche Details drinnen. Ein paar Sachen sind natürlich ganz furchtbar, wie man das so kennt.
Und da, in der Keynote von 1997, in diesem FAQ, wo er meint irgendwie, da gab es so einen ewig langen Rand von Ollestief auch zum Thema Mail-Programme. Da ist seine Vision noch sehr beschränkt.
Den Teil hat er noch nicht geschafft.
Hat jemand mal dieses Next-Step-Mail benutzt?
Nee, aber ich nehme an, dass...
Ach nee, der hatte einen anderen kleinen da. Das Video kannst du in den Show Notes auch noch mal verlinken, im Übrigen.
Seine Speech, die er noch, bevor er ICO wahrgehalten hat.
Das fand ich so lustig, wie viel sich seitdem geändert hat. So dieses, hey, wir machen jetzt hier mal so auf, ich rede mal mit euch Leuten, ich will hier keine Präsentation machen und wir neue Zurückhaltung und Demut und weißte treffe was. Ist jetzt nicht mehr allzu viel von da.
Nee, aber lass uns das Kalenderthema abschließen. Ich sage einen Satz dazu. Ich hoffe, irgendjemand von euch kommt einfach jetzt mal schnell mit einer echt coolen Lösung dieses Problems. Aber vielleicht schicker Kalender.
Aber vielleicht wollen die meisten Leute das auch einfach so. Die wollen vielleicht wochenweise ihre Termine sehen.
Ich will sie ja auch wochenweise sehen.
Ach guck mal, aber bei Outlook, da ist selbst Tim durch den aktuellen Tag.
Ich kriege sie ja nicht wochenweise präsentiert, sondern ich kriege sie kalendermonatweise präsentiert.
Wir haben doch auch wochenweise.
Aber dann sehe ich halt nur eine Woche.
Ja, wir haben es halt.
Ich kann doch noch mal von vorne anfangen.
Machst du das in deinem Kalender-Podcast?
Also, wenn ich Steve Jobs wär, und ihr werdet alle bei Apple, ihr werdet alle gefeuert.
Guckst du hier extra einen Fahrstuhl ein?
Irgendwann mal ein Fahrstuhl angefährt.
Ich hab gar nicht zugehört. Was hat er gesagt?
Hier gibt es noch eine Mac-Software, die kann ich nochmal loben.
Mal gucken, wie so ein Lob aussieht.
Mediathek. Als ich das erste Mal diese Mediathek runtergeladen habe, dachte ich, mir trifft der Schlag. Das war irgendwie so ein Java-Foo. Und ich bin mir nicht so ganz zu sicher, ob ich jetzt wirklich von demselben Programm rede. Aber das letzte Mal, als ich das benutzt habe, war das irgendwie echt schick. Also man kann jetzt wirklich, wenn da mal was im Fernsehen gelaufen ist und alle twittern darüber, kann man dann so darüber das in der Regel ganz gut finden und er lädt einem das einfach gnadenlos in so einem Hi-Res Epic 4 runter und alles ist gut. So eine Software, die auch übrigens schon längere Zeit bei Flatter sich zur Belohnung, weil es ja auch kostenlos ist, zur Belohnung ausgeschrieben hat. Und das ist so Software, wo ich so auch so eine Flatter-Subscription drauf habe.
Ach, das ist ja nett.
Das mache ich jetzt eigentlich mit jedem Programm, was ich benutze, was gut ist und was bei Flatter ist und was kostenlos ist.
Dann schreibt doch mal jemand ein Programm, mit dem man automatisch seinen Application-Folder durchscannen kann und dann alles wegflattern, was da noch drin liegt. Oder was in den letzten 30 Tagen geöffnet worden ist.
Ja, das würde man machen. Flatter ist jetzt übrigens mit Soundcloud zusammengegangen. Das dürfte dich ja eigentlich auch interessieren, Max.
Ja, ich hab, man kann, die sind direkt integriert. Also nicht so wie bei Twitter, wo man irgendwelche Twitter-Accounts anlegen kann.
Das ist bei der Bude, die diese Soundcloud abhackt.
Genau, ich bin demnächst bei der Bude, wo die Soundcloud abhacken tut.
Na, dann baut da mal Flatter ein.
Ja, das ist doch eine schöne Idee. Keine Ahnung, welche Priorität das da hat. Da gibt es irgendwie so eine Road... Also ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das abläuft. Ich frag mal nach, wie das abläuft.
Vielleicht ist das ja auch ganz einfach möglich.
Das ist ja aber eine coole Idee, das da einzubauen.
Gibt es denn eine richtig saubere Flatter-AP, die über den reinen Button hinausgeht, also dass man irgendwelche Credentials eingeben kann und dann...
Na, AP gibt es seit Jahr und Tag. Ich meine, das ist das, was der Button da benutzt.
Was mache ich mit meinen 100.000 Flatters, die ich jetzt schon habe?
100.000?
Ja, 30.
In Bitcoins investieren.
Was meinst du, was du damit machst?
Na, diese, die mich einfach so flattern auf meine Twitter-Adresse oder irgendwie sowas.
Achso, na, du legst dir mal einen Flatter-Account an und claims die.
Hast du das noch nicht?
Und dann?
Und dann bekommst du dafür Geld.
Dann kann ich sagen, hier wird der Konto überweisen, fertig. Oder ich kann ihn wieder spenden, wenn ich will. Big spender.
Also du kriegst es auf dein Flatter-Konto gut geschrieben, was auch immer dabei rauskommen mag. Und das kannst du dann entweder direkt weiter verflattern bzw. indirekt weiter verflattern, weil du musst es von dem Revenue-Konto auf dein Ausgabenkonto noch mal so flatterintern weiter schieben. Also wenn du das Patrouille nicht haben willst oder du ziehst es halt über PayPal oder Moneybookers auf so ein richtiges Konto raus.
Das sind so die Optionen.
Du kannst es natürlich auch erst mal gammeln lassen, aber in dem Moment, wo du halt claimsst, ab dem Moment werden diese Klicks überhaupt erst aktiv, weil solange das noch niemand geklaimed hat, kann man das zum Beispiel auch nicht subscriben.
Ach, das ist auch nicht vom Konto runter, das Geld?
Nein, nein, also wenn du jemanden klickst, der gar keinen Flatter-Account hat, über seinen Twitter-Account, da sagst du hier, du bist cool, ich flatter dich jetzt einfach mal, auch wenn du von Flatter noch nie was gehört hast, dann liegt der also als unclaimed-Click vor. Und der wird aber dann zu einem Ende des Monats, wenn der immer noch unclaimed ist, nicht berücksichtigt, aber er merkt sich, dass der immer noch unclaimed ist.
Also sozusagen flattert das zu dem Zeitpunkt, zu dem das geklamt wird?
Ich hätte es gerne geflattert, aber da es nicht geclaimed wurde, findet es nicht statt am Ende des Monats. Aber dieser Anspruch bleibt sozusagen so lange erhalten, bis du ihn explizit wieder wegnimmst, wenn man das überhaupt kann, weiß ich gar nicht. Und in dem Moment, wo halt jemand diesen Twitter-Account claimt, also sich bei Flatter ein Account macht und dann sagt, ich bin aber der Twitter-User sowieso und dann O aus Anmeldung über Twitter und so weiter, wie man das jetzt mit jedem Client macht, dann kriegst du quasi automatisch alle Klicks einmalig übergeben, die dann eben zum Ende des Monats dann auch aktiv werden.
Okay, ich dachte, dass das so wäre, dass das Geld dann quasi im luftleeren Raum liegt, nachdem da jemand einen angeclaimten Account geflittert hat.
So ist ja viel schicker. Genau, so ist es eigentlich viel schicker. Das haben die echt gut gemacht und ich hoffe, dass sie das auch demnächst mal auf Facebook oder so erweitern.
Da wird der Mark Zuckerberg bestimmt gut damit zusammenarbeiten. Ich glaube, Facebook ist doch nicht so das Ding für kreative Sachen, oder?
Naja, ich meine, da sind halt viele Menschen.
Oder für...
Bei Flatter ist es ja so...
KT-Spenden, damit er sich eine neue Doktorarbeit leisten kann.
Es ist ja so ein bisschen wie so ein Flatter, so ein angeclaimed Flatter-Click ist ja eigentlich so Nigeria Scam 2.0. Hello, my name is Mark Zuse Windows and I have money waiting for you. You only need to sign up here on this web page.
Sind halt bloß keine 30 Millionen, sondern ungefähr 4 Cent, aber...
Future looking bright. Alles in Großbuchstaben. Jetzt.
Komm mal zum großen Fiasco.
Ich sag, alles nicht so schlimm.
Ja, jetzt nachdem ich den Pogo-Stick gelesen hab, klingt das alles nicht so schlimm.
Hast du mal reingekickt?
Heisch Rene Kiekswort.
Also Final Cut Pro X, alle regen sich auf.
Wollen wir ein bisschen vor... Wir haben ja irgendwann mal darüber gesprochen, über Final Cut Pro X und haben dieses Video ausführlich rezitiert, wo sie...
alle tollen Features gezeigt hat.
Wo sie alle tollen Features begeistert waren.
Und alle so tierisch begeistert waren.
Ja, aber von Xcode 4 war ich vorher auch tierisch begeistert.
Ja, da wird auch noch die Features gezeigt, die da zukommen, nicht die, die wegfallen.
Genau, und bei diesem Final Cut X, da haben sie nicht erwähnt... Also haben sie gesagt, ey, 64-Bit, aber dafür könnt ihr eure alten Projekte nicht... Genau, aber kein 32-Bit mehr. Den Teil haben sie dann irgendwie unterschlagen. Und jetzt sind alle böse, weil sie nicht mehr arbeiten können mit Final Cut.
Also es gibt einen Aufschrei von Leuten, die die neuen Features gerne hätten, aber jetzt auf den alten hängen bleiben und wissen, dass wenn sie jetzt Final Cut Pro X im App Store kaufen, runterladen und installieren, dass sie weder ihre alten Projekte konvertieren können, und dass eben bestimmte Dinge für die, sagen wir mal, heute im Filmbusiness durchaus gängig sind für die Automatisierung, insbesondere für die Automatisierung eines Workflows zwischen unterschiedlichen Parteien, sprich Import- und Exportformate, dass das weitgehend nicht enthalten ist. Es gibt noch so diverse andere Kritikpunkte, die ich jetzt im Einzelnen so nicht bewerten kann. Aber im Wesentlichen läuft es immer darauf hinaus auf Features, die halt nicht drin sind und die vielleicht nochmal kommen könnten. Sachen, die konzeptionell vielleicht schwierig sind, die für mich ein bisschen schwer zu bewerten sind, in ihrer Aussage. Und Sachen, die man aber auch heute schon mit Plugins lösen kann. Es gab ja dann diesen Artikel, den du da erwähnt hast, jetzt hier, wo der Poke dem mal nachgegangen ist. Das heißt, er hat vorher diese ganzen Behauptungen oder die ganzen Klagen eingesammelt und ist dann zum Produktmanager von Final Cut Pro gegangen und der hat dann halt so Antworten geliefert. Das lief im Wesentlichen darauf hinaus, dass das, was empfiehlt, weitgehend schon durch Plugins gelöst wird bzw. durch Plugins gelöst werden könnte.
Durch Plugins gelöst wird?
Also es gibt doch noch keine Third Party Plugins.
Doch, es gibt dieses Automatic Doc.
Ja, es gibt so ein paar Tools zumindest, mit denen man halt noch die alten Files irgendwie dann wieder erzeugen kann oder wieder die Tonspuren in das alt gewohnte Format dann in die Files kleben kann.
Also es ist jetzt noch nicht so, dass es da eine wilde, vibrierende Landschaft von neuen Plugins gibt, aber es ist so, dass es diese Plugins Schnittstelle gibt und dass sie das ermöglichen könnte.
Also die zwei großen Problemzonen waren da einmal diese Red-Kameras, die halt vorher direkt irgendwie supported waren und jetzt halt nicht mehr. Und da haben sie halt geschrieben, ja wir arbeiten mit denen zusammen und gibts bald. Aber ihr könnt jetzt einfach auch einen Quicktime aufnehmen und dann gehts da auch. Und dann gibt es halt von Blackmagic, die halt irgendwie krasse Codex und krasse Setups so für Video-Foo machen. Mit denen arbeiten sie jetzt auch zusammen, um da irgendwie so wesentliche Teile irgendwie wieder funktionabel zu kriegen. Und Blackmagic, also die haben echt krasses Zeug. Die haben zum Beispiel, also hier, meine Freundin arbeitet ja in so einem Laden der Filme, also Analogfilme einscannt, und die haben da so richtig die krassen Filmscanner stehen, so für Millionen und Abermillionen von Euro. Und dann gibt es da von Blackmagic zum Beispiel so einen Ankommen. Ja, und da ist halt auch viel Blackmagic im Spiel. Die haben halt irgendwie so lossless-Codex und irgendwie allen möglichen Scheiß, auch Hardware und so. Und da waren halt viele halt verärgert, weil die jetzt erstmal nicht so direkt mitspielen. Und eigentlich so ein Punkt, der noch am ehesten, finde ich, nachvollziehbar ist, es gibt halt so bei diesen Filmstudios halt viele, die da jetzt schon echt viel Kohle in ihre Workflows und Setups und so weiter investiert haben. Und da gibt es ja auch so eine Petition von eben diesen Leuten, die meinen irgendwie, ja, wir haben uns jetzt hier so eine Industrie aufgebaut und für uns ist das jetzt Industriestandard und ihr macht jetzt den Support aus für Final Cut 7 oder was auch immer die letzte Version war.
Ja, der Support ist noch nicht weg, aber du kannst das nicht mehr kaufen.
Ich dachte, der Support ist auch aus. Also...
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie jetzt Support einstellen für eine Software, die sie noch vor ein paar Tagen verkauft haben.
Naja, aber es gibt keine Updates mehr dafür zum Beispiel. Also wenn jetzt noch Backup...
Es wird keine Feature-Updates mehr geben. Das ist halt Final Cut Pro X. Ich meine, das ist ihre Version.
Ja, ne, aber so wie ich das zumindest verstanden hab, beklagen sich da, dass halt irgendwie Support jetzt auch vorbei ist.
Ja, die Leute beklagen sich immer so einiges, was ja dann zum Beispiel in dieser Liste von dem Pok immer hieß mit, ihr habt nicht an der richtigen Stelle geguckt.
Naja, aber Support war dann zum Beispiel nicht dabei. Also das ist halt der Kernpunkt von dieser Petition.
Achso ja genau, jetzt gibt es ja auch noch eine Petition.
Die wollen halt, dass jetzt Apple zumindest den Support erstmal noch aufrechterhält, solange bis dann vielleicht mal irgendwie...
Ja, also gut gelaufen ist das auf keinen Fall, sonst wär es gar nicht so weit gekommen. Und ich frage mich auch, wie sie das so jetzt kontern wollen.
Ja, wir alle warten auf den Letter from Steve.
Genau, irgendwie der Vorhang muss aufgehen und wir werden jetzt das, das, das und das tun. Ich weiß auch nicht so richtig, was sie davon abhält, jetzt für eine bestimmte Zeit über noch das Alte mit anzubieten. Ich meine, dass sie das so schnell wie möglich loswerden wollen, das kann ich ja verstehen. Die Frage ist nur, ist der Zeitpunkt schon gekommen? Und dem scheint mir nicht so zu sein. Die zweite Frage ist, was haben sie jetzt für eine Power? Ich meine, sie haben jetzt zwei Jahre lang an einer Reimplementierung gearbeitet. Das muss schmerzhaft gewesen sein. Ja, sie haben es komplett neu geschrieben. Das ist Hardcore. Und jetzt, wo es draußen ist, jetzt können sie anfangen, es besser zu machen. Und vermutlich ist die Basis, auf der sie jetzt aufsetzen, so unglaublich viel, unendlich mal toller, als das, was sie vorher hatten, um da neue Features einzubauen. Dass ich mir auch vorstellen könnte, dass sie jetzt einen irren Pace hinlegen. Also keine Ahnung, wie die Roadmap ist, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es jetzt noch ein Jahr dauert, bis diese Software sich noch mal ändert. Also und signifikant neue Möglichkeiten.
Ein Ding, was irgendwie auch noch beklagt wurde, was auch nicht in diesem Poke-Artikel vorkam, war ja, dass diese Color-App jetzt auch wegfällt. Da gab es scheinbar auch total viele Fans von, um irgendwie das Coloring von einem Film anzupassen und so weiter.
Aber das ist ja eine Funktionalität, die jetzt in Final Cut Pro X mit drin ist.
Ja, aber es scheint nicht so gut zu funktionieren, ansonsten würden sich die Leute nicht so furchtbar aufregen, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, da ringen sich auch viele Leute auf, die sich das Ding noch nicht mal runtergeladen haben.
Also ich hab so die Vermutung, dass das schon ziemlich scheiße gelaufen ist, dass Apple da einfach mal richtig schön verkackt hat.
Richtig schön verkackt.
10 Meter Bremsspur, verstehst du?
Es ist halt so dieses, hätten sie halt nicht einstellen sollen. iMovie, dass sie von Grund auf neu anfangen, ist ja schön, aber bei QuickTime haben sie eine OK-Lösung gefunden, indem sie QuickTime 7 und QuickTime 10 parallel laufen lassen. Sie haben bei iMovie irgendwie so eine OK-Lösung gefunden.
Ja, aber iMovie hat das auch funktioniert.
Nee, da sind sie parallel gefahren. Auch mit der vorherigen iMovie-Version, die die dann kostenlos runterladen. Also gab's auch, haben sie es zuerst abgeschafft und haben sich die Leute beschwert. Und dann konntest du dir die iMovie-Version, die alte, kostenlos runterladen. Und nach ein paar Tagen haben sie sie zur Verfügung gestellt. Und dann haben sie sozusagen, bis die Features alle nachgerüstet waren. Und so eine Übergangszeit ist halt nötig. Wenn du nicht die gleichen Features zur Verfügung stellen kannst und keine abgehangene, gut funktionierende Software hast, dann erwarte nicht, dass irgendwelche Profis, die damit vielleicht Kinofilme schneiden wollen, dir begeistert um die Arme fallen, wenn sie nur beim Ausprobieren nicht mal ihre Testprojekte aufkriegen. Ich finde, die regen sich da zumindest ein Stück weit zurecht auf.
Dieses Öffnen von alten Sachen. Ich meine, die Antwort von Apple zu dem Thema war ja sowas wie die alten Projekte haben nicht die notwendige Information, dass wir da ordentliche Final Cut Pro X Projekte daraus machen können. Also diese Gruppierung von Dingen, die ja bei X jetzt dabei ist und die vorher nur vom draufgucken, wie es gemeint war, sich ergibt, was ja sozusagen nicht automatisch herausgelesen werden kann. Die liegen da in diesen Spuren und es gibt da nicht wirklich eine Gruppierung, wobei ich glaube, es gab auch bei Sieben schon irgendwelche Möglichkeiten zu bequellen. Aber ich kenne mich da auch nicht wirklich aus. Das war die Aussage von Apple. Ich denke mir allerdings auch, es wäre eigentlich ein super Training, wenn Sie so einen Importer haben, der das so importiert, ohne dass es groß gruppiert ist. Und du gehst dann los und fängst an, es zu gruppieren und einfach diese ganzen Features von Final Cut Pro damit zu erlernen. Also ich sehe durchaus da einen Nutzen in dieser Import-Funktionalität. Und ich wäre jetzt noch nicht mal so überrascht, wenn Sie dann doch da klein beigeben und das mit hinzufügen. Also so alte Projekte werden auch eigentlich immer mit der alten Software weiter bedient. Also ich meine ja auch so bei Premiere und so weiter. Wenn du da zwei, drei Versionen weitergekommen bist und du willst halt ein Projekt von vor vier Jahren noch mal öffnen, in der aktuellen Version, da rennst du auch gegen die Wand.
Ich dachte ja damals war schon schön, dass du mit Freehand oder Photoshop irgendwie deine alten PSDs, das kannst du ja auch noch heute machen, kannst ja auch noch einen PSD von Photoshop 3 aufmachen.
Ja gut, aber ein Dateiformat versus diesem super Mega-Wust an Formaten ist schon noch ein bisschen in andere Dimensionen, aber du hast recht. Legacy ist schön, aber irgendwann muss man den Schwanz halt auch abschneiden.
Ja, aber nicht nach drei Minuten und in dem Fall war es wirklich drei Minuten.
Genau, nicht nach drei Minuten, das ist echt Fail an der Stelle. Tja, Apple, tja, ihr dachtet, ihr könnt euch wohl alles erlauben.
Naja, also irgendwie...
Dabei könnt ihr euch nur fast alles erlauben.
Also ich meine, die Movieindustrie, da steckt halt auch schon einiges an Kohle drin und sie sind ja eigentlich scharf drauf, dass halt auch so richtig die Power-Tools irgendwie auf ihrer Plattform sind.
Ja, die wollen den Markt haben. Ich meine, Jobs ist Pixar und der hat da einfach Bezug. Also mich würde es enorm überraschen, wenn sie nicht in der Lage sind, sagen wir mal, innerhalb des nächsten halben Jahres da Frieden herzustellen. Also es würde mich einfach total überraschen. Weiß der Geier, wie ihre Roadmap-Ips ist? Ich meine, darüber sagen sie natürlich nichts und ich wäre nicht überrascht, wenn die Roadmap so ist, dass die nächsten zwei, drei wirklich großen Schritte sehr schnell hinterher kommen.
Ja, aber dann hätten sie Final Cut 7 auch abschaffen können, nach den zwei, drei großen Schritten.
Ja klar, sag ich ja auch. Sie sollten es auch wieder in Verkauf geben oder keine Ahnung, mal etwas kostenlos runterladbar machen, alles.
Da würden die Studenten dieser Erde alle in die Hände klatschen.
Ja, aber daran hätte ich glaube ich kein Interesse, weil damit schaffen sie sich eigentlich nur neue Support-Hölle, die sie eigentlich nicht mehr haben wollen. Und ich glaube auch die meisten, also meine die Studenten, sind wahrscheinlich mit dem aktuellen Final Cut Pro X auch voll bedient. Das ist einfach genau die Software, auf die sie schon immer gewartet haben. Ist ja nicht so, dass du damit nicht arbeiten könntest. Es ist nur so, dass du diese ganzen mega Pro-Features, die im professionellen Workflow, das ist alles, was ich bisher gehört habe, dreht sich nur da drum. Niemand übt generelle Kritik an dem, wie es funktioniert.
Also es gibt wohl auch keinen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, keinen Multikamera, keine Multikamera-Unterstützung.
Was meinst du damit?
Ich glaube, das ist, dass du einfach zwei Kameras parallel laufen lässt und dann sozusagen immer zwischen den beiden Kameras hinterher schaltest. Das ist jetzt meine Vermutung.
Naja, also da sind wir glaube ich auf dünnem Eis.
Wobei, das vermute ich jetzt mal, dass das heutzutage relatives Standardfeature ist.
Das ist ein Schnittsoftware, keine Kamerabetriebssoftware.
Naja, aber du hast zwei Videospuren und wenn du sagst, dass du in jedem Zeitpunkt sagen kannst und jetzt schalte zurück auf diese Spur und dass das auch dann als eins importiert wird, keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das so richtig der Punkt ist. Naja, also über uns jetzt da auch noch im Kopf und Kragen reden, in Final Cut Features und wer was da braucht. Also wie gesagt, es ist ein bisschen...
Also hier ist okay, meint im Chat, RTL habe komplett auf Final Cut Pro umgestellt und es sei jetzt unmöglich... Also sie haben sicherlich nicht auf Final Cut Pro X umgestellt, von daher muss es ja wohl möglich sein, mit einer professionellen Umgebung zu arbeiten, weil sonst hätten sie es ja wohl kaum gekauft und wenn es jetzt funktioniert, weiß ich überhaupt nicht, was sie dazu beklagen haben. Ich meine, wenn es jetzt geht, dann geht es ja jetzt. Und wenn dann irgendwann mal Final Cut Pro X soweit ist, dass es das alte Sieben vollständig ersetzen kann, dann tut man das.
Na ja, aber...
Upgrade-Cycles sind doch in dem Bereich sowieso über Jahre.
Ja, aber wenn sie jetzt auf die Idee kommen, neue Leute einzustellen und ein paar neue Arbeitsplätze hinzupacken, dann können sie legal keine Lizenzen mehr nachkaufen.
Und wie gesagt, wenn es halt tatsächlich keinen Support mehr gibt, das müsste man jetzt nochmal nachlesen genau, dann finden das bestimmt so große Studios einfach kacke, wenn sie jetzt bei Apple nicht mehr anrufen können und die sagen, ach nee, hier nochmal was anderes.
Ach, siehst du, doch tatsächlich. Multicamera Support heißt, mehrere Videospuren von mehreren Kameras importieren und live schneiden. Das heißt, Tasten drücken, um die Spur auszuwählen.
Wenn du eine Show aufnimmst mit zwei Kameras gleichzeitig, sozusagen die Zeit gleich, das machen, dass du hin und her wechseln kannst, je nachdem was ist und die Zeit sozusagen gleich bleibt.
Es gibt gar keinen Capture mehr in Final Cut Pro X. Oder doch, es gibt noch einen Live-Capture, aber irgendeinen Capture gab es nicht mehr, was es vorher gab.
Und keinen Support für den zweiten Monitor.
Du kannst halt nicht aufs Tape rausschreiben.
Und das ist, also das mit dem zweiten Monitor, das ist falsch. Diese Information ist nicht wahr, sondern es ist, dem wurde widersprochen, das sei sehr wohl so, dass das geht.
Ja, also dieser Poke-Artikel wäre da nochmal eine...
Ja genau, Capture gibt es, aber es gibt kein Batch-Capture mehr, das war es genau. Also du kannst nicht batchen, du wurde vorher gesagt, so Band hin und her, aber es gibt halt auch einfach keine Bänder mehr.
Ja, die meisten Leute, also niemand...
Es gibt natürlich noch Bänder, aber du kaufst heute keine Kamera mehr mit Bändern.
Final Cut Pro X ist nicht für Leute, die mit Technik vorgestern arbeiten und auch nicht von gestern, sondern von heute. Und das ist jetzt noch ein Jahr Schmerz und dann wird da kein Mensch mehr drüber reden. So, so viel zum Thema, wir reden über...
Dinge, über die wir uns nicht ausgehen.
Genau, wo wir keine Ahnung haben und uns das auch nicht genau angeschaut haben.
Ich hab hier noch was Schönes für dich, hier kannst du mal... Ich paste mal in den Chat so ein kleines Bild. Klick da mal drauf und mach das mal auf dem Schirm. Ja, zu diesem Thema Kalender und Zeitlines... Oh, da klicken jetzt alle Scheiß. Das ist hier von dieser Serie Dr. Who, die ich selber eigentlich nicht gucke, aber ich fand dieses Chart ganz schön... Leider ist es relativ klein.
Und relativ dunkel.
Und relativ dunkel, aber what people think time ist und dann unten what time actually ist. Daran musste ich gerade denken, als du dann so meintest, so mit Kalender und irgendwie die Zeit und das ist ja alles gar nicht so...
Kannst du mal den Text vorlesen unten.
Naja, aber so muss Kalendersoftware funktionieren.
So muss es aussehen.
Stimmt, mit Zeitreisen wird es dann mit deinem Kalendersoftware nochmal wirklich eine Herausforderung werden.
Zeitreisen, genau, gute Zeit.
Ich will, dass der Montag der vorjährigen Woche wieder verschwindet.
Einfache Sache, was mit iCal nicht geht. Du kannst keinen Zeitraum anlegen. Das ist ein reines User-Interface-Problem, wo du sagst, der Anfang ist in dieser Zeitzone und das Ende ist in der anderen Zeitzone. Zum Beispiel ich fliege in die USA. Du fliegst in eine andere Zeitzone und du willst einfach sagen, so steht das nämlich auf deinem Flugticket drauf. Da steht immer drauf, Abflug, lokale Zeit, Ankunft, die Zeit, da. Versuch das mal einzugeben, du wirst wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig.
Ich glaube, das ist zum Beispiel auch ein Problem, wo man mit iCal-Format schon an Grenzen stoßen kann.
Nein, das ist ein reines Darstellungsproblem. Na ja, es ist eine Zeitzone. Eine Zeitzone ist eine Darstellung von Zeit. Es gibt nur eine Zeit, G, M, T. Und der Rest, Zeitzone, Sommerzeit, der ganze Fu, ist einfach so leer mit Plus und Minus. Das kannst du live rausrechnen und das kannst du auch anzeigen. Aber es ist einfach unmöglich zu sagen, der eine ist da. Oder überhaupt dieses Mal eben. Also dafür gibt es in iCal zumindest die Möglichkeit, dass du das einschalten kannst, oder du kannst sagen, ich trag den jetzt mal anders ein. Aber dass man den auch zum Beispiel in beiden Zeiten anzeigen lassen kann. So was wie, wann ist die Keynote mit Steve Jobs? Dann willst du kalifornische Zeit haben, willst das eintragen, was du im Web liest. Aber du willst natürlich auch das immer korrekt übersetzt haben in deine lokale Zeit. Aber du willst auch immer mit dabei sehen können, dass du das eigentlich in dieser anderen Zeit eingetragen hast. Und dann willst du auch immer diese Informationen noch heimziehen.
Schreibt schnell in die Kalender, Sofiel. Schreibt um Himmels willen keine Kalenders, Sofiel.
Tim wird euch fertig machen. Ist egal, was ihr macht.
Schreibt eine bitte schnell bis zur nächsten Sendung.
Wenn ihr's macht, ich stoppe die Zeit.
Schmeißt alles rein.
Womit denn?
Lustige Sendung. So, wie sieht's aus jetzt? Wie sieht was aus?
Denis? Die scharen schon mit den Hufen.
Das ist der letzte Punkt. Du erklärst uns, wie wir jetzt alle reich werden.
Nee, ich erkläre euch, wie man scheitert, reich zu werden.
Wie Denis reich wird.
Also es sind ja mehrere Sachen. Also erstens die Geschichte mit dem Öl. Kann man ja schnell erzählen. Hast du nicht gesehen mein Twitter?
Ach so, ich dachte du erzählst jetzt hier irgendwas über Peak Oil.
Peak Oil, ja das ist es auch.
Nein, das Thema ist Bitcoin.
Genau, und die Geschichte mit dem Öl hat ja so ein bisschen damit zu tun.
Denis hat sich ein bisschen beschäftigt.
Ja, ich hab mit meinen Kumpels, die haben halt so eine Art uns zusammengesetzt. Wir haben gedacht, wir teilen uns ein paar Grafikkarten, shoppen die zusammen, teilen uns die Kohle und teilen uns auch den nicht vorhandenen Gewinn.
Und macht ihr mit Bitcoin, wie heißt das? Mined Bitcoins.
Mined Bitcoins, so. Und weil wir so eine Grafikkarte haben, das so El Chipo ist, eine 5850 von AMD, ist aber irgendwie so ein billig, würde ich mal sagen, Produkt, das ist nicht mehr das Referenzding, wie man das so schön sagt, sondern schon eine spätere Karte, die in Gehäuse hat, was halt, muss man mal erklären, ins, also in einem PC hast du die Grafikkarte da drin, dann kühlt die halt einfach ins Gehäuse rein, anstatt das hinten über diesen PCI-Slot rauszuschieben. Verstanden? Okay, wenn du davon vier Stück auf ein Motherboard machen willst, was geht, wenn du das entsprechende Motherboard hast, dann würde das in dem Rechner ziemlich warm werden, oder auch wenn du selbst gar kein Gehäuse drumrum hast, das würde ziemlich heiß werden, weil die halt nicht wegblasen, sondern einfach nur so neben sich. Und wenn gleich die nächste Grafikkarte da neben ist, würde das ein bisschen zu heiß werden. Deswegen dachten wir uns, Ölkühlung ist mal angesagt. Haben wir ein bisschen gegoogelt, leider viel zu schnell, weil jemand hat gesehen, Rapsöl wäre das Richtige. Haben wir den ganzen Scheiß in Rapsöl getaucht, hat super funktioniert, also es kühlt super toll. Müsste man jetzt das Öl auch noch kühlen, das haben wir nicht gemacht, aber das könnte man mit so einem Ölkühler prima machen. Haben wir uns auch schon geholt, VW Golf, 20 Euro, so ein Riesending von Ölkühler. Wahrscheinlich bräuchte man nicht mal mehr Luft.
Ihr habt euch einen Ölkühler von einem Golf geholt?
Ja, 20 Euro. Billiger als was die Leute sich in ihre Wassergekühlten PCs einbauen, weil die kosten locker mal 100 und sind vielleicht ein Zehntel so groß.
Also du hast ein Motherboard genommen, mit vier sauteuren Grafikkarten drauf.
Wir haben da erstmal eine billige genommen. Die vier Grafikkarten haben wir noch nicht versenkt.
Mit einer Grafikkarte und habt die so erstmal schön ins Frittenfett gehält.
Andersrum, wir haben so eine Wanne genommen, haben das Motherboard da reingemacht, haben erstmal alles angeschlossen, Lief, Bildschirm, alles dran, Tastatur und so. Und so und dann haben wir die erste Flasche Öl genommen. Der Mutige ist vorgegangen, der Rest ist zurückgetreten. Dann haben wir das ganz entspannt direkt auf den Lüfter der CPU gegossen, damit es schön noch rumschlackert. Und dann haben wir das halt, wir haben 10 Liter Rapsöl gehabt, haben wir das halt vollgefüllt, bis die Grafikkarte halt sozusagen unter Öl war.
Aber Platte und so nicht?
Platte außerhalb, weil die Platte geht halt nicht, Netzteil auch, könnte man aber auch versenken, Netzteil geht. Also Öl leitet halt nicht, deswegen du kannst halt Öl nehmen. Also Wasser leitet wegen den Mineralien und so weiter, und auch destilliertes Wasser würde irgendwann verdrecken und würde Leiten, Öl halt nicht. Wobei ich nicht verstehe, warum das Öl nicht auch verdreckt.
Macht es auch, aber es dauert länger, bis es dann leitet.
Jedenfalls Netzteil haben wir nicht, Platte nicht, weil die brauchen nicht das Entlüftungsloch, weil die haben ja da so eine, weiß schon, zum Entlüften, weil die Luft sich in dem Gehäuse ausdehnt, die muss irgendwo raus und rein können und so. Jedenfalls, das Öl hatte erst mal Zimmertemperatur, ist ja Sommer, hatte irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 25 Grad oder 23. Und es hatte locker irgendwie zwei Stunden gedauert, bis das Öl irgendwie auf, keine Ahnung, 35 Grad kam. Also es hat ewig gedauert, weil das Öl hat ja an sich erstmal eine große Masse an Kapazität, um Energie aufzunehmen. Das hat es natürlich erstmal getan. Ansonsten muss du natürlich, das Öl nimmt auch nur die Energie auf, also das Gesamtsystem halt ab, sondern du musst auch dem Öl irgendwie diese Energie natürlich wieder nehmen. Also kühlen musst du das Öl auch. Es ist nicht so, dass du da Öl drauf schüttest und du hast jetzt eine Kühlung, sondern irgendwann ist das Öl halt auch heiß.
Klar.
So, geht natürlich besser, weil es halt flüssig, das heißt du kannst es schneller von dem Ding, was heiß wird, nämlich CPU und Grafikkarte wegführen. Hast du irgendwie so einen kleinen, wie im Aquarium, so kleinen Propeller unterm Öl, der das ein bisschen bewegen lässt und dann irgendwie einen Schlauch, der das durch diesen VW-Golfkühler leiten würde, was wir noch nicht haben, aber das könnte man so machen, der das dann locker wegkühlen kann, weil der so riesengroß ist, dass man meiner Meinung nach fast nicht mal Lüfter bräuchte.
Aber jetzt mal blöde, wäre es denn nicht, also ich meine, das ist klar deutlich teurer, aber wäre es denn nicht besser, so Motorölfüll zu nehmen oder sowas?
Das Rapsöl war auch eine blöde Idee, weil das wird ranzig.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, das stinkt ziemlich schnell, oder?
Aber war es euch nicht klar?
Nein, wir haben das irgendwie, das war es. Das war die Kurzschlussreaktion, am nächsten Tag war das Öl. Weißt du, wir sind doch Nerds, wir wollten es ausprobieren. Das ging alles ganz schnell.
Aber irgendwie im Club oder jedem, dem ich gefragt habe, oder dem ich es erzähle, war das nicht ranzig?
Die Lehrerin hat es gedacht. Eine hat halt für Google gemeint, ja, Rapsöl geht. Weil auf irgendeiner Seite doch tatsächlich steht, mit Rapsöl könnte man das prima machen. Und ist ja auch egal, wir wissen, dass wir das Öl auch wechseln müssen. Es war halt ein Test, hat funktioniert. Und die Katze, die auf dem Bild ist, die lebt noch. Also ihr müsst doch keine Sorgen machen. Auf irgendeinem Bild rennt die Katze Mütze rum. Der heißt Mütze, ist immer sehr neugierig und still alive. Und das ist die Geschichte mit dem Öl. Hat halt indirekt mit Bitcoin-Meinen zu tun.
Also es ist ranzig geworden?
Nee, das steht noch genauso da. Und da ist noch nichts ranzig eigentlich. Also witzigerweise hier Mütze, die Katze geht immer ran. Und der will immer am Öl schlabbern. Jetzt haben wir schon was oben drauf gelegt, aber die Kiste hat auf den Bildern, ich hab die gefiltert, ihr könnt ja gucken, hat an der Seite so Griffe, wo man durchgreifen kann. Und dann haben wir die Katze entdeckt, wie sie an der Seite ist, die Fote voll durch dieses Grifffloch durchsteckt und wieder reintatscht und sich das Öl daraus holen. Also irgendwie ist er scharf auf das Öl. Es hält Rapsöl. Der Mütze ist eh ein bisschen komisch, der isst auch lieber Käse anstatt Fleisch.
Das ganze Mainboard in Rapsöl läuft ohne Probleme?
Einwandfrei, ja.
Ich hab das ja schon öfters mal gehört, ich hab Lust, jetzt kenn ich, ob jemand das probiert hat.
Aber spritzt das nicht, wie sau, wenn da dieser Lüfter sich da drin dreht?
Der ist ja auch unterm Öl, das ist so träge, da spritzt nichts. Der dreht nur ein bisschen lang. Ich hab da auch ein Video gepostet, da siehst du, wie das Öl sich so ein bisschen bewegt, weil der Lüfter sich dreht da. Also ist ja kein Lüfter mehr, ist ja jetzt ein Öler. Das Video hab ich auch gepostet, das müsste da irgendwo sein. Also ich weiß nicht, wie man das in meiner Timeline irgendwie sehen kann. Vielleicht einer aus dem Öl-Channel.
Denis wird da doch nicht so viel.
Ist irgendwie schneller. Ja, es ist gleich, dass ein, zwei Bilder weiter müsste das ja sein.
Da ist doch hier ein Play-Button da oben.
Auf Y-Frog.
Ja, da ist ja schon der Play-Button.
Alles klar.
Die Leute, die den Podcast hören, müssen natürlich jetzt auch das Video suchen, damit ihr das jetzt auch gucken könnt. So wie wir. Ja, da ist auch Ton, aber ist nicht so spannend.
Und das Video ist irgendwie da komisch.
Womit hast du das aufgenommen?
Mit meinem iPhone.
Womit hast du es hochgeladen?
Das ist dein Player, der da schuld ist. Ja, ich hab das mit meinem iPhone aufgenommen. Ich schick mir meinen Link zu.
Er hat's halt hochformatbestimmt aufgenommen und dann hat das iPhone ja bei Videos keine Flash-Player.
Ja, doch. Ich hab ne Ahnung, was es sein könnte. Ich hab's in einem Format aufgenommen und hab es irgendwann gedreht. Und wahrscheinlich hat er die Position des Aspektratios beim Schließen des Videos genommen, und nicht die beim Starten, was auch immer. Ist nicht meine Schuld, bei mir sieht's alles voll schick aus.
Yfrog schickt mir ein HTML5, ja.
Den schicken wir gerade die letzte Flasche rein.
Klingt auf jeden Fall sehr lustig.
Und wie viel kühler war's dann so?
Zimmertemperatur.
Und vorher?
Na vorher, keine Ahnung, 40, 50 Grad warm. Das Öl wird auch auf Dauer so warm werden. Aber du kannst das Öl besser kühlen. Das ist der Witz. Die Energie, die du da verballerst, ist ja immer die gleiche. Nur das Öl kann es schneller wegverbreiten. Und dann kannst du es schneller runterkühlen.
Und dann läuft einfach der Ölkühler nebenbei.
Genau, ganz entspannt. Deswegen die ganzen Overclocker, diese PC-Gamer, die irgendwie sich die fetteste Intel-CPU holen, die haben eine Wasserkühlung, haben da Radiatoren im Gehäuse, da ist das schon fertig, oben im Deckel drin, da klemmst du diese oben in den Deckel. Der Deckel hat nach oben so Schlitze, da sind die Lüfter drin, die ziehen dann die Luft durch diese Wasser-Radiatoren durch. Und dann haben die da Wasserkühlung und deren CPU ist, obwohl die da overclocken bis 4 Gigahertz oder so, ist die immer bei 40 Grad oder so, also ganz entspannt. Das machen die Overclocker. Und bei den Grafikkarten genau dasselbe, weil gerade Grafikkarten willst du ja overclocken wie blöd, weil sonst dein Crysis 2-Funk...
Also wie schließt du jetzt eine Grafikkarte aus dem Handel an deine Wasserkühlung an?
Hast du nicht auch das Video gesehen, wo ich gezeigt hab, wie Grafikkarten hergestellt werden? Das sah sehr schick aus, das war richtiger Nerdpaun. Hast du nicht gesehen? Aber Alter, followst du mir nicht oder was?
Doch.
Also dann nimmst du das Original-Kühlkörper-Teil mit von der Grafikkarte runter, dann holst du dir von so einem Third-Party-Hersteller den Wasserblock, der ist genau, ein Kupferblock genau gefräst, dass er genau auf die entsprechende Grafikkarte raufpasst, schraubst du irgendwie fest, da ist halt dann so Spuren drin, wo das Wasser durchgeht, da drüber ist meistens ein Plexiglas-Deckel oder was anderes, dass du sogar noch zugucken kannst und da wird einfach Wasser durchgeschossen, wie blöd. Und das schließt du zusätzlich auch an deinen Kühlkreislauf, an der auch schon die CPU kühlt oder auch nicht.
So übliche und gefärbtes Wasser, damit es so ein bisschen schicker aussieht.
UV gibt es, damit es dann strahlt, weil die haben ja auch beleuchtete Gehäuse und so, da musst du noch Zeug reinmachen, damit es nicht irgendwie hier Bakterien und so, damit es keine Pilze oder so.
Und warum nehmen die denn nicht Öl, wenn Öl besser ist als Wasser?
Weil bei denen ja, die versenken ja nicht die Grafikkarte selbst, berührt ja das Wasser, sondern das Wasser fließt durch den Kühlkörper. Und wir haben einfach alles versenkt, weil man das halt auch so machen kann, und das ist halt nicht so teuer. Diese Grafikkarten-Blocks kostet pro Grafikkarte für die teure nur so 100 Euro. Die Radiatoren, also die Kühlkörper, kosten irgendwie 100 Euro, oder 80, 60, keine Ahnung. Du brauchst doch noch mal eine Wasserpumpe, dann brauchst du so einen kleinen Behälter. Also wenn du für eine fette Grafikkarte so nicht gerade billig irgendwie Wasserkühlung machst, sind locker mal 250, 300 Euro weg.
Aber so ein Ölkühler aus dem VW ist ja nicht dafür da, um das Öl beim Fahrtwind zu kühlen?
Nee, die haben auch Propeller.
Die haben auch ein Propeller, wenn du stehst. Deswegen sind doch die Autos manchmal, die an der Ampel stehen, und das ist irgendwie Sommer.
Ach so, die dann noch runterkühlen.
Genau.
Du musst aber auch die ganze Zeit das Fenster aufmachen, ansonsten.
Der Körper ist doch nicht im Auto, also nicht im Innenraum, der ist doch vorne am Motor.
Nein, ich meine, wenn du dann zu Hause in deiner Wohnung so ein Ölkühler rumstehen hast.
Also die Energie, kann ich das tausendmal betonen wieder, die Energie, die entsteht. Die ist immer die gleiche. Du kriegst sie halt mit Wasser oder Ölkühlung, du kriegst sie besser entsorgt. Aber wenn die Grafikkarte 300 Watt irgendwie verbraucht, dann verbraucht die 300 Watt und da entsteht Wärme für 300 Watt und die muss irgendwie weg.
Du solltest die Wärme verkaufen, ich glaube, damit verdienst du mehr als mit dem Bitcoins.
Die Drei-Sätze der Thermodynamik, von nichts kommt nichts, viel hilft viel und was weg ist, ist weg.
Da sieht man gerade jetzt in dem Video, was ich gepostet habe, ihr müsst in meine Timeline gucken, von Twitter, wie halt so eine Grafikkarte in so einer CNC-Fräse irgendwie schnell hergestellt wird. Die nehmen wirklich einen puren Alublock, weil Alu ist halt so schön wärmeleitend und fräsen die so hin, dass sie genau auf die Grafikkarte raufpasst, weil der Memory der Grafikkarte muss ja auch gekühlt werden. Und ja, da schicken wir ihn später Wasser durch und dann ist alles schick. Also ich fand das sehr schick, wie die da loslegen und die lasern auch dann ihre Gravuren drauf und so weiter und so fort. Das kommt auch noch später.
Also so ähnlich wie so eine MacBook-Behäuse bloß halt nach innen gedreht.
Genau, das ist nicht Unibody Alu, das ist Unibody Kupfer. Und der muss da echt ein Speed auf dieser Spindel haben, mit der der lang fräst. Das muss schon erstaunlich sein, weil da geht der echt durch. Da denkst du, der fährt da durch, buttert durch. Also schon ganz schön krass. Ja, das ist...
Nicht Öl gekühlt.
Na, man nimmt bei Eisen eine Mischung aus Wasser und Öl. Bei Kupfer weiß ich nicht, weil bei Alu, glaube ich, nimmt man auch nur Wasser. Boa, Milch heißt es dann. Ja, das wär erst mal das. Und was gibt's noch zu erzählen? Dann das Bild, was ich gepostet hab, wo man ein X sieht.
Du musst mal diese ganzen Urls aufschreiben.
Ja, das kann mir bitte wer anders machen im Chat. Ich guck ja, wenn's keiner macht.
Mach ich's, aber ich kann grad nicht.
Wo sollen die die hernehmen?
Aus meiner Twitter-Timeline, Mann. So, jedenfalls die X-Konsole, den X-Schirm, den ich gepostet hab, auf meiner Twitter-Timeline. Das ist das, was mein Rechner zu Hause gerade an Bitcoins meint. Da sind drei Grafikkarten drin. Zwei davon sind Dual-GPU-Grafikkarten. Das heißt, da sind fünf GPUs am Rechner. Man sieht die Werte, wie schnell die da gerade sind. Und dann ist da noch so ein Tool, womit man den Core... Genau, ohne Worte heißt es. Da sieht man, wie ich den Core-Clock auch hochtakte und den Memory runterklocke, weil Memory braucht man beim Bitcoin, beim Schaas berechnen nicht. Und dann kann man locker nochmal 20 Watt pro Karte sparen, wenn man den Memory runterklocke, weil wir wollen ja auch Strom sparen, weil ist ja alles teuer, teuer. Und gleichzeitig bleibt dann auch mehr Volt für den Core-Clock übrig, sodass man den besser übertakken kann, wenn man den Memory runterklocke. Also es ist A und O beim Performance rausholen, beim Bitcoin-Mining.
Du hast da vier Fenster gerade offen, die... Fünf. Ach, da ist noch eins, okay. Die jeweils so 350 bis die schnellste 420 MHz pro Sekunde berechnen.
Na, da sind 2x AMD 5970-Karten, das sind Dual-GPU-Karten, die sind ein bisschen langsamer getaktet, weil es halt zwei auf einem Board sind, sonst würde es mehr Strom verbrauchen, als die PC-I-Spec von Intel irgendwie sagt, dass man machen darf. Das sind 350 MHz pro GPU. Und dann ist da noch eine Single-Karte, die kann halt richtig so viel Strom nehmen, wie sie braucht, und die schafft so bis 440. Die laufen jetzt bei mir ein bisschen langsamer, weil ich hab festgestellt, wenn ich sie ein bisschen langsamer laufen lasse, dann crashen sie seltener. Und wenn sie halt nachts, wenn ich schlafe crashen, und die dann 8 Stunden nicht laufen, dann nützen mir die halben Prozent, die ich da rausgekitzelt habe, auch nichts. Also lasse ich sie ein bisschen entspannter laufen, und dafür laufen sie jetzt wenigstens durch. Und das ist sozusagen, so wie es jetzt bei mir die ganze Zeit aussieht, die Kiste frisst wahrscheinlich locker 800, 900 Watt.
Das ist wie so ein kleiner Wasserkocher, der mir die ganze Zeit rumsteht.
Allerdings, aus der Grafikkarte, aus der einen kommt, die Dynamite verbaut ist, die am heißesten wird, kommt 70 Grad heiße Luft raus. Irgendwo muss die Wärme hin. 70 Grad.
Und wie viel kostet dich der reine Betrieb dieser Anlage pro Tag?
800, 900 Watt kannst du ausrechnen. 24, 7. Das heißt, es sind so 900 mal 24. Das ist ein Kilowatt dann so und so viel mal 20 Cent.
Du kannst am Haus noch ein paar Schläuche legen und Fernwärme verkaufen.
Im Winter kann ich mir meine Heizung auslassen.
648 Kilowatt wären das pro Monat, ungefähr, wenn ich das jetzt gerade richtig ausgerechnet habe. Da kostet so eine Kilowattstunde 30 Cent, oder?
Nee, 20.
Und hast du jetzt schon erfolgreich Bitcoin berechnet?
Ich mach schon so ein paar Bitcoins am Tag.
Paar Bitcoins am Tag?
Also ich mach auf jeden Fall noch mehr, als ich gerade an Stromkosten habe, mit den aktuellen Bitcoin-Preisen. Meine Hoffnung ist ja aber, dass die Bitcoins auch steigen, weil sonst ist das ja alles eh sinnlos.
Wie sieht es denn aus auf dem Markt?
Die Schwierigkeit erhöht sich ja. Das heißt, ich kann ja nicht ewig zwei Bitcoins erzeugen, denn demnächst, wenn sich die Schwierigkeit wieder verdoppelt, dann erzeuge ich ja zum Beispiel nur noch einen Bitcoin und nicht mehr zwei. Das heißt, damit sich das dann lohnen müsste, auch entsprechend der Preis sich für einen Bitcoin irgendwie verdoppeln, damit ich am Ende die gleichen Dollar... 50 Bitcoins, wenn du einen Block findest. Ich suche ja nicht einen Block. Ich bin ja in so einem Pool und da kriegst du Anteile. Da kommen wir gleich hin, zu dem Pool.
Aber die Chance ist doch auch, wenn jetzt irgendjemand... Also wenn ich das... Ich habe ja am Anfang... Wir haben das glaube ich auch total falsch erklärt. Wir haben ja gedacht, dass man tatsächlich diese Bitcoins berechnen würde.
Wir haben sehr, sehr viel falsch erklärt. Ich bin ein very sorry Dimitri.
Also wir haben ja...
Ich weiß nicht zumindest, dass ich berechtigt verwirrt war.
Jaja, wir auch. Wir haben uns rumgerät. Aber es ist auch wirklich komplex. Also ich meine, ich bin ja wirklich schon seit ein paar Wochen dabei und bin echt tief eingetaucht in die Materie. Und es ist schon nicht so easy alles.
Man rechnet ja gegen andere eigentlich.
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Na eigentlich... Na nicht gegen andere. Also du kannst... Wie soll ich sagen? Ich hab auch mal überlegt, ob man zum Beispiel andere... Wenn man andere dossen würde. Also angenommen, du rechnest, ich rechne. Und ich will nicht, dass du irgendwie Blöcke findest, könnte ich dich ja dossen, dass du nicht so zum Rechnen kommst. Aber es nützt mir gar nichts, weil ich muss rechnen und ich muss den Block finden. Was die anderen machen, ist total Schnuppe.
Naja, aber in dem Moment, in dem weniger Leute an dem System teilnehmen, wird doch die Komplexität runtergesetzt.
In dem weniger Leute was finden würde, dann nach 2016 Blöcken wird die Schwierigkeit neu berechnet. Und die Schwierigkeit passt sich immer so an, dass mit der Geschwindigkeit, mit der die letzten 2016 Blöcke berechnet werden, dass die nächsten 2016 Blöcke auch wieder genau zwei Wochen brauchen. Das heißt, wenn sich die Anzahl der Leute und damit die Hashing-Rate verdoppeln, dann wird sich die Schwierigkeit beim nächsten Mal auch verdoppeln, dass wieder alle doppelt so lange brauchen, damit es wieder zwei Wochen sind.
Insofern rechnet man schon gegeneinander. Indirekt, aber es ist wirklich... Naja, aber wenn jetzt alle immer mehr aufrüsten, dann wird das in zwei Wochen...
Dann muss ich sozusagen mit aufrüsten, damit ich den gleichen Anteil kriege, wie in der Woche davor. Aber die rüsten ja nicht nur auf, sondern es werden ja auch, sagen wir mal, 10.000 Leute, die eine Woche berechnen, haben alle die gleiche Grafika, um es mal einfach zu machen. Und wenn es dann 20.000 sind, ich kann ja aus meiner Person nicht zwei machen. Das heißt, dann kriege ich einfach mal nur noch die Hälfte. Und das ist dieser Schwierigkeitsfaktor. Und da gerade immer mehr Leute einsteigen, ist der Anteil, den ich kriege, immer geringer. Und das ist dieser Difficulty-Faktor. Und der ist, am Anfang, als ich geguckt hab, war der bei 200.000, inzwischen ist der bei 1,4 Millionen. Das heißt, das ist siebenmal schwerer als vor irgendwie sechs oder acht Wochen. Das heißt, ich kriege jetzt mit der gleichen Hardware siebenmal weniger Bitcoins als vor sechs bis acht Wochen.
Und sind die auch siebenmal mehr wert in dem?
Ja, doch, die Bitcoins sind natürlich, vor sieben, acht Wochen waren die irgendwann bei 7 Dollar. Jetzt sind sie bei 17, zwischendurch waren sie mal bei 30, weil die bei Fox News irgendwie, da sind die ja nach oben geschossen, wie blöd. Aber die schwanken, aber zurzeit sind die ziemlich stabil bei 17 Dollar, weil jetzt auch MT-Gogs, die waren ja gehackt worden, vielleicht haben viele Leute die Geschichte gehört, da wurde die Passwortliste, die Passwortliste mit den Hashes, da kommt es her, die wurde irgendwie geleakt, hat irgendwie, ist die den abhanden gekommen, dann fingen die Leute an auch mit ihren Grafikkarten übrigens, es gibt ein Tool, das heißt Hash Kill, damit kann man... Hash Kill, damit kann man Passwörter, sind ja ein Passwett, kennst du ja, die waren ja früher mit Crypt, irgendwie, da stand ja nicht das Passwort drin, sondern der Hash von dem Passwort, und inzwischen ist es nicht mehr Crypt, sondern irgendwie auch, keine Ahnung, SHA-256 oder irgendwas, und das ist ja genau das, was Bitcoin auch rechnet, und deswegen gibt es natürlich auch schon lange Tools, die die Grafikkarte benutzen, um diese Hashes wieder zu rechnen, also die fangen halt mit Dictionary-Attacks an, oder gehen einfach die Buchstaben durch und machen alle Kombinationen, und wenn sie die mit 3-buchstabigen Passwörter durch haben, nehmen sie die 4-buchstabigen und arbeiten sich so langsam durch. Das haben die mit dieser Passwortliste von diesem MT-GOX-Exchange auch gemacht, und da wurden schon irgendwie eine Liste mit 1000 Passwörtern irgendwie gepublished, das sind die, die sie schon alle geknackt haben. Deswegen musste man sich ja bei MT-GOX auch irgendwie seinen Account reclaimen, musste möglichst viel angeben, um zu beweisen, dass es der eigene Account ist, um den wiederzubekommen. Also GPUs sind gerade im Kommen, also Passwort knacken, Bitcoins rechnen oder halt auch für Renderfam, was aber mehr so NVIDIAs Ecke ist. AMD ist mehr Integer und deswegen sind die in Krypto gerade so gut. Oder ich hab gehört, so hat mir auch ein Vögelchen geswitchert, der GSM kann man auch prima knacken mit Grafikkarten. Ja, oder hast auch immer die da genutzt, keine Ahnung. Genau, so, jetzt kommen wir zum eigentlichen Thema. Ich hab irgendwie seit zwei Wochen sitze ich mit noch drei weiteren Kumpels da und wir schreiben an einem Bitcoin-Mining-Pool. Weil man kann ja, selbst wenn man noch die dickste Kiste hat, wenn man einen Blog finden will, der 50 Bitcoins wert ist, bräuchte ich Monate. Das schafft natürlich einer alleine nicht oder so lange will man nicht warten. Deswegen tun sich ganz viele Leute in einem Pool zusammen, sagen wir mal 1000, dadurch ist man 1000 mal schneller. Du findest den Blog schon nach, sagen wir mal, eine Stunde. Dann kriegst du aber auch nur einen Tausendstel dieser 50 Bitcoin, die dann gefunden wurde. Jeder kriegt natürlich seinen Anteil, je nachdem, wie viel er mitberechnet hat. Dafür sind diese Pools da, um sich zusammen zu tun. Der Pool übernimmt sozusagen diese Verteilungsinfrastruktur. Da gibt es schon einige. Eine heißt Deepit, eine heißt BTC-Guild, eine heißt Slushpool oder so wird er genannt. Wir haben jetzt auch einen, der heißt btcmp.com. Da muss man auf die Webseite www.btcmp.com gehen. Also btcmp wie Bitcoin Mining Pool. Da kann man sich einen User anlegen. Dann wird automatisch ein Worker angelegt.
Ich hab euch da nicht einen schicken Namen eingefallen lassen. Warum immer so?
Ich wollte einen kurz nehmen, weil man muss den andauernd eintippen. Bitcoin Mining Pool BTC-MP fand ich voll toll aus. Es ist fünfbuchstabig und ich will die später mal, wenn Bitcoin schon keinen Schwein mehr kennt, dann habe ich eine fünfbuchstabige Domain. Ich denke ja ein bisschen voraus. Da habe ich auch irgendwann dennis.btcmp.com btcmp.com? Ja, das spricht sich irgendwann ganz easy.
Bestimmt. Irgendwann sind Bitcoins free rate und btmc.com spricht sich leicht.
Ganz früher mussten die Leute bei Google bestimmt auch überlegen, wie das geschrieben wird, inzwischen nicht mehr. Und BTCMP wird auch mal ganz groß rauskommen, ich sehe das schon.
Ich hätte es anders genannt, aber...
Ja, wieder, erzähl mal. Du kannst mir ja immer noch holen.
Wie klondike.biz oder so.
Wo ist alles eintippen, man?
Geht nur mit, geht nur mit, äh, mit www vorne?
Nicht?
Also wenn ich da...
Ja, das wollten wir absichtlich nicht, weil das Problem ist, irgendwann haben wir, also wenn das System wirklich wächst und die Leute wirklich das, hier sieht man in den Examples, in ihren Phönix oder Pudding Pop irgendwie Open-Cell-Miner eintragen, wenn die da nur btcmp.com eintragen, dann kriegen wir das nie wieder auf andere Domains verschoben, wenn wir mal mehrere Pools irgendwie, also mehrere Frontends haben. Deswegen habe ich da extra dafür gesorgt, dass das halt irgendwie nicht so richtig geht. Und unser Pool heißt auch rr.btcmp.com, weil es sozusagen Round Robin ist. Ich will das per DNS dann verteilen. Und die Pools sollen dann, wenn wir mal mehrere haben, P1, P2, P3 heißen und so weiter, falls sich die Leute das dann einzeln einstellen wollen. Also ich habe ja schon die anderen Pools so ein bisschen beobachtet und geguckt, was sie so falsch machen und BTC gilt. Der hat es mal falsch gemacht und alles hat auf seine Haupt-Webseite geballert und der konnte seinen zweiten Rechner nicht an den Start kriegen, weil den halt keiner benutzt hat und der musste ja den Trafik von seinem Haupt-Rechner wegkriegen. Und der hatte richtig ein Problem. Und ja, aus Fehlern anderer sollte man lernen. Das ist immer besser als aus einem eigenen. Also die Sache ist die jetzt, Jungs, jetzt mal einen Aufruf an euch. Ihr müsst jetzt alle ordentlich auf diesen Pool meinen, weil das Problem ist, dass die Leute natürlich ankommen und sagen, naja, euer Pool ist ja so langsam, der findet ja so einen Blog nur alle zwei, drei Tage oder so. Da müsste ich ja so lange auf meine Auszahlung warten. Das stimmt nicht so ganz, weil erstens natürlich, umso weniger Leute bei uns mitmachen, umso größer ist natürlich auch deren Ausschüttung, weil die Menge ist eigentlich immer gleich, weil das wird an Anzahl der Shares festgelegt. Also, ob du beim großen Pool mitmachst, dann kriegst du vielleicht jede Stunde deine Auszahlung, aber die ist auch so klein, dass es wirklich minimal ist. Bei uns kriegst du nur alle zwei Tage dafür dann auch dementsprechend mehr, weil nicht so viele Leute mitmachen. Also das verteilt sich ganz gleich. Aber so eine gewisse kritische Masse braucht man schon, damit es wenigstens zwei, drei Blöcke am Tag sind und nicht alle zwei, drei Tage. Deswegen legt man alle los, damit ich die kritische Masse erreiche. Und unser Vorteil ist noch, muss man kurz zu Ende erzählen, gegenüber anderen Pools ist, wir sind noch klein, wir sind nicht überlastet. Die anderen Pools sind auch mal für eine halbe Minute oder auch mal fünf Minuten sind die nicht erreichbar. Und in der Zeit kann das Mining-Programm nicht meinen. Das heißt, du hast verschwendete Zeit. Dann sind die relativ träge, weil die so trafficmäßig überlastet sind. Und die sagen den Minern, die ja Worker genannt werden, die sagen denen nicht, wenn ein neuer Block gefunden wurde. Weil dann müssen die neue Arbeit holen. Weil mit dem alten Block brauchst du da nicht mehr rechnen, weil das ist ja eine Blockchain. Du musst ja immer anhand des neuesten Blockes rechnen. Und ich hab heute mal gemessen.
Das Brems mal ein bisschen nicht so hier den Dampfpflaren. Dann kommt der gar nicht mehr mit irgendwie. Das ist irgendwie ein Feuerwerk der Fachwörter.
Die Leute können dann später hier in ihrem QuickTime auf die Slow-Taste drücken und das mit 0,9-fach abspielen.
Wenn das jetzt noch zwei Fahrgeschwindigkeit hört, dann würde ich auch gerne.
Wir können ja noch mal ein CIE zum Thema Bitcoin-Mining machen, wenn du möchtest.
Ja, können wir gerne machen. Dann warten wir noch mal so zwei, drei Wochen, dann habe ich alle zusammen und dann können wir los.
Dann gibt es keine Bitcoins mehr.
Dann ist es schon nach Südamerika abgesetzt.
Ist wichtig, dass der Pool halt den ganzen Workern schnell Bescheid sagt, dass es halt einen neuen Blog gibt, damit die halt immer mit den neuesten Daten arbeiten. Sonst, wenn halt einer zufällig einen Blog finden soll, obwohl schon längst ein neuer gefunden wurde, dann ist es ein Invalid-Blog und dann war die sozusagen umsonst die Suche. Und ich habe heute gemessen mit einem anderen großen Pool. Diesem BTC gilt ja 3 Terrahash pro Sekunde. Also das ist echt ein fetter Pool. Der hat gerade 25% des gesamten Bitcoin-Hashing-Power ist gerade bei diesem einen Pool. Was auch nicht so gut ist, weil ab 50% könnte er ja scheiß machen. Weil dann kann er sozusagen das ganze Bitcoin-Netz übernehmen. Das ist gar nicht so gut, wenn es so große Pools gibt. Jedenfalls, wir waren immer circa 15 bis 25 Sekunden schneller im Bescheid sagen an unsere Worker, dass ein neuer Block berechnet wurde. Das heißt dann, BTC gilt in dieser Zeit in 15 bis 25 Sekunden. Wenn da einer von dem einen Block finden sollte, dann war das für die Katz. Und das ist wichtig, dass man da immer...
Ist das viel schneller, 15 Sekunden?
Naja, wenn man berechnet, dass circa alle 10 Minuten im Durchschnitt ein Block gefunden wird und teilweise schneller, weil wir ja immer ein Stück schneller sind als diese Vorgabe, ist das schon... Genau, und man sieht auch bei BTC, wenn man so guckt, sie haben schon so circa 1-2% valid Blocks, die sie finden. Das ist natürlich weiter so riesengroß. Wenn unser Pool irgendwann mal so groß sein sollte, dann wird man auch irgendwann ähnliche Probleme haben, aber noch haben wir die erstmal nicht, da haben wir einen Vorteil. Na erstmal noch gar nichts, weil wir wollen natürlich Leute haben, aber natürlich kann ich das nicht kostenfrei betreiben und dann gibt es halt die Donation und bisher haben wir noch nicht so richtig einen Plan, aber wir denken auch, dass wir so Features anbieten, wie zum Beispiel E-Mail-Benachrichtigung, falls ein Worker nicht funktioniert, ich denke sogar über SMS-Benachrichtigung nach und so weiter, die man sich dann für Prozentpunkte sozusagen einkaufen kann. Also nicht in Bitcoins, sondern dann sagt man, ok, ich hätte gerne SMS-Benachrichtigung, kostet dann ein halbes Prozent von dem, was er da so verdient, so rum. Genau, es gibt dann einfach weniger ausgezahlt, das läuft so nach Prozentpunkten. Das machen die anderen Pools eigentlich auch so. Komischerweise macht glaube ich der DeepBit der größte Pool, den es so gibt, nimmt irgendwie drei Prozent und dafür kriegt man aber auch schon ausgezahlt, egal ob die einen Block finden oder nicht. Weil rein statistisch finden die natürlich Block, aber du kriegst sozusagen schon ausgezahlt, obwohl noch gar nicht bestätigt ist, dass dieser Block wirklich valid ist. Das heißt, die zahlen auch invalid Block aus, aber dafür drei Prozent, das ist sozusagen, die können sich das leisten, weil sie drei Prozent nehmen.
Achso, drei Prozent ist schon viel, ja?
Ja, drei Prozent ist das höchste, glaube ich. Also BTC gilt, nimmt null Prozent, außer du machst irgendwie, willst Early Payout haben, also auch von den noch nicht, also noch nicht von den Blocken, die schon eine Confirmation haben. Beim Generieren sind das 120, da brauchst du 2,5 Prozent Donation. So, das war jetzt ein Feuerwerk.
Aber sag mal, woher kommen denn die 4.400 Active Workers?
Das sind die Round Shares, das sind 44.000 Shares pro Block. Wir müssen die Welt retten, denn das Bitcoin-Universum scheint von einem einzigen Pool übernommen zu werden.
Nee, von drei Pools.
Aber ist das jetzt schon so gewachsen, gerade waren es noch 3,5 Gigahertz, jetzt sind es schon 3,8, kann das sein?
Das schwankt ein bisschen, weil das ist ja nur so estimated. Ich hab da Experten aus Osteuropa im Staat, die Mathe im Blut haben und wir wollen nicht die gleichen Fehler machen wie die anderen Pools, weil die haben teilweise 30 Millionen Einträge in ihrer Datenbank täglich und haben da ein Problem gegen anzukämpfen. Wir haben das ein bisschen schlauer geregelt und das machen meine osteuropäische Mathematiker.
Was? Die Schätzung?
Naja, die Anpassung. Die Schätzung schwankt dadurch ein bisschen, aber wir sind dadurch, unser CPU ist reichlich weniger belastet und wir können viel mehr handeln. Und das ist wirklich so.
Und die 20 Worker oder 30 seid ihr jetzt erstmal alles?
Nee, ich hab vorhin schon mal vor announced hier im Chat.
Also, wenn sozusagen jemand ganz viel Grafikkarte bei sich zu Hause hat, aber irgendwie diese 3D-Ballerei immer auf dem Sämpf geht...
Oder halt gerade mal nicht zockt und schlafen geht. Oder dringt ein bisschen stromlos werden muss. Nicht den Rechner meinen lassen, der neben einem am Bett steht, und schlafen gehen, das ist einem passiert. Das war wohl nicht so gut. Da gibt es irgendwie so einen Pfeil wohl. Ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Urban Legend ist. Aber da hat einer sein Miner gestartet, hat sich pennengelegt, da waren keine Ahnung, 50 Grad im Raum die ganze Nacht, und der hatte wohl Schäden davongetragen.
Der musste dann in die Notaufnahme, weil er total dehydriert war.
Also 50 Grad Eiweiß ab 42 Grad macht ein Problem. Und das ist wohl echt nicht gut. Ich weiß nicht, wie warm es war, aber er hatte Schäden davongetragen. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Urban Legend ist, aber don't do it.
Dann solltest du bei der Anmeldung so einen Flag haben. Ich bestätige, dass ich...
Nicht in meiner Meinung nachschlafe.
Bitcoin ist gefährlich für die Gesundheit.
Genau.
Oh meier. Also wer Lust hat, an Datenspaß mit Denis und Rockhard hier mal so ein bisschen die Weltregierung zu übernehmen und die anderen Pools in die Ecke zu stellen. Was ist das Ziel?
Einfach auch einen coolen Pool sein. Weißt du, als Hacker will man ja auch immer Provider von coolen Sachen sein. Ich kann nur erinnern an Huckels World. Wie war das? Was war das? Weird World. Das war schon eine coole Zeit, oder? Hast ja leider nicht weitergemacht irgendwann. Aber wenn man immer irgendwie so ein Ding hat, was auch so ein Eigenleben führt irgendwann, weil dieses Weird World hat ja auch Huckel nicht den Content reingemacht, sondern andere, richtig? Irgendwann lebt das dann und das ist schon irgendwie cool. Das ist mit diesem Pool halt auch so. Der lebt halt irgendwann von alleine. Das ist so eine Datenmark, die so vor sich herläuft und diese Ausschüttung macht und Payouts macht. Und kannst dann Urlaub fahren, kommst du wieder und das Ding läuft vielleicht immer noch, hoffe ich. Und all sowas. Ich finde das cool. Man will ja auch so seinen Beitrag leisten.
Ja, Bitorrentrecker hast du ja auch schon vorgelegt.
Bitorrentrecker, genau, habe ich auch schon gemacht. Oder iSac. Aber nur kurz war Apple, fand ich nicht so toll.
Ja, hast schon so einige Kerben im Holz.
23 Worker jetzt hier. 4 Giga-Hashes.
Die rechnen auch, also 4 Giga-Hashes hatten wir vorhin auch schon. Die rechnen da nicht, die haben nur Worker im Start. Die müssen doch mal die dicken Grafikkarten an den Start bringen.
Was muss man denn da jetzt installieren, um das irgendwie alles zum Laufen zu kriegen?
Na das Problem ist, man braucht, auf Mac ist es ein bisschen schwierig, weil auf dem Mac gibt es die Software nicht so, aber ich poste nochmal, wie man das auf dem Mac aufsetzt. Auf den neuesten MacBook Pros, da geht es, weil die halt eine AMD-Karte haben, da kommt man so auf 44 Mega-Hashes. Aber mit so einer ATI-Karte kommt man schon auf 300-400 Mega-Hashes und die braucht man. Das ist eher schon so eine PC-Windows-Geschichte. Oder Linux. Die ATI-Treiber, also OpenCL wird da viel benutzt, gibt es halt unter Linux auch. Das ist eigentlich sehr schick. Deswegen mein Bild war ja auch Linux.
Ich hab ja noch eine relativ alte AMD-Karte drin, glaube ich.
Ja, das ist dann so ein 4800er oder sowas.
4850.
Ja, die tut es auch.
Ja, was muss ich dann installieren?
Na, ich hab hier im IRC gerade so einen Link gepostet. Du müsstest erst mal Boost bauen. Das dauert erst mal ewig. Dann müsstest du PyOpenCL bauen. Dann müsstest du JasonPython irgendwie bauen. Und dann bist du auch schon fertig fast. Also ich hab das alles über Brew gebaut.
Was ist das denn für ein Link?
Sag mal, Brew install was? War das das erste?
Das ist das falsche.
Das ist irgendwie eine Pornosammlung hier oder was?
Nee, das ist ja auch nicht von mir. Das hier ist von mir. So, das da.
Jetzt unten.
Du hast den falschen Link geklickt.
Genau. Da hat einer mal das zusammengebaut, wie man das baut. Also man muss sich erstmal den Boost bauen. Dann PyOpenCL muss man sich bauen. Das ist ein Typ, der halt OpenCL für Python implementiert hat. Also dass Python halt OpenCL-Programme, hier so eine Kernels irgendwie starten kann. Dann muss man sich Python-Json-RPC bauen.
Ey, jetzt nicht auf dem Aufnahmerechner Boost bauen. Der baut auf allen Kern und nimmt sich alles, was er was bei drei auf dem Boll, also nicht bei drei auf dem Boll macht.
Ja, das bringt dein System in die Knie.
Haben wir jetzt gleich auf?
Ja, danach können wir es locker machen. Du kannst es ja mal so stehen lassen. Dann machen wir es dann, wenn die Werbung fertig ist. Dann können wir gucken, was deine Karte so kann. Und die müsste schon ordentlich was können, weil unser Laptop hier mit 44 Megahash ist ja halt eben eine Laptop-Grafikkarte. Dein Ding ist ja schon so eigentlich...
Guck mal, da steht ja sogar...
Ist keine...
4850.
Und das ist genau die, die du hast?
Ja, 58000.
58 Megahash, naja, das ist auch nicht so viel besser. Was?
5,8 Megahash?
58000 Kilo ist, was 58 Megahash entspricht.
Also 58 Megahash, okay. Oder ist das gut?
Ne, das ist relativ wenig. Wie gesagt, so eine fette Grafikkarte schafft so 400 Megahash.
Übertakteste halt ein bisschen.
Klicks für ein Öl.
Oder so, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, aber ich find das immer so cool, wenn ich mal so ein paar Cent verdiene, einfach mal mit ein bisschen Mining. irgendwas.
Könnte es ein paar Millibitcoins...
Na, in ein paar Jahren ist das bestimmt bei irgendeinem Hacker-Umfragebogen ist dann auch so eine Checkbox mit. Wann hast du den ersten Bitcoin? Ja, ja, oder wie viel hast du überhaupt mal? Mindestens einen Tala gemacht. So, da hast du irgendwie echt Street-Cred. Da kann ich auch noch so als Hacker-Opa irgendwie durch Straßen laufen. Ich hab im ersten Jahr gleich noch drei Tala gemacht.
Ich sag nur TU Berlin Multi-User Dungeon.
Irgendwann gibt's gar keine neuen Bitcoins mehr.
2033.
Gehörst du noch zu den Leuten, die überhaupt welche gehabt haben?
Vielleicht bricht auch morgen alles zusammen und wir hatten alle eine kurze Zeit dicken Spaß und ich kann dann endlich...
Mich erinnert das irgendwie an diese crazy Zeit, die wir damals gemacht haben, wo wir die ganzen CPOs haben rennen lassen um diesen MD5... Ja, genau. Die rechnen inzwischen auch mit Grafikkarten.
Aber inzwischen auch nicht mehr. Ich glaub, die sind alle zum Bitcoin-Lager herüber gekommen. Das wollte ich auf jeden Fall aber auch noch ausbilden, weil ich war da früher auch echt dick am Start hier bei Pixelpark. Früher haben wir die Rechner nach Feierabend bei den ganzen Grafikern heimlich Distributed Net gestartet.
Da gingen sie hin, die Gewinne.
Da musst du wieder anfangen bei Firmen zu arbeiten, wo du Zugriffe auf dicke Grafikkarten hast nach Feierabend. Das ist eigentlich sehr schlau.
Das wär's, ja.
So billigen Hausmeister-Job annehmen, schlecht bezahlt.
Dann kommst du da hin und auf den ganzen Kisten laufen schon Bitcoin-Einer.
Ja, dann kriegst du einfach deine Worker-Adresse ein, anstatt die von dem anderen und dann übernimmst du erst mal.
Sie arbeiten ja wirklich sehr gut, aber unsere Stromrechnung ist so gestiegen in letzter Zeit. Klingt mir irgendwie nach einer großen Bitcoin-Blase.
Wer da noch Fragen hat, ich glaube wir haben inzwischen auch leider eine Google-Mail-Support-E-Mail da auf der Seite. Wir müssen natürlich noch unseren eigenen Mailserver aufsetzen, aber dann kann man auch Mails hinschreiben und so. Ist auch auf der Seite.
Nehmen wir noch anonymen hier Google-Mails auch nicht schlecht.
Das war jetzt mal echtes Mac-Thema, ne?
Es ist, muss man sagen, alle Developer haben Macs. Und, naja, wir nutzen FreeBSD, aber es ist schon ganz schön Mac-lastig auch.
Doch, es geht. Du bist tiefer in der Kloschüssel drin als ich.
Und ich muss noch dazu sagen, es wurde kein MySQL verwendet, ja. Also eure Daten sind in guten Händen.
Jetzt hast du dich...
Und alle Evente, ey? Er hat nur sich selbst... Oh, der Tim hat sich totgeschaltet.
Und das, wo ich gerade das One More Thing einkündigen wollte...
Fang doch an, ich meine, kann doch...
Das One More Thing? Irgendwie guck ich gerade erstmal sorgenvoll auf Tims Bild schon mit dem Ableton, wo nichts mehr zu sehen ist.
Erzähl doch mal dein One More Thing.
Naja, das Nokia N9... Wir müssen ja doch noch auf jeden Fall besprechen. Oder nicht?
Also ich find das ja super. Was hältst du davon?
Ja, also das ist das beste Telefon. Ich bin auch der Meinung, dass Nokia auf jeden Fall damit zurückkommen wird. Sie werden es nochmal allen zeigen und Meebo wird die Welt übernehmen.
Erstaunlich, dass... Ich hab Tim noch nie so schnell...
Echt ein Reglant. Er sitzt mit offenem Mund da und schaut das in neuen Präsentationsvideos und kann es kaum fassen.
Also bei Spiegel stand ja auch eigentlich ein cooles Telefon. Es kommt nur irgendwie ein gefühltes Jahr oder zwei zu spät, oder was? Also...
Ich glaub, das schreibt sich aber auch einfach gut. Hat es irgendjemand schon in der Hand gehabt?
Ich hab mir nicht mehr das Video angeschaut.
Also ich hab mir das Video tatsächlich angesehen und ja, es sieht alles ganz hübsch aus, aber ich fand's ja so, weil ja auch gleich eine Petition losging an Hey Nokia, Meebo, nicht sterben lassen, das ist das beste Handybetriebssystem, was es jemals gab.
Was ja schon einiges aussagt, oder?
Ihr habt's noch nicht mal gesehen. Sagt nicht, es sei das beste Handybetriebssystem, wenn ihr es noch nicht in der Hand hattet. Aber irgendwie wäre es auf jeden Fall schöner, wenn es, also besser als dieser Windows-Mobile-Scheiß, das glaube ich alle mal.
Wir können jetzt so in Ruhe über Nokia sprechen und Tim kann nicht mitmachen. Klemmt deine V-Mode auf dem Mute-Button, oder was?
Bestimmt wird Apple jetzt einfach auch auf den Ruhumsteigen.
Ja, also das ist ja auch ein bisschen ein bisschen. Die V-Mode bedient und dann war's plötzlich aus.
Das macht keinen Sinn.
Ja, wir sind eh fertig, oder?
Habt ihr jetzt schon drüber geredet, oder nicht?
Über Nokia, ja. Hast du nicht gehört?
Wir kaufen uns jetzt alle eins.
Genau. Ich hab mein iPhone gerade schon auf Ebay eingestellt.
Lohnt sich doch gar nicht, kriegst du eh nichts mehr für, wo du das jetzt in neuen gibt.
Mein Kumpel hat sich ein iPhone 4 geschoppt bei Ebay. Hat sich ein iPhone 4 geschoppt bei Ebay. Und was dann ankam, war eine Box mit einem Gerät, wo Phone drauf stand. Und der hat halt irgendwie so eine Fälschung bekommen. Und dann wollte er sich bei Ebay auch beschweren. Und dann stand da, das geht nicht, weil der Account wär ja aus Australien plötzlich. Also der muss irgendwie seinen Account nach Australien umgezogen haben oder irgendwie so. Jedenfalls alles sehr mysteriös. Und er musste halt zur Polizei latschen und dort ne Anzeige aufgeben.
Und wie viel hat er bezahlt?
Über 400.
Für so ein Scheiß Schiene.
Dickes iPhone 4.
Und hat er nicht mit Paypal, Käuferschutz und Phone bei ihm?
Nee, ist alles irgendwie ein bisschen unglücklich gelaufen und so weiter und so fort.
Ich leg doch mal hier bei Tim nochmal ein paar Mal auf die Reuspertaste, dann geht das bestimmt gleich wieder.
Was ist denn die Reuspertaste?
Hier der rechte Plus.
Und Timme, wie sieht's aus jetzt bei dir?
Sag mal was.
Timme? Hörst du uns noch? Hören wir dich?
Jetzt tropft es doch in der Tropfenhöhle, oder?
Das ist die V-Mode.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Klingt nochmal auf die Reuspertaste.
Hallo.
Und? Jetzt ist er wieder zu hören. Timme Samrat? Geht doch. Ja, du musst die Reuspertaste festhalten.
Ja, dann klingen wir alle, als ob wir in einer...
Oh, nö.
Verstehe, es geht nur mit Echo. Timme hat seine Stimme verloren. Dann müssen wir die Sendung jetzt...
Aber gleich. Und dann wird es wahnsinnig witzig klingen. Das ist wie Helium inhaliert. Apropos, das können wir mal für die nächste Sendung klar machen. Den Helium-Effekt.
So, ich lass jetzt mal los, den Button. Habt ihr Bock?
Solange wir Tim noch nicht hören, können wir auch über die neue Opera-Version erzählen.
Also ich sag euch, ich bin in der Aufnahme, wenn ich völlig normal zu hören, und keiner wird verstehen, worüber wir die ganze Zeit...
Nee, die sagen, du bist immer nur von ganz weit weg zu hören.
Ja, im Stream, aber die hören auch einen anderen Mix, als den, den ich aufnehme.
Aber auf dem Kopfhörer hören wir auch einen anderen Mix dann, ja? Ja, weil wir hören dich auf dem Kopfhörer auch nicht.
Ich werd jetzt nicht anfangen, euch das Setup zu erklären.
Nein, danke, nein.
Funktioniert das auch, wenn ich die Rolls-Bars-Taste drücke?
Ich verstehe bloß überhaupt nicht, was...
Ich drücke jetzt die Rolls-Bars-Taste, jetzt hör ich dich normal und hab selber ein Echo. Wie schön. Dein OSC oder so ist kaputt.
Oder dein Bitcoin-Minor. Hast du wieder zu schnell auf Final Cut 10 umgestellt, oder?
Also liebe Freunde, da draußen an den Hörgeräten.
Ihr merkt ja, Tim hat seine Techniken hier im Griff.
Es ist zu warm hier, also wir haben auch keinen Sauerstoff hier mehr drin und eine gefühlte Luftfeuchtigkeit von 90 Prozent. Also wahrscheinlich ist das Mischpult jetzt auch einen kurzen oder so.
Das ist ja auch ein Schweißtroff.
Schönen das Mischpult geschrottet. Ich mach mal Fenster auf, das geht ja alles gar nicht mehr.
Wollen wir hier mal das Sendung Ende einladen?
Nee, warte einen Moment.
Das ist ja heißer jetzt bei meinem Pool zu Hause.
Freunde.
Macht noch jemand einen Aufguss?
Ich bin nicht weg, da hört man mich jetzt nicht mehr.
Warte, ich drücke die Reuspart.
Ich mach das jetzt aus.
Ich würde mal sagen, wir machen jetzt mal hier langsam Tschüss. Vielleicht hat Tim irgendwann wieder seine Technik im Griff.
Max, du hast das Schlusswort, ich höre mich auch nicht mehr.
Ich bin ja letztes Jahr auch da. Das ist ja nicht mehr.
Denis auch nicht.
Jetzt bin ich auch gleich weg.
Ist es ansteckend?
Macht euch einen schönen Abend. Ich glaube, wir haben den Rekord mal wieder gehört. Wir sind weit über drei Stunden geblieben, glaube ich. Insofern, tschüss, Winke, Winke. Oh, ich hörte meinen eh nicht.
Die anderen sagen, ihr seid blöde Arschlöcher.
Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.